serait par celui que vous avez présenté
à juste titre comme urgence inattendue
du moment qui a occupé
finalement pas si longuement les débats
du conseil mais qui est un sujet
important c'est le cap polonais je le
précise à l'aune de deux éléments
d'actualité un que vous avez rappelé un
élément de contexte et qu'aujourd'hui
même de prendre la république en ce
moment même le train de la république
reçoit le président de la république
polonaise
ce qui est un signal pour commencer à
répondre à votre question sur l'aspect
juridique ou politique du traitement de
cette question sensible c'est que le
dialogue doit continuer et continue
concrètement le prix à la république
s'était aussi entretenu avec le premier
ministre polonais qui représente son
pays au conseil européen en amont du
sommet jeudi dernier est un élément qui
pour le coup et juridique qui vient
d'être connu c'est que la cour de
justice de l'union européenne à la suite
d'une procédure déjà engagés et qui
n'est pas nouvelle mais qui date du
printemps dernier avec une première
décision au mois de juillet a constaté
que la pologne ne s'était pas mise en
conformité avec la réforme souhaitée de
l'indépendance de la justice et plus
particulièrement des chambres
disciplinaires et à ce titre ayant
constaté l'absence de rectification de
réponse à sa décision de juillet a
imposé une amende d'un million d'euros
par jour ce qui est un montant
relativement exceptionnel et unique mais
exceptionnelle qui marque que cette
procédure continue alors je voudrais
dire un mot de cet équilibre ou des
principes qui sont en jeu car vous
l'avez rappelé on mêle parfois beaucoup
de choses dans la discussion vous
d'abord rappelé peut-être est-ce une
évidence mais c'est important que le
débat qui est en question n'est pas un
débat sur la souveraineté de la pologne
comme d'aucuns états membres
ça va mieux en le disant en est à
choisir souverainement d'adhérer à
l'union peine ils choisissent ou
vraiment d'y rester en l'espèce dans le
cas polonais ce fut même par référendum
que l'adhésion à ces décider a pris
effet début 2004 et tant qu'on est un
état membre quand on est un état membre
on l'a évidemment des droits des
obligations aussi mais un stand le droit
évident important de participations ou
décisions on a parfois l'impression en
écoutant le discours de partenaires
polonais peut il vivrait sous contrainte
extérieure de l'union européenne ou des
partenaires européens ça n'est pas le
cas
cela nous amène à un deuxième constat ou
un deuxième principe la question fameuse
question de la primauté du droit
européen qui a été en effet attaqué dans
non pas le cas que j'évoquais mais la
dernière décision lanières à vis du
tribunal constitutionnel aux polonaises
saisie à la demande du gouvernement
polonais lui-même c'est important parce
que il est évident là aussi mais je
crois qu'il est bon de le démêlés de
notre débat actuel qu'un juge national
tire sa légitimité de sa constitution et
la faire respecter de même qu'un juge
international ou un jeu européen en
l'occurrence doit faire primer le traité
qui lui donne sa légitimité c'est ce
qu'on appelle quand il ya friction quand
il ya tension le dialogue des juges mais
nous savons que notre propre ordres de
juridictions comme en allemagne comme
dans notre pays l'application pratique
de ce principe de primauté pose parfois
un certain nombre de difficultés
ça ça n'est pas nouveau et ça n'est pas
spécifique à la pologne ce qui est
spécifique et la pologne et qui
transparaît clairement dans l'avis rendu
c'est que ce qui a été mis en cause par
le tribunal constitutionnel polonais
c'est l'existence même
de la cour de justice tsj jurisprudence
et même l'article 1er donc l'existence
même de l'union européenne et le
principe de primauté dans toute cette
globalité c'est à dire le fait que
indépendamment des dispositions
constitutionnelles
on doit respecter un principe de
primauté qui est je le répète la
condition du vivre ensemble européen
nous parlions nous parlerons de pêche
cela concerne à un état tiers mais quand
il ya des conflits pour nos agriculteurs
par exemple qui a récemment obtenu
satisfaction devant la même cour de
justice de l'union européenne pour faire
respecter une appellation de champagne
je prends volontairement d'exemples très
concrets
il est important qu'ils puissent faire
respecter ces règles communes par les
autres états membres et la pologne elle
même saisie régulièrement la cour de
justice de l'union européenne encore sur
le fameux règlement conditionnalité en
souhaitant que les règles européennes
qui selon elle en l'espèce ne serait pas
respectée soit pleinement appliqué donc
nous avons besoin de cet ordre juridique
commun le principe de primauté n'est pas
autre chose que le respect du règlement
de copropriété européen qui est fondée
sur notre été et j'insiste parce que ça
n'est pas du tout comparable cette
récente décision polonaise avec ce que
le conseil d'état la cour de karlsruhe
notre juridiction suprême européenne ont
ponctuellement sur la protection des
données sur d'autres sujets soulevés
comme difficulté aujourd'hui ou dans un
passé plus lointain
je crois que ne vont pas céder à cette
comparaison
instrumentalisé parfois par certains de
nos partenaires européens
et puis un troisième point qui est très
important et qui est le coeur du sujet
c'est que ce qui a été mise en question
dans un certain nombre de procédures
juridiques notamment c'est le respect
non pas devenir archi les normes qui
serait débattue mais deux éléments
substantiels de l'état de droit et
fondateur de l'union européenne
notamment l'indépendance de la justice
qui est en cause principalement dans le
débat qui nous occupe c'est que le
tribunal constitutionnel polonais selon
le pas selon la france où selon moi
selon la juridiction européenne selon la
commission européenne n'est pas
indépendant mais cela a été constaté à
plusieurs reprises y compris dans la
décision récente que j'évoquais à
l'instant donc je voudrais qu'on aimait
vraiment le sujet de souveraineté qui
est un incontesté je suis et primauté
qui doit être respectée avec les
précisions que j'apportais et puis un
problème fondamental qui est celui que
l'on constate en pologne le manque
d'indépendance de la justice faut pas en
faire un sujet bilatérale dans le sens
où nos procédures initiées par la
commission européenne constaté par l'aco
logis sont importantes
mais ne sont pas à combat un match d'un
état contre un autre que quelques états
contre un autre encore moins j'insiste
aussi de tels
pays contre tel autre pays ou contre un
peuple contre une société sommes pas en
train de faire le procès des polonais
nous sommes en train de contester
collectivement le respect le non respect
de principes essentiels nécessaires à la
vie du projet européen par le
gouvernement polonais ou certaines
juridictions non-indépendance c'est cela
qui a été en question le débat n'a pas
lu ce degré de détail au conseil
européen mais les interventions je crois
avait ce contexte en arrière-plan et il
est très important me semble-t-il a
rappelé et pour aller à votre question
directement on doit voir je crois qu'il
ne faut pas s'en excuser ou sans cash et
des procédures communes de la commission
juridique la cour de justice parce que
quand on nous sommes une union de droit
le miracle européen pour le lire
politiquement c'est que nous avons
remplacé les rapports de force prend des
rapports de droit et on doit défendre
cela c'est un choix c'est un outil
juridique au service d'un projet
politique et parfois on nous dit même l'
inverse à juste titre je l' ai constaté
plusieurs fois devant votre commission
que l'europe est parfois un couteau sans
lame un couteau sans manche auxquels il
manque la lame et donc on peut pas dire
cela et en même temps
s'excuser ou se désolait qu'il y ait des
procédures jury pour faire respecter in
fine et un certain nombre de principes
mais cela ne va pas empêcher parce que
cela est la responsabilité des
gouvernements du prix en la république
participants au conseil européen de
maintenir un dialogue car l' issue à ce
problème de fond ne sera évidemment pas
dans le simple procédure aussi
nécessaire soit elle et je crois qu'ils
complètent un dialogue d'une pression
politique qu'on doit exercer qui encore
une fois n'est pas une punition de la
pologne une mise au banc d'un pays d'une
société mais la volonté de faire tenir
bon l'europe sur ses principes sans
lesquels
tout discours sur la puissance
européenne la crédibilité internationale
serait à mon sens 20 si nous sommes
capables de faire d'abord respecter
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens nos
principes à l'intérieur de cette famille
politique
c'est en quelque sorte ce message
dialogue et fermeté que le président a
tenu à illustrer en parlant pr ministre
polonais directement comme la
chancellière allemande angela merkel
d'ailleurs mais en rappelant les
messages de respect de l'état de droit
et en soutenant la commission européenne
dans l'activation d'un certain nombre de
procédures et demain dans la mise en
oeuvre du règlement dit conditionnalité
qui je le rappelle aussi a été actée
dans son principe à l'unanimité des
états les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement lors du sommet européen
consacré au plan de relance en juillet
2020 donc il n'ya eu de mauvaise
surprise ou de mauvais coups adressé à
aucun état membre à cet égard
voilà pour le contexte j'ai été un peu
long mais je pense qu'il était important
de le leur rappeler plusieurs autres
enjeux extrêmement important très
différents mais également importantes
été abordée à l'occasion de ce sommet
européen la question de l'énergie avec
évidemment une dimension de court terme
la hausse des prix les mesures de
pouvoir d'achat la commission européenne
a encouragé puisque cela relève des
états membres de chacun des états à
prendre des mesures de soutien au
pouvoir d'achat d'urgence ce que la
france a fait vous connaissez l'arsenal
de mesures en matière de gaz
d'électricité désormais de carburant et
que d'autres pays selon des modalités à
ses proches qui varient parfois l'outil
fiscal parfois l'outil budgétaire
souvent une combinaison des deux est
mise en place en italie en espagne je
dois souligner que rentre pas dans le
débat sur la mesure elle même qui
dépasse ma juridiction si je puis dire
mais la france sur le point spécifique
des carburants est l'un des premiers
pays avant l'allemagne avant d'autres à
avoir mis en place une mesure sur les
tristes et le gaz donc beaucoup d'autres
pays ont pris des mesures à peu près en
même temps que nous sur les carburants
nous sommes plutôt en avance et je
croirais actif sûr en tout cas l'idée de
prendre une mesure et la mise en oeuvre
d'une mesure et puis a été débattue la
question le plus long terme qui est la
transition énergétique et le rôle des
différentes énergies en europe deux
points sur ce sujet ont été
particulièrement évoqué débattue la
question
du bouquet énergétique et la question
sensible évidemment de l'énergie
nucléaire pour être tout à fait direct
et ce conseil européen a été positif sur
cette question puisque jamais comme l'a
rappelé le pr la république à l'issue il
n'y avait eu un consensus ou plus
exactement une approbation large pour
être plus précis aussi forte et aussi
fédératrice sur l'idée que la neutralité
carbone pour 2050 la réduction des
émissions de -55% en 2030 pouvait nous
disent penser
collectivement au niveau européen du
nucléaire on a besoin on ne peut pas
exclure le nucléaire si on veut
atteindre ses objectifs climatiques cela
a été reconnue même par des pays qui eux
ont fait le choix national qui est
respectable de ne pas utiliser ou de
sortir de l'énergie nucléaire
il ya une vingtaine d'états membres dont
les dirigeants chefs d'état de
gouvernement ont dit ils étaient filés
il est un fait que on ne peut pas
exclure l'énergie nucléaire si on veut
tenir des objectifs de neutralité
carbone 2005 en tout
une vingtaine parce que je les
expressions qui était plus ou moins
explicites
on a dans les états qui n'ont pas signé
cette vision des états amis n'ai-je pas
les à la position des allemands alors je
suis il ya deux états pour être très
clair qui font de ce sujet un combat
important et qui ne veulent pas que le
nucléaire soit reconnu pour eux-mêmes
évidemment mais même pour les autres
c'est le luxembourg et l'autriche et
puis l'allemagne dans une position
intermédiaire à tous égards d'abord
parce que le gouvernement est en
transition et parce que sans trahir de
secret des délibérations la chancelière
merkel n'a pas une position d'opposition
frontale mais a laissé ce débat ouvert
au gouvernement suivant donc ce sera
encore une discussion à mener pour être
très honnête et très clair mais la
commission européenne a indiqué y
compris publiquement qu'elle prendrait
rapidement les mesures les propositions
ce qu'on appelle techniquement l'acte
délégué de la taxonomie pour que dans
les investissements privés qui
permettent d'atteindre la transition
écologique et la neutralité carbone le
nucléaire puisse être inclus ce combat
n'est pas terminé je suis très clair
avec vous on nous attendrons le voir les
preuves d'amour au delà des quelques
mots sur cette inclusion de l'énergie
nucléaire dans les outils les
transitions et l'investissement privé
mais cela est déjà une avancée
importante et un changement de nature du
débat que la crise énergétique
évidemment à accélérer le deuxième point
qui était important ne serait plus
rapide c'est là le fonctionnement du
marché unique et la fixation des prix au
sein du marché unique européen de
l'énergie
avec je crois à la nécessité de
distinguer deux choses ce fut le message
du train de la république l'idée d'un
marché unique intégrée interconnecté
avec des prix commun est une bonne chose
que ne vont pas remettre en cause sa
fait partie des éléments positifs du
marché unique y compris favorable
industriellement à la france puisque edf
en particulier exporte
dans le marché européen massivement et
quand les prix augmentent les prix de
gros augmente c'est un avantage
concurrentiel puisque nous produisions
moins chère que la moyenne européenne
et cela permet de financer notre
tragédie dans notre trajectoire
d'investissement notamment ceux qui ne
convient pas c'est que le lien entre ces
prix de gros selon la règle de la
dernière centrale mise en service si je
puis dire et les prix des consommateurs
est trop directe et les mécanismes de
régulation des prix pour les
consommateurs
existe aujourd'hui tant mieux mais sont
mises en question mise en cause parfois
par la commission européenne donc savon
au niveau français sur le fameux
mécanisme à rennes est ce que cette
crise montre c'est que nous avons besoin
de garder au sein du marché européen des
outils de régulation des prix pour les
consommateurs
sinon lorsqu'il ya des bosses dans une
trajectoire d'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie comme on le fait en ce moment
nous ne pouvons pas agir et ne pouvons
pas nous priver de ces instruments cela
fait l'objet aussi d'un large consensus
et une étude a été commandée la
commission européenne pour identifier ce
qui fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne
pas il doit être changée dans les fonds
le fonctionnement pardon la formation
des prix sur le marché unique de
l'énergie je crois que c'est important
qu'on ait reconnu cette difficulté
ce fut l'essentiel d'ailleurs des débats
la question de l'énergie où vous avez
dit à juste titre monsieur le président
que la question sanitaire
tant mieux a été moins centrale dans les
débats alan est emmené en moins et
évoquer rapidement la fois sur le volet
international les dons de doses de
vaccins aux pays étrangers la france est
aujourd'hui le premier pays européen qui
honore ses engagements de dons à
l'initiative kovacs et je crois que nous
pourrons atteindre les 60 millions de
doses promises d'ici la fin de l'année
pour notre pays mais il faut accélérer
ce mécanisme au niveau européen et
international
même si l'europe reste le premier
exportateur mondial de vaccins
aujourd'hui nous devons le souligner
parce que non parfois l'impression que
ce sont d'autres qui communiquent mieux
états unis où britanniques américains et
britanniques qui donne des vaccins
romulo export s'est d'abord l'europe
l'union européenne mais plusieurs pays
ont fait état et je crois que ça doit
nous éclairer dans ce moment sur la
nécessaire vigilance que nous devons
continuer à voir sur l'épidémie avec un
certain nombre d'outils de freinage ou
de maîtrise à commencer bien sûr par le
maintien ou l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination pour les rappels
vaccinaux en particulier et plusieurs
pays je pense à la roumanie ont les
situation sanitaire très difficile
aujourd'hui en europe ou même notre
voisin allemand a eu son taux d'incident
se repasser la barre des 100 peu près de
deux fois le taux d'incidence france est
aujourd'hui dans notre pays nous
constatons nous mêmes nous voyons chaque
jour une légère augmentation du nombre
de cas quotidiens donc ça nous assister
à cette grande vigilance ce fut partagé
par les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
dans ce conseil sans qu'il ait eu lieu
de prendre des décisions particulières
un deux points ont été évoqués gelé
mentionne plus rapidement la question
numérique est important que la viande
est battu tamar et madame la sénatrice
mans a essayé et d'autre avant avant le
sommet et je sais qu'il ya une
proposition de résolution européenne
de madame blatrix compte taille de
madame morin desailly c'est un sujet
très important sur lequel le président
passer un message nous avons besoin
rapidement de muscles et nos outils de
régulation numérique et ceux qui sont en
discussion au niveau européen appelé dsk
et dma pour nous espérons toujours
l'aboutissement sous présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne peuvent être renforcés je
pense notamment aux dsi et l'application
stricte pure et parfaite du principe du
pays d'origine qui confierait au
régulateur
du pays où est établie une grande
plateforme numérique par exemple irlande
luxembourg ne peut pas marcher s'il
n'est pas tempéré parce que cela en bout
viserait les procédures dans d'autres
pays pour les régulateurs sur le petite
taille et allongerait les délais de
réaction qu'on doit retirer un contenu à
caractère terroriste et nous autres et
donc l'idée que la commission européenne
puis dans certains cas avec une
procédure d'urgence se saisir de
certains dossiers pour éviter ce renvoi
de balle et le décision entre
régulateurs nationaux a été mentionnée
par le président pour qu'on est en tout
cas un dispostif rapide et
opérationnelles qui ne soit pas
prisonnier des dogmes que serait celui
du pays du principe qu'il répare dont le
principe du pays d'origine
dans le même état d'esprit c'est à dire
juste régulation et évoqué brièvement la
politique commerciale avec la nécessité
soulignée par le priant de la république
qu'on doive accélérer la modernisation
de cette politique qui doit mieux
prendre en compte en sortant des accords
commerciaux traditionnels dont on
connaît les limites le respect nos
standards alimentaire le respect de nos
standards climatique et accélérer aussi
sur la réforme l'organisation mondiale
de commerce qui fera l'objet d'une
réunion ministérielle dans quelques
semaines le sujet migratoire a été
rapidement évoquée dans son volet
externe avec un point de débat je le
souligne puisque douze pays rejoints par
deux autres après la lettre envoyée à
leurs partenaires et aux institutions
européennes ont demandé que puisse être
financé des infrastructures de
protection des frontières en allant
jusqu'à évoquer très précisément des
grillages barbelés grillages barbelés
agrémenté pardon pour ce détail
technique mais d'importants de l'âme il
faut être très clair le frein de la
république l'a dit ainsi comme madame
von der leyen d'ailleurs tenir notre
frontière extérieure nous en avons
besoin et nous l'assumons
je me suis rendu récemment à la
frontière entre la lituanie la
biélorussie j'ai pu constater qu'il y
avait une menace migratoire organisé un
trafic d'êtres humains organisée par en
l'occurrence le régime biélorusse nous
l'avons vu dans d'autres moments avec la
turquie par exemple donc il ne faut
avoir aucune naïveté à cet égard assumer
que nous avons nous sommes en train de
développer une police aux frontières
européennes qui s'appelle frontex et qui
doit sans doute accéléré montée en
puissance plus vite passer d'une police
des frontières européennes qui
maîtrisent nos fournisseurs extérieurs à
un financement européen de grillages
barbelés à lame dans certains pays qui
souvent refusent même les mécanismes de
solidarité européen je crois qu'il ya un
pas que nous ne voulons pas franchir et
nous avons été clairs sur ce point pour
terminer très vite deux rendez vous
internationaux rendez vous
internationaux ont été évoqués à
l'occasion de ce sommet je l'avais
mentionné la com 21 là comme 26 pardon
qui commencent cette semaine et qu'elles
seront là le prendre la république en
fin de semaine la cop 15 qui se tenait
du bronze au 15 octobre qu'en chine et
puis un futur sommet asie europe qui
sera l'occasion fin novembre d'évoquer
la stratégie au pacifique de l'europe
présenté au mois de septembre et enfin
le 15 décembre prochain justement du
prochain conseil européen juste avant un
sommet du partenariat oriental qui est
un sommet souvent assez procédurales
mais qui prendra un relief
significatif particulier avec la crise
qui implique aujourd'hui les autorités
biélorusses je souhaite simplement
conclu en évoquant comme cela a été fait
au conseil européen un point qui était
qui a été ajouté par dont la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme puisque s'est
tenu mi octobre en suède un forum
international pour la mémoire low cost
est un sommet pour la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
je n'ai pas de détails particuliers à
porter simplement que l'union européenne
s'est enfin dotée d'une stratégie de
lutte contre l'antisémitisme et divers
outils
budgétaires de soutien des actions de
mémoire de formation d'éducation et que
nous voyons bien
chaque jour que cela reste
malheureusement un défi européen partagé
enfin monsieur le président je me
permettais en regardant les derniers
développements comment voilà ministre de
la mer sur la question du des licences
de pêche puisqu'une elle sait que je
suis ici absolument et une réunion avec
jersey c'est pour ça que je vérifie
c'est pour ça que je vérifie les
derniers développements
voilà
pardon je le vérifie l'instant donc nous
avons eu ce matin
une réunion supplémentaire avec la
ministre de la mer et avec surtout les
élus des trois régions concernées
président de région ou leurs
représentants
présidents de conseils départementaux
certains maires de villes très concerné
je pense à boulogne en particulier pour
évoquer concrètement car maintenant on
veut est venu être opérationnel des
mesures que nous prendrons à l'égard du
royaume uni
on l'a évoqué parfois contestés nous
avons été très patients je crois que le
fait d'avoir toujours assorti ces
discussions d'une pression la
perspective de mesures de rétorsion a
été utile pour que ce dialogue parfois
reprennent ou s'accélèrent et il a
permis d'obtenir néanmoins des licences
et encore récemment de la part de jersey
enfin le compte n'y est pas nous le
savons et nous devons maintenant pour
des raisons d'efficacité de crédibilité
de soutien d'abord à nos pêcheurs et aux
territoires concernés ont seulement
haussé le ton nous l'avons fait mais
agir et nous avons évoqué ce matin même
avec les élus des territoires concernés
des mesures très concrètes et nous les
annoncerons nos les détaillerons dans
les heures qui viennent avec la ministre
de la mer un communiqué et elles se
trouveront leurs applications en tout
début de semaine prochaine
je précise ce sont des mesures graduées
cela signifie que les premières mesures
que nous mettrons en application dès le
début semaine prochaine pourront être
complétées s'il n'y a pas de geste les
britanniques puisque notre objectif ce
n'est pas de poser des mesures c'est
d'obtenir des licences
et donc la première série de mesures
sera très concrète une forme de logique
de réciprocité puisque les britanniques
ne respecte pas les engagements écrits
ratifié à l'égard de nos pêcheurs de
licences de pêche nous limiterons
strictement les débarque dans les ports
français de produits de la mer
britannique nous procéderons à des
contrôles systématiques
vétérinaire douaniers en particulier et
nous mettrons même en place des
contrôles à l'égard d'autres
marchandises à destination du royaume
uni la semaine prochaine en renforçant
nos procédures et nos contrôles par
rapport à la pratique actuelle
c'est une mesure concrète qui va avoir
un impact sur nos relations commerciales
avec le royaume uni nous l'assumons nous
l'inscrivons aussi dans une démarche
européenne puisque nous avons saisi en
même temps la commission européenne pour
avoir une réunion
deux premiers étages de règlement des
litiges qui s'appelle le conseil de
partenariat avec le royaume uni et nous
avons demandé à la commission européenne
le premier ministre le fera par écrit
dans les heures qui viennent de nouveau
que des mesures de rétorsions
commerciales européennes soient
explorées envisagée mais nous le savons
pour être tout à fait clair et concret
cela prend du temps c'est pour cela que
nous commençons par des mesures
nationales car nous n'avons plus le
temps d'attendre et nous serons très
claire aussi le porte parole du
gouvernement vient de l'indiquer ou leur
préciseront dans les heures qui viennent
je le disais avec annick girardin c'est
une première série de mesures soit cette
première série de mesures donnent lieu
un dialogue et au delà du dialogue et
des licences tant mieux soit ces mesures
ne donne pas lieu à la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord c'est simplement ça comment
donc et nous prendrons d'autres mesures
y compris sur le plan de
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
exemple donc ce sera clair ce sera ferme
ce sera concret et ça commencera en
début de semaine prochaine potions min
si je puis me permettre je dirais enfin
bien sûr et et je m'en félicite que vous
puissiez mettre en place des mesures
concrètes première question immédiate
qui me vient à l'esprit puisque vous
dites turin décalé par rapport aux
mesures européennes
est ce que cette mesure qui concerne la
débarque dans les ports français ne va
pas nous pénaliser et les anglais vont
aller débarquer est-ce que c'est
verrouillé avec les belges et hollandais
etc c'est à dire que il est il est hors
de question qu'on voit de la débarque
diminué en france au profit d'autres
d'autres pays des états membres
c'est ce que nous préciserons les
prochaines heures il ya une discussion
du mystère de la mer avec les homologues
étrangers évidemment pour qu'ils aient
pas d'effet de report
premier point deuxième point nous
sélectionnerons à septembre nous
limiterons les lieux des barques nous en
sélectionnerons quelques uns qui
demeureront des 2 débarque notamment
ceux qui sont soumis aux risques de
concurrence intra-européenne les plus
forts donc luca livreront la mesure dans
les heures qui viennent avant
application en début de semaine
troisième point je le dis parce qu'il
faut être honnête et responsable toute
mesure même ciblé même prenant en compte
ces risques de report a un impact sur la
filière
le mariage en particulier nous
l'accompagnerons nous avons évoqué ce
matin la ministre la mer dans le cadre
des dispositifs existants le plan de
soutien à la filière le fond de la
réserve d'ajustements brookside qui
consacre 600 millions d'euros à la pêche
et je veux le dire malheureusement nous
le savons il n'y a aucune mesure de
réponse ou de rétorsion qui soit si je
puis dire parfaite ou gratuite
nous le faisons pas par plaisir à
l'égard des britanniques ou à l'égard de
ceux qui seront impactées qui feront les
contrôles ou qui les subiront elles nous
le faisons parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autres choix il nous assumons d'avoir
été pédagogue calme je veux rendre
hommage à la profession en particulier
vous connaissez mieux que moi ce cadec
monsieur le président n'aura pas nôtres
parce que ils ont été d'une patience
alors que pour nous c'est de la
négociation pour eux c'est la vie
quotidienne exemplaires
et leur outil de travail et leur vie
tout court et ils ont été
remarquablement responsable je crois que
nous devons de partager ensemble nous
avons échangé régulièrement avec eux
maintenant on ne peut plus tolérer que
cette responsabilité soient prises par
une forme de naïveté pour rester polie
ou des faits paillasson par le royaume
uni et donc nous prenons des mesures
nous espérons qu'elles dureront le moins
longtemps possible toutes ces mesures
sont proportionnées et graduées
réversible mais elle donne un signal
face en demandant les mots mais dans les
actes une grande fermeté nous avons
évoqué ce sujet vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président je vous lui
confiez en arrivant au conseil des
ministres ce matin je ne disais pas par
souci protocolaire mais pour montrer à
quel point ce sujet et pris sérieusement
par le président du gouvernement
une autre petite question et c'est même
pas une question si une remarque c'est
vraiment dommage qu'on soit utilisent
les obligés d'utiliser le fonds
d'ajustement breakes site pour des
mesures de rétorsion que nous imposons
aux finalement c'est ça c'est enfin
c'est pas de votre faute c'est anticiper
je l'entends mais c'est franchement on
arrive à des paradoxes qui sont un outil
qui sont pas acceptables et on c'est de
la faute à qui
passez donc la parole dans l'ordre des
demandes de prise de parole on en a
quelques-unes jusque je vous propose
c'est qu'on prenne part trois questions
comme ça va sur le ménisque peut
répondre et on se souvient de la
première comme ça quand on arrive à la
troisième on à cyrille pelegrin qui est
en ligne et qu'ils avaient demandé la
parole le premier
oui oui cyril
président
entend on n'entend pas bien cyrille
à l'eau
est ce que vous entendez mieux comme ça
- et peut-être oui vas-y très bien merci
monsieur le président de ses ministres
alors ma question a porté sur le
numérique 1 la corée du sud a récemment
approuvé un projet de loi interdisant
aux grandes plate forme de distribution
dominante d'obliger les développeurs à
utiliser leurs propres systèmes de
paiement en effet apple et google par le
biais de l'appstore est de google play
impose aux apps développeurs d'utiliser
leurs systèmes de paiement et prélève au
passage des commissions pouvant aller
jusqu'à 30% de la facture en cas de
refus de développeurs l'application ne
peut alors être distribués la commission
européenne a également considéré qu
apple fait preuve d'abus de position
dominante en prélevant des commissions
plus élevées pour applications rivale de
celle développée par apple mais digital
market act entend donc à l'image de la
loi votée en corée du sud limiter ces
pratiques anticoncurrentielles en créant
de nouvelles obligations pour ceux qu'on
appelle les contrôleurs d'accès ou
gatekeeper les dma sera assurément une
grande avancée en matière de droit de la
concurrence et de régulation du marché
numérique est nécessaire qu'il soit
adoptée dans les plus brefs délais tel
que cela a été souligné au conseil
européen
la question des pratiques
anti-compétitives est toutefois
étroitement lié à la question de la
protection des consommateurs et
notamment des mineurs en effet à ce jour
un mineur peut tout à fait télécharger
une application interdite aux moins de
18 ans par le biais de l'apple store ou
de google plaire alors qu'il est
nécessaire de fournir ces données des
petits dés et donc son âge pour
s'inscrire c'est plate forme de
téléchargement d'applications ces
dernières ne bloque automatiquement les
téléchargements pour les personnes ayant
indiqué qu'elle était mineure en
s'inscrivant et en demandant uniquement
de cocher une case pour attester de leur
majorité
de surcroît sont couverts de faux
prétextes relative à la protection des
données en réalité d'ordre économique et
gatekeeper refuse d'indiquer aux
développeurs d'applications c'est le
consommateur qui va de télécharger l'aps
est mineure
ainsi le contrôle et là j'ai eu 16
heures des utilisateurs ou via nos
applications et non pas au contrôleur
d'accès pourtant si nous faisons le
parallèle avec interdiction de vendre de
l'alcool contrôle de l'âge et bien
effectué par les distributeurs soient
les supermarchés et non pas les
fabricants d'alcool la même logique on
devrait être applicable sur ma chaîne
numérique
d'autant plus que les applications n'ont
absolument pas besoin de l'ensemble des
données du consommateur mais uniquement
de savoir s'ils ont plus ou moins de 18
ans il semble donc indispensable de
travailler ces questions protection des
mineurs en ligne et sur les moyens de
réellement déterminer l'âge du
consommateur en parallèle des travaux
sur le thème
les digital services atteint autres
l'installation en cours d'examen par
l'union européenne mais qui porte cette
fois sur les services numériques et non
pas uniquement les contrôleurs d'accès
cherchant parti a proposé un internet
plus sûr pour les jeunes seulement la
question du contrôle de l'âge semble
largement mises de côté
les conclusions du dernier conseil
européen indique une volonté des états
membres de définir des normes communes
et de s'accorder sur une approche
coordonnée en ce qui concerne à un cadre
européen relatif et une identité
numérique
c'est une très bonne chose cependant la
création d'une identité numérique que
causer de nombreuses difficultés
notamment au niveau de la protection de
la question cyril story ça casse des
contrôleurs
je trouvais donc connaître monsieur
ministre la pression de la france à ce
sujet l'initiation européenne visant à
obliger les gatekeeper à bloquer les
téléchargements sont elles envisageables
de se croiser en attente d'une
initiative à ce sujet la france ne
pourraient pas adopter une législation
nationale à ce sujet enfin la france un
thème déjà dit qu'elle ferait
concurrence est bon secteur du numérique
une priorité lors de sa présence du
conseil européen en soirée t-il de même
concernant le contrôle de l'âge sur
internet merci claire simon les chers
collègues je vais vous mettre au régime
je vais vous mettre au régime de la
cosac c'est à dire 90 secondes pour
poser votre question parce que on a
beaucoup de demandes de prise de parole
et à 15 heures il ya les questions
d'actualité à l'intellect 90 secondes
alors je me faisais mon chrono
non monsieur merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez déjà
quasiment répondu à toutes les
interrogations que j'avais c'était
évidemment par rapport à aux problèmes
rencontrés avec l'application du rexy et
évidemment les problèmes de la pêche
notamment les licences le fait que les
jets reviennent ne crois pas les
licences qui devrait 1,3 yeoh aux
pêcheurs français
je partage l'inquiétude
de mon collègue rhin pas sur le mariage
parce que le fait de limiter les
débarquent d'un évidemment impacter
mécaniquement
les marier le mariage à vous disiez que
vous auriez mis en place un système
d'indemnisation à partir du fonds
d'ajustement du du bric site ça pourquoi
pas mais je pense que c'est d'abord je
pense qu'il faut prendre des mesures
c'est ce que vous faites il est temps de
le faire il n'est pas trop tard mais il
est temps de le faire par contre je
m'interroge sur le pourquoi ne
reviendront pas
alors évidemment si on
si on écarte l'article 19 du bric site
qui théoriquement évidemment balaye tous
les accords
antérieurs je rappelle quand même que
l'accord les accords de granville date
de son postérieur à la mise en oeuvre et
la mise en place de la pcp donc on
aurait pu considérer que
l'on pouvait faire du bilatéral encore
une fois avec les britanniques et
remettre en place alain corneau
brouillard c'est vrai que l'article 19
du bric site nous bloque un peu à ce
niveau là mais je pense que c'est quand
même ce serait quand même à terme la
meilleure solution alors est ce que
c'est possible juridiquement je n'en
sais rien mais ce serait sûrement la
solution c'est sans doute la solution
vous a été proposé d'ailleurs par par
les présidents de région enfin j'imagine
parce que c'est négocier directement
avec le gerbier et et des îles
anglo-normandes ce cas était britannique
ça paraît impossible on n'y arrivera
jamais et puis une autre question qui
est en lien direct avec tout ça mais
mais qui est un peu lointaine c'est la
frontière nord irlandaise parce que
c'est quand même le problème le plus
grave on sait que l'accord est
impossible à mettre en oeuvre à ce
niveau là est-ce que vous avez des
précisions et des informations là-dessus
monsieur le ministre et puis juste une
petite remarque bien juste une petite
remarque
vous avez vous avez dit que le président
de la république
avait donc
enfin souhaité avec cette formule
extraordinaire
dialogue et fermeté on est sur le fil de
rasoir
dialogue et fermeté il a eu beaucoup
d'autres avant lui il ya eu beaucoup
d'autres avant lui ont proposé genre de
truc mais c'est pas facile il faudra
bien basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre
voilà merci à l'est on essaie de bien
respecter catherine morin desailly mais
avant je dirais que sur le bilatérales
avant que le ministre réponde très
attentif à la façon dont nous on négocie
et dont les les lignes les hollandais et
les belges négocie
bien merci président sion sujets
numériques qui était un poids important
du conseil européen vous l'avez souligné
monsieur le ministre je vous en remercie
j'ai vu charles michel avait dit qu'il
souhaitait que dans les meilleurs délais
le dma lds à soi donc voilà en action
vous avez beaucoup insisté sur le dessin
je me permets quand même d'insister sur
le débat parce que les deux sont
corrélés en réalité les deux renvois aux
modèles économiques assez désastreux de
ces plateformes qui font qu'on a besoin
dé prendre en tenaille avec les deux
textes donc faut pas non plus se louper
sur le dma et je me vais marier
d'insister sur l'ensemble des
propositions d'amélioration que nous
avions fait monsieur le ministre vous
avez une numération moment je passe à
l'objet pour pousser le lot maximum ses
contraintes autour des plats temps parce
qu'on est quand même sur un système
défensif là on n'est pas sur un système
offensif où on essaye de paliers un à
une absence de régulation n'a pas été
mis en place depuis des années donc je
me permets juste d'insister là dessus
sur le dessin nous rendrons notre avis
début décembre nous continuons nos
auditions nous auditionnons je l'espère
monsieur le président francis haugen qui
a quelques jours voilà
fait l'effet d'une monde sait
aujourd'hui c'est au congrès américain a
fait l'effet d'une bombe elle était à
londres il ya deux jours elle sera à
bruxelles aussi au mois de novembre
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs aussi
au tout ce tahitien un autre sujet dont
j'aimerais très très rapidement vous
parlez on aura peut-être l'occasion
chers présidents d'autres débats avec
vous monsieur le ministre c'est la
boussole numérique et le plan pour la
décennie numérique j'ai essayé de relire
un peu les textes on y voit les
objectifs une méthode en matière de
gouvernance des projets au niveau
multinationaux je n'y vois pas vraiment
l'ambition de quel paysage industriel et
technologique 10 6 d'ici 20 ans et je
pense que ça passe par là aussi les
questions de souveraineté de politique
numérique pour l'union européenne on a
eu ce débat déjà lors du débat palabres
conseil européen mais je préfère manas
là dessus si vous pouvez avoir plus de
précision là dessus l'intention de la
france qu'est ce qu'elle va pas pour
mouvoir ce serait bien à vous monsieur
le ministre pour répondre à ses attentes
trois éléments
merci beaucoup monsieur le président sur
les questions alors pardon si j'ai
manqué quelques mots de schellebelle va
monsieur le sénateur dans la temps là
dedans la traduit dans la transmission
mais je vais vous poser les questions
sur le contenu des aces à d'ailleurs la
question de la responsabilité des
gatekeeper pour le dire en bon français
et puis les contrôles en matière d'âge
heures je reviendrai vers auch aux
contrats en matière d'âge à ma
connaissance ça ne figure pas
aujourd'hui mais je le vérifie ray dans
le texte qui proposait mais j'entends le
point et sur le renforcement des
obligations de ceux qui sont quelque ipr
cela signifie en réalité les plateformes
les plus importantes celles qui parce
que c'est un moteur de recherche ou une
place de marché très importantes ont un
rôle structurant dans le fonctionnement
du monde numérique oui nous sommes en
train justement de renforcer les
obligations j'ai évoqué la question des
contenus pour que la régulation soit
rapide si on veut supprimer un contenu
cela vaut aussi en matière commerciale
pour des produits défaillants pour les
produits frauduleux pour toute une série
de de fraude ou de malveillance sur les
produits qui sont vendus c'est si je le
résumé c'est un texte de renforcement de
la responsabilité des grandes
plateformes au titre des contenus
qu'elle diffuse ou des produits qu'elles
vendent donc on peut refaire un point
avec aussi madame morin desailly sur ces
textes pour bien s'assurer que les
derniers amendements que nous portons
avec cédric au le secrétaire d'état au
numérique sont conformes à vos rapports
précédents et à vos attentes je crois
que nous sommes en ligne sans mauvais
jeu de mots mais on peut le vérifier je
rebondirai du coup sûr la question de
madame la sénatrice mme morin dessailly
sur le dma demander les raisons je
n'oublie pas le des mâles le site - pour
une raison
positive c'est que je pense que son
aboutissement avec intel de qualité en
matière de nouvelles règles
concurrentielles pour les grandes
plateformes est plus facile et c'est
s'il devait
série et les choses par leurs
difficultés je pense que nous aurons
peut-être même sous président slovène
mais plus probable en sus présidence
française un accord sur le dm1 sur le ds
à nous avons encore un travail plus
important parce que le texte qui propose
aujourd'hui et troubat dans son ambition
de régulation pour être clair sur la
boussole numérique vous avez raison ça
fait partie de ces textes de la
commission européenne portée notamment
par le commissaire bretons qui sont
importants mais qui sont une forme de
boîte à outils de différents aux
objectifs ont néanmoins il montre que
sur la question de la régulation sur la
question des cyber attaques sur la
question de la lutte contre
l'illettrisme numérique toute une série
de sujets très différents mais qui vise
à prendre en compte le défi sociétal que
la transition numérique nous avons des
outils européens parfois ce sont de
simples recommandations parfois ce sont
les outils législatifs plus puissants
comme le dsl dès ma seule boussole
numérique elle est maintenant là n'ont
pu utiliser cela comme une forme de
guide en quelque sorte mais il faut la
traduire en éléments concrets à
commencer par ceux des usa et ceux
d'emma
sur les questions
de pêche mais devrait excite plus
généralement monsieur le sénateur québec
vous avez raison je commence qu'à parce
qu'on a moins le moins évoqué le
protocole nord-irlandais c'est
évidemment d'un point de vue européen
plus important encore puisque la cde
l'axé notre marché unique
c'est une violation potentielle mais
caractériser des accords signés frontale
si l'article 16 étaient déclenchées
c'est à dire la suppression de
l'application du protocole je veux
tendre le cou à un mythe ce que nos amis
britanniques répandent régulièrement ils
disent les difficultés de commerce de
contrôle
petites frictions que l'on observe sont
à cause du protocole qui remettraient
par ailleurs en cause à ce titre la
stabilité politique la prospérité de
l'irlande
n'inversons pas les choses le protocole
est une réponse au problème il n'est pas
le problème par ailleurs une réponse
nécessairement imparfaite puisque le
problème est insoluble on veut quitter
l'union européenne sans quitter l'accès
au marché unique ça ce n'est pas
possible donc il ya forcément des
contrôles une forme de frontière quelque
part le protocole l'allège et donne des
outils partager je veux rentrer dans le
détail de contrôle simplifié etc nous
avons en plus proposé c'est dire si nous
sommes de bons élèves coopératif et
sympathique dé flexibilité
supplémentaire il ya quelques jours en
lisant britannique on peut sans doute si
on regarde les die améliorer ou
simplifier les contrôles sur des
produits vétérinaires à ce terrain nous
sommes une bonne volonté j'allais dire
confondante parfois et donc il faudrait
pas que ce soit pris par les
britanniques comme une autorisation de
faire n'importe quoi ce qui ne nous
demandera l'autorisation de faire en
général mais le protocole sip protocole
était un problème les pénuries ne serait
pas du côté de la grande bretagne mais
du côté d'irlande du nord alors il se
trouve que la région de grande bretagne
ou le royaume-uni pardon aujourd'hui
nous avons le moins de problèmes
d'approvisionnement c'est l'irlande du
nord précisément grâce au protocole qui
permet un commerce relativement fluide
avec sur l'ensemble de l'île d'irlande
avec l'irlande membres de l'union
européenne donc je crois qu'il faut être
très prudent là dessus nous sommes prêts
les flexibilités concrètes mais nous ne
sommes pas prêts à remettre en cause le
protocole sur le rexy je crois que j'ai
tout dit je serais prudent sur la bile
des réalisations nous l'avons fait
fonctionnement mais en bonne
intelligence avec la commission
européenne et avec les organisations
professionnelles d'ailleurs ces
dernières semaines via ni jardin qui a
rencontré ses homologues ses partenaires
de jersey mais ne tombons pas dans un
risque de militarisation trop grand qui
comme le rappelle pris en main pourrait
nous sortir du cadre européen avec des
effets de non coopératifs avec la
belgique l'irlande à d'autres pays et
puis surtout ne tombons pas dans le
panneau britannique si je peux dire de
séparer nos pêcheurs français entre eux
parce que pour moi le combat est commun
il l'est d'ailleurs je le sais le vote
relève est aussi entre
aujourd'hui principalement de régions ou
de zone les hauts de france où là nous
avons trois des six 12000 majeures et
les îles anglo normandes et donc c'est
ensemble que nous résoudrons nous
résoudrons par des canaux un peu
différent il faut disputer que
l'autorité de jersey mais si on
résolvait le problème avec jersey nous
n'aurions pas n'aurait fait qu'une
petite partie du chemin qu'une partie du
chemin parce que nous avons tout le
problème boulonnais en particulier
évidemment pas résoudre et nous
défendrons l'ensemble de notre filière
pêche quand tous ces régions ça va de
soi nous prenons des mesures nationales
appliqué au 2 novembre je les dis parce
qu'on ne peut plus attendre nous les
signalons la commission européenne nous
inscrivons dans un cadre européen
nous demandons en même temps le conseil
de partenariat les mesures de rétorsion
européenne mais nous ne faisons pas
dépendre la protection de nos pêcheurs
de procédure trop longue
merci monsieur le ministre alors dans
l'ordre andré gattolin se prépare jean
yves le conte et victorin lurel
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
après avoir salué la la la solidarité et
l'union des 27 dans les négociations du
bric site on a l'impression que cette
période post briques site et frappés par
des mouvements entre piques au sens
thermodynamique du terme qui sont assez
inquiétants on vous avait parlé de la
question de l'état de droit bien
évidemment du l'acceptation de la
primauté du droit européen sur le droit
national
on a l'impression cependant qu'avec une
partie des pays de l'union européenne on
a une sorte de dialectique entre
solidarité financière budgétaire d'un
autre côté et acceptation des valeurs je
me demande si parfois nous n'allons
peut-être pas trop loin et si je suis
favorable à la conditionnalité
évidemment pour les budgets et les et il
est à d'autres sujets je crois qu'il
faut aussi établir un dialogue de
solidarité politique ce qui se passe aux
frontières du bélarus à l'encontre de
trois pays de l'union européenne et je
vous remercie parce que vous l'avez
souligné
et quand même scandaleux alors on a
tendance à dénoncer haut et fort et
compris la présidente de la commission
la volonté de construire des murs ou en
tous les cas les murs seront construits
mais ils seront simplement pas financé
par l'union européenne mais il ya une
vraie dissymétrie entre la tacc entre
guillemets du bélarus qui utilisent la
migration comme une arme massif de
traite humaine à l'encontre d'un pays
comme une arme hybride et je crois que
nous le disons pas assez haut et fort ce
qui s'est passé avec la lituanie en
quelques semaines 4100 personnes entrées
sur le territoire c'est équivaut à ce
qui se passera en france plus de 100 120
mille personnes qui se retrouveraient
massés aux frontières par exemple
italienne et on aurait bon dos de nous
critiquer en disant vous n'avez pas les
conditions d'accueil il n'ya pas les
camps
nécessaire d'hébergement pour accueillir
les personnes je crois qu'il faut aussi
peut-être temps en temps rendre grâce et
affirmer un peu plus fort notre
solidarité politique parce que à la
dernière réunion de l'assemblée
parlementaire du conseil de l'europe le
30 octobre dernier où on avait un débat
d'urgence sur le sujet il y avait une
mise en équilibre entre le méchant
bélarus condamné monsieur loukachenko
ont dit c'est pas bien et on est content
et dans l'autre côté c'est méchant pays
baltiques et polonais qui ne respectent
pas le devoir d'accueil des migrants
choc un moment il faut qu'on soit assez
prudent si on leur montre cette logique
de solidarité sans accepter des murs en
tous les cas des finances et il faut
bien rappeler que là dessus nous sommes
unis
à l'intérieur de nos frontières
même si nous avons des divergences sur
le reste je sois merci merci andré jean
yves
le ministre je pourrais partager en
grande partie l'analyse que vous avez
développé sur la question du tribunal
constitutionnel polonais mais pas
nécessairement la manière de réagir
parce que la première chose à constater
c'est d'abord ce sont les polonais qui
sont victimes de la situation dans la
mesure où ils n'ont plus de justice
indépendante et c'est des premiers à en
souffrir et quand on voit un certain
nombre de juges qui sont sanctionnés
parce que certaines décisions d'une ils
appliquent des décisions de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne c'est
quand même très très compliqué toutefois
je ne suis pas d'accord sûr
je pourrais rentrer théoriquement en
bout sur la question du principe mais la
difficulté c'est que on doit constater
que le gouvernement polonais s'il a posé
la question de principe c'est justement
pour nous amener sur sûr sûr sûr sur ce
terrain là pour essayer de sortir de la
question des conditionnalités qui ne le
mettaient pas en situation favorable et
je crois qu'il faut surtout pas prendre
les polonais en otage du comportement de
leurs gouvernements aujourd'hui parce
que on constate composants des camps
répondant par des principes à la
question de principe finalement on
organise une convergence de
l'euroscepticisme qui n'est pas de doux
favorable à la manière d'aborder le
sujet dans le fond et ça je voudrais
bien que dans l'action du gouvernement
se soit pris en compte sur le sujet
biélorusse je partage ce qu'a dit andré
gattolin tout en soulignant deux points
c'est d'une part c'est pas parce qu'on a
un sujet avec la pologne aujourd'hui
qu'il faut pas ouvrir un nouveau front
quand il ya une loi qui est ok qui est
qui et qui est voté et qui légalise les
push back et qui est une attaque directe
contre le droit d'asile désolé quel que
soit ce que tu viens de dire alain andré
il faut il faut aussi le condamner par
contre on doit faire on doit être aussi
très claire par rapport à ce qui se
passe bon la biélorussie est un état
passeur toutefois ce qu'on constate de
plus en plus en particulier dans les
hubs d'istanbul et de moscou peut aussi
être problématique parce que finalement
il ya beaucoup de ceux qui arrivent en
biélorussie avec des visas biélorusse
qui passe par ces deux ces deux hubs et
ça demande une opération diplomatique
que concertée de la part de l'union
européenne qui n'est peut-être pas
encore tout à fait à la hauteur de ce
point de vue là merci victor acquis
victorin lurel qui doit être en visio
par des oui oui maintenant invasive rue
entend très bien l'asie vous avez tenté
de tenir les 90 secondes merci
de jean-yves sur la question polonaise
au delà du mouvement de doigt de
l'indépendance de la justice moi me
viennent en tête la situation allemande
lorsqu'on a fait le mls en 2012 qu'il y
avait
de la cour constitutionnelle le
casse-cou qui avait émis un avis
justement contre les décisions de la
banque centrale de rouve et la cour de
justice de l'union c'était un pari avait
donné tort et bien cette cause n'avait
pas hésité à dire que c'est
incompréhensible et qu'on donnait trois
mois à la banque pour se conformer
aux textes ou à l'interprétation qu'il
donnait à ce texte là aujourd'hui le ms
fait encore l'objet de recours
apparemment c'est en bonne voie et on
pensera vendée mais moi je m'étonne que
on traite
cela un peu dans les différences que
l'extra territorialité de la loi
fondamentale allemande ne soit à
questionner remettre constamment la
primauté du doigt parce que ça touche
rien dit on a l'identité
constitutionnelle et au principe dit
l'éternel
allemand est ce que on peut là à voir
une question est dire s quel est
l'avenir la solidité juridique de
l'union la primauté du droit a
constamment remis en cause par nos amis
allemands
merci à vous monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président je
répondrais si vous le voulez bien en
même temps aux sénateurs le compte et au
sénateur gattolin sur la question
biélorusse ce qui est très importante
il faut être clair le puissance c'est
aussi nommer ses adversaires et ceux qui
ne le sont pas l'adversaire il est
simple il est la biélorussie en
l'occurrence je ne mets absolument pas
sur le même plan
le régime de monsieur loukachenko et
ceux qui subissent en premier lieu les
agissements scandaleux de ce régime nous
l'avons vu sur un acte de piraterie
aérienne digne d'un mauvais film mais
qui malheureusement était bien réel nous
le voyons avec un trafic d'êtres humains
je le redis en ces termes car c' est
organisée par la famille lukashenko
d'ailleurs elle-même
directement avec des pays tiers je vais
y revenir en tout cas avec les vols
commerciaux et des circuits organisés et
c'est un trafic insupportable qui vise à
diviser et affaiblir l'union européenne
a en l'occurrence par trois pays qui
sont en effet non seulement la lituanie
conventionnel mais aussi la pologne et
la lettonie
je ne crois pas qu'en s'affaiblissent
une fois que les choses sont nommés
clairement en disant nous y répondons
ensemble moi j'ai toujours défendues
cela nous avons été les premiers la
france a envoyé cet été du matériel
humanitaire certes mais qui était aussi
nécessaire pour que la lituanie face les
deux à la fois protège la frontière
européenne et est depuis ce que ces gens
sont là ce sont des êtres humains qui ne
l'ont pas abandonné j'en ai rencontré en
visitant un camp d'accueil à la
frontière avec la biélorussie ce sont
des gens en immense détresse et donc ils
ont besoin de tentes s'ils ont besoin de
rations de nourriture ils ont besoin de
lits parce que quoi qu'on pense de ce
qu'a fait le régime loukachenko ils sont
là et donc nous devons faire c'est deux
choses à la fois je crois que c'est sale
et les valeurs européennes et je suis
d'accord je n'ouvre pas de polémique qui
met les choses sur le même plan mais que
dans la réponse que nous construisons ça
ne sont pas ce n'est pas avec des
barbelés à lame de rasoir qu'on va
résoudre le problème et ce n'est pas
avec des refoulements ou avec parce que
c'est aussi une préoccupation loi d'état
d'urgence appliquée en pologne qui ne
permet pas par exemple à la presse
d'accéder à une vaste zone tout
simplement pour vérifier ce qui s'y fait
donc notre réponse aujourd'hui de tête
fermes collectives les sont encore
insuffisamment je pense aux outils
frontex notamment qui peuvent être
déployées la lituanie a fait appel nous
l'offrons aussi à la pologne ou la
lettonie s'il le ciel le souhaite mais
dans le respect de ce que nous sommes
comme zéro comme européens car le piège
dans lequel le faire tomber loukachenko
nous l'avons vécu avec la turquie est
autrement c'est me dire c'est vous qui
ne voulez pas des migrants c'est vous
qui les maltraiter c'est vous qui ne
respectaient pas les grands principes
dont vous réclamez donc on doit être
impeccable ferme et humains dans cette
réponse sans commencé le jeudi je crois
que nous partageons et vous avez raison
vous le soulignez monsieur le sénateur
dans ce trafic d'êtres humains savamment
organisée malheureusement il y a aussi
une action européenne a menée vis-à-vis
des liaisons aériennes les aéroports ou
des pays les compagnies qui permette
l'arrivée en biélorussie et ensuite
l'acheminement puisque c'est organisé
comme cela vers les frontières
européennes nous l'avons fait avec le
service européen d'action extérieure je
crois que là on a une vraie politique
européenne de sécurité qui s'est mise en
oeuvre en permettant la lituanie a
souligné d'ailleurs l'efficacité de
cette action commune de suspendre un
certain nombre de vols notamment depuis
l'irak mais il ya encore des actions
menées par ce que le régime s'organise
savamment par la turquie par dubaï qui
nécessite un effort diplomatique
européen d'accompagnement de ces trois
pays pour éviter que cela
continue à se prolongea se prolonge
pardon et pour finir sur ce point qui
est très important c'est un problème
collectif c'est pas seulement des mots
nous nous voyons d'ores et déjà
l'allemagne à 4000 personnes qui vit à
la pologne sont arrivés sur son
territoire donc quand bien même on
dirait c'est loin cela ne nous concerne
pas vraiment c'est faux ça nous concerne
directement au delà du test européen que
cela représentait auquel nous devons
fermement répondre mais je crois qu'on
peut être tout à fait ferme sans dériver
vers des pratiques qui ne serait pas
conforme à ce que nous défendons sur la
question sur la question polonaise de
monsieur le sénateur partage aussi ce
que vous avez dit
toujours être nuancée dans l'expression
ça fera sourire le sénateur cadec sur
dialogue et fermeté mais c'est un peu ça
on le voit bien dire que c'est pas un
pays où un peuple qui est en cause que
nous ne jouons pas les instituteurs à
l'égard du peuple polonais de la société
polonaise dont d'ailleurs nous voyons ce
sont les enquêtes d'opinion mais elle
semble traduire une réalité profonde que
80 % des polonais veulent évidemment
rester dans l'union européenne que deux
tiers des polonais pense que la pologne
doit revenir sur des réformes le
gouvernement polonais de revenir sur les
réformes pour répondre aux valeurs et
aux exigences européennes et
c'est un vaste débat mais je crois que
nous défendons ses valeurs européennes
et l'adhésion à l'europe dans ce pays et
dans ses sociétés en montrant que
l'europe apporte des bienfaits
budgétaires et autres mais deschamps
elle même ses valeurs et à leurs côtés
quand leur gouvernement remet en cause
l'indépendance de la justice qui n'est
pas une vieille lune mais qui est une
garantie d'abord pour le polonais
certains
à l'extrême droite de notre pays s'érige
en camarades
des dirigeants parfois les plus radicaux
moi je prétends qu'en faisant cela c'est
nous qui défendons les polonais parce
que ils ont droit comme nous à
l'indépendance de la justice ils ont
droit comme nous l indépendance des
médias etc dans le pacte européen sur
les questions que soulevait en parlant
d' état de droit monsieur le sénateur
lurel jeu quand même être
un peu plus nuancé
il y à des décisions qu'on peut juger
problématique à l'égard de l'ordre
juridique européen le la cour l'otan le
trou comme dans d'autres pays que
l'allemagne et que la pologne mais c'est
un cas qui est objectivement très
différent et je ne fais pas de double
standard que celui que nous vivons en
pologne puisque d'abord ce n'est pas les
principes même fondateur de l'union
européenne et sur le juridique qui sont
attaqués l'article 1 ou l'article 19 qui
sont menacés par l'anp qui sont
contestés dans la vie du trim et le
consuel police n'a jamais été le cas en
allemagne ou en france ou ailleurs
que quand cette décision se sont
matérialisés il y eut ce qui montre bien
que tous les pays sont concernés des
procédures engagées parfois par la
commission européenne ça nous fait pas
plaisir mais la commission européenne au
titre de la primauté du droit engager
ces trois dernières années une procédure
contre la france est une procédure
contre l'allemagne à la suite de la
décision de mai 2020 de karlsruhe sur la
solidarité budgétaire
et ni l'allemagne la france et d'autres
pays on en fait
une forme le combat politique
quand l'art et de karlsruhe a été rendue
début mai elles 2020 pour dire
les programmes monétaires européens
peuvent poser problème il faut que ce
soit les décisions politiques sur le
plan budgétaire le gouvernement allemand
a dit nous prendrons nos responsabilités
à cet égard et c'est l'un des facteurs
qui a contribué à l'accord sur le point
de relancer la solidarité budgétaire
c'est à dire c'est que les principes qui
sont mises en cause les procédures qui
sont appliquées la position politique de
gouvernement sont très différents dans
le cas allemande dans le capot les ailes
je me suis pas l'avocat ici de ce que
fait la cour de karlsruhe parce qu'on
pourrait contester certains de ses
principes mais où la tonalité d'un
certain de césar et ça ne m'appartient
pas non plus de le faire mais on est
dans un cas objectivement très différent
de ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui en pologne
où là c'est l'indépendance de la justice
qui peut être mise en cause voilà pour
cette audition de clément bonne le
secrétaire d'état en charge des affaires
européennes il répondait aux nombreuses
questions des sénateurs après le conseil
européen et notamment aux tensions entre
la pologne et l'union européenne sur
fond de respect des valeurs de l'état de
droit c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi dans un instant
c'est l'heure de sens public votre
émission de débat et de décryptage de
l'actualité a présenté par thomas hugues
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur public sénat
la légalisation du cannabis
est-ce que c'est envisagé c'est drôle
c'est la merde on va pas légaliser cette
mère
le cannabis est une drogue y
aussi un médicament on a tous les
patients extrêmement douloureux pour
lesquelles on est désespéré j'avais mal
aux articulations
quasiment au plus mal on traite pas en
appel
on accompagne
je suis tout à fait favorable à cette
expérimentation ça va ouvrir des portes
j'ai pensé et permettre ensuite à faire
de vraies recherches sur ces produits de
thérapeutique pour être produit en
france il ya trois ans les politiques
nous avait écoutés il y aurait déjà des
producteurs de thérapeutiques
actuellement c'est des producteurs
étrangers qui vont produire
légaliser le cannabis médical samedi à
21h sur public sénat
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue ses sens public que votre
rendez vous quotidien de débats et des
analyses sur public sénat trois temps un
thème d'actualité est la rubrique les
électeurs ont la parole et puis notre
débat volontairement plus prospectif
décalé de l'actu si les titres de ce
mercredi 27 octobre la grande crise de
l'hôpital public une enquête flash menée
par jean-françois delfraissy le
président du conseil scientifique révèle
que 20 % des lits sont fermés faute de
personnel le ras-le-bol des soignants et
ses conséquences politiques à venir
juste après ses titres il a fallu que la
région des hauts de france menacent la
sncf de ne plus payer pour qu'elle
obtienne des renforts d'urgence pour ces
ter ce sera le thème des électeurs ont
la parole avec un représentant des
usagers évidemment et le vice président
de région et puis idées neuves ou idées
courtes chaque semaine avec cette
question dans ce sens public on passe au
crible les promesses de la campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui c'est le
travail et moins qui réunit presque
toute la gauche dany d'algos à jean luc
mélenchon en passant par yannick jadot
on évoque le passage au 32
par semaine 20 ans après martine aubry
c'est son difficile de parler d'une idée
neuve mais est ce pour autant une idée
courte le débat tout à l'heure mais
d'abord celi qui ferment dans nos
hôpitaux publics faute de personnel
soignant lassitude passagère ou crise de
sens avant de donner la parole à nos
experts le débat c'est est à la une de
libération les révélations libé
synthétisée par jérôme rabier
c'est un chiffre au choc révélée par nos
confrères de libération 20 % des lits
des hôpitaux ne seraient pas utilisés
faute de personnel soignant pour les
ouvrir ce chiffre vient d'une enquête
flash réalisée par le professeur
delfraissy qui est à la tête du conseil
scientifique chargé de proposer des
solutions à l'exécutif pendant la crise
du coc vide olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé ne nie pas l'ampleur du
phénomène mais jurent de tout faire pour
y pallier et rappelle les hausses de
salaires décidées lors du ségur de la
santé beaucoup de nos soignants sont
épuisés par la charge mentale et le
rythme de travail de la crise avec un
ségur je leur donne un cap et des
raisons de tenir de l'autre côté
j'active tout ce qui peut pallier le
manque d'effectifs alors que l' enquête
flash porté sur 16 chu et chr le
gouvernement promet prochainement une
étude nationale sur le sujet mais
rappelle qu'avant la crise 10 % des lits
étaient déjà fermés malheureusement cela
fait des années que notre hôpital
souffre de manque de personnel qui nous
contraignent à ne pas pouvoir ouvrir
tous les lits nous rencontrons encore
des difficultés de recrutement des
problèmes d'absentéisme de démission
surtout après la crise et surtout chez
les paramédicaux au groupe communiste du
sénat on juge que c'est encore et
toujours la logique comptable qui
fragilise l'hôpital public et une
politique du gouvernement qui est de
fermer des lits parce que c'est toujours
pour affaiblir l'hôpital et puis des
conditions de travail qui font
qu'aujourd'hui les personnels
hospitaliers quitte l'hôpital parce
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus en attendant
que de nouveaux personnels soient formés
ou recruter la crise risque de
s'installer dans la durée et
concrètement pour les patients allonger
les délais de prise en charge au
multiplié les reports pour des
interventions
la crise de l'hôpital public je vous
présente mes invités et nos experts pour
ce soir patrick peloux bonsoir à médecin
urgentiste à l'hôpital necker à paris
président de l'association des médecins
urgentistes hospitaliers de france bruno
mais gardanne bonsoir soir chef du
service réanimation médicale et
toxicologique c'est un hôpital
lariboisière à paris frédéric bizarre
économiste de la santé mais ce moment
soit vous publiez l'autonomie solide et
en santé c'est aux éditions michalon
j'accueille également en visioconférence
avec nous rodolphe bourrec et directeur
du centre hospitalier de valenciennes
bonsoir bienvenue votre hôpital qui est
premier du classement du point pour la
seconde année consécutive souvent donné
en exemple on verra pourquoi vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez de cette
crise dont on parle et puis matthieu
croissandeau évidemment éditorialiste à
mes côtés comme chaque lundi et mercredi
bonsoir mathieu donc surtout bienvenue à
vous peut-être votre constat pour pour
commencer on l'a vu à la une de
libération on l'a vu avec ce ce sujet de
notre journaliste jérôme rabier bruno
mégarde je commence avec vous la crise
cette crise dont on parle nous
aujourd'hui journaliste vous la voyez
vous la santé pointe depuis combien de
temps je parlais ni fermés faute de
personnel ecoutez-moi déjà un début de
l'été 40 % de mon personnel infirmier
m'a donné son intention de quitter le
service à la rentrée donc évidemment
septembre réinventer de septembre donc
ça mettait le série en très grande
difficulté notamment on s'attendait à ce
qu'il y ait un rebond épidémie que cet
hiver donc heureusement discutant je
remercie et l'encadrement pour ça on a
réussit à étaler les départs c'est pas
pour autant que le personnel ne part pas
et padres changer d'avis mais simplement
c'est impossible alors pourquoi ils
partent c'est pas parce que je suis
tyrannique ou parce que
parce qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas aux
patientes qu'il prenait en charge parce
qu'ils se sont rendu compte après la
crise d'abord que les conditions de
travail étaient extrêmement de vicier
qu'il n'y a pas eu la reconnaissance
attendue de tout ce qu'ils ont fait en
terme de salaire bien sûr mais surtout
en termes de qualités relationnelles
avec les patients en termes de
valorisation de leur profession en
termes de possibilités dans l'avenir et
puis évidemment on va dire
la crainte d'avoir à nouveau à vivre une
autre blague avait effectivement ils ont
souhaité partir alors partir pour
beaucoup en changeant de région en
allant vers des photos vers la campagne
a forcément en changeant de profession
pour certains voient là même s'ils sont
toujours attachés à leur travail et
c'est vrai que pour beaucoup et ça c'est
un problème aussi on peut être qu'on va
en parler le fait d'avoir côtoyé des
intérimaires pendant la crise qu vide et
bien leur a montré que certaines
personnes pouvaient toucher le double du
salaire choisir leurs horaires et
finalement faire le même travail et ça
évidemment c'est un constat qui est
assez général ça a donné des thèmes
quelques idées d'ailleurs patrick peloux
c'est vrai aussi aux urgences
celle là si tu
sais tu crées les urgences et la
variable d'ajustement de tous les
dysfonctionnements du système
c'est-à-dire quand on n'arrive pas à
mettre un malade en réanimation il va
aux urgences en attendant bon là la
dégradation c'est du jamais vu ça fait
20 ans qu'on se connaît que vous
m'interviewer régulièrement chez jamais
changé ma ligne j'ai jamais vu ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya dix ans
mais d'hermann parce que quand d'un coup
on dit les gens partent en province
quand on parle avec ceux qui sont de la
province ils disent ils partent aussi
donc on ne sait pas non c'est pas mieux
et c'est dramatique
l'histoire des intérims passionnant à
comprendre l'histoire d'intérim c'est la
loi bachelot 2008 2007 on enlève les
codes pour pouvoir travailler faire de
l'intérim embaucher et ses terrasses et
la flexibilité du travail très bien
d'accord quelques dizaines d'années
après c'est un échec total par en effet
c'est plus rentable de se placer comme
interop intérimaire évidemment
évidemment et du coup c'est pas eux les
méchants c'est juste un système qui a
fait une une inflation social
considérable et ça a cassé le truc ce
qui fait que l'a1 le personnel n'a pas
le moral ça c'est sûr on en fait tous
partie jamais j'ai vu autant de burnout
et ça c'est vrai c'est tellement vrai
qu'à l'assistance publique ils ont créé
une cellule contre la violence au
travail enfin d'accord troisièmement on
est complètement obsolète sur la gestion
du personnel et sur la relation c'est à
dire qu'en effet il ya un encadrement
qui est de plus en plus éloigné parce
qu'on a mis l'encadrement à faire de la
technostructure et remplir des tableurs
excel formidable plus du tout à côté du
personnel à dreux mans c'est
l'encadrement administratif a misé la
scène le service dans lé médecin chef de
service aussi parce qu'on les a éloignés
sciemment de plus en plus du lit du
malade pour leur faire faire de la
gestion de la prospective et des comptes
et et c'est comme ça ce qui fait qu'il
ya une perte de l'adhésion collective
par rapport à la chose hospitalières et
les infirmières quand on parle avec elle
à 10 je ne me reconnais plus dans
l'encadrement jeu là là vous voyez tous
les grands systèmes des entreprises ont
évolué sur les ressources humaines ils
ont fait évoluer sur des mesures de la
démocratie participative sur des trucs
comme ça et c'est devenu il ya des
socles et ça descend et ça monte à
l'hôpital on est resté pyramidale et
donc d'un coup le truc ne pouvait plus
fonctionner ce qui fait que l' on
constate parce que oui il ya eu des
augmentations de salaires ça c'est sûr
le manque de lits en novembre 2019 on
faisait avec le collectif inter
hospitalier des manifestations avec
toutes les confédérations syndicales
pour dire on manque de lits on a fermé
trop de liszt et personne ne vous
écoutait là c'est même pas pourquoi le
conseil scientifique a fait cette étude
mais tant mieux mais ce n'est pas une
conseil scientifique donne son avis sur
tout maintenant donc c'est très bien
parfait
débattre et puis de venir à fabien sénat
c'est très très bien mais où l on savait
savons sa naissance avec les et là le
drame il est totalement faillir ibiza
en préparant les missions j'ai trouvé ce
chiffre les infirmières infirmiers
tiennent en moyenne 8 ans avant de
renoncer donc c'est quand même
impressionnant quoi le l'effet de
lassitude l'effet de burnout ou 2 ou de
turnover pardon d'employés tendanc
d'anglicismes c'est quoi c'est la perte
de sens dont on parle
patrick peloux aulas en est ce que c'est
ça le premier mot qui vous vient à
l'esprit oui en grande partie mais il
faut essayer de l'expliquer oui un
fossile y poser un diagnostic d'abord
quand vous travaillez sur un peu les
réorganisations des systèmes de santé
des modèles de santé c'est très
difficile de réformer un système de
santé et vous ne savez pas quel va être
l'élément déclencheur
si vous regardez aux états unis
l'obamacare 50 millions d'américains qui
sont sortis du système assurantiel là
pour des gens qui ont un peu à une fibre
sociale aussi ça ça suffit c'est la fin
des choses en france on a en un pays
tellement riche avec une telle qualité
de ressources humaines que la diviser
c'est quand est ce qu'on va prendre
conscience que ce conte ce que l'on sait
tout cela qui est un problème à
l'hôpital qui est un problème en ville
qu'ils apprennent dans les ehpad que
notre système n'est plus adapté à son
environnement parce que vous avez deux
choses qu'il faut comprendre notre
système a été bâti sur les ordonnances
debré pour faire rapide en considérant à
juste titre que l'hôpital public devait
être le carrefour des soins
principalement des soins complexes ont
laissé les soins courants ville mais ton
club quand même eu tout ce qui était
complexe de la recherche de
l'enseignement tout se passait à
l'hôpital public et tu as fait elle
pouvoir des mandarins des chefs de
service
non mais c'est le modèle sa volée qui a
fait ça et on peut les appeler les
mandarins et oui et c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire pour différentes raisons
que je vais pas développer donc on a
créé le meilleur système de santé au
monde et puis on a médicalisé des
territoires autour pour que chacun est
un accès et puis au fur et à mesure des
décennies vous avez vu ce qu'on appelle
la transition épidémiologique tout d'un
coup il ya une chronicisation
d'hématologie donc vous aviez des les
patients étaient de plus en plus sans
l'ambulatoire puis vous avez des
évolutions technologiques terre ce qu'on
ne faisait que à l'hôpital on faisait en
ville puis au de mise et donc le
l'hôpital tout d'un coup a perdu un peu
sa place centrale mais on a toujours
considéré que
ne changez donc on n'a pas repenser la
place de l'hôpital donc en effet il ya
la place d'hôpital et de ceux qui y
travaillent donc on est resté sur ce
modèle là qui est en fait plus en
adéquation la deuxième chose et je serai
ta coup parce que patrick peloux l'a
parfaitement c'est que ça c'était pour
essayer de maîtriser des dépenses aussi
il faut que l'état reprenne on était
dans un système très décentralisé
jusqu'au au mandarin qui gérait ses
ressources et c'était c'est ça qu'il
faut faire faut décentraliser la gestion
garcia choc bon donc pour bien pour bien
gérer ça et en fait on s'est dit non en
fait pour mieux contrôler on va redonner
toutes les manettes à l'état qui va ré
administrer le système les rh les ars et
puis les hôpitaux qui sont même plus
dans les mains des directeurs qui sont
dans les mains des ars qui en a mis
entre les deux une autre couche avec
l'agent j allais je pense que tout le
monde connaît
la crise mais bref mais je vous aide
dans une une gouvernance qui est
tellement loin des réalités du terrain
et qui a tout pouvoir on a des
médicalisé 7,7 gouvernance la pop ans en
pensant bien faire je jette pas mais
aujourd'hui ça ne peut pas fonctionner
donc ça et mais ça on le savait avant le
coc vite donc il faut repenser de façon
vraiment structurelle la place de
l'hôpital qui doit rester une place
forte mais qui peut pas être organisée
de la même façon dans ce nouveau modèle
dont vont penser un nouveau modèle à la
statue le statut de fonction publique il
doit pas être simplement à l'hôpital il
faut l'étendre en ville quand vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui et ça c'était
madame touraine en 2015 elle dit non la
permanence des soins c'est qu'à
l'hôpital le service public c'est qu'à
l'hôpital dont le service public c'est
dans les territoires il faut passer du
service public hospitalier au service
public territorial de santé la
permanence des soins doit se gérer par
les privés comme par le public dans les
territoires qu on remet tout à plat
c'est une réforme globale on y reviendra
évidemment je voudrais entendre quand
même heureux de le gouray je rappelle
que vous êtes le directeur du centre
hospitalier de valenciennes qui est
souvent cité en exemple moi j'ai un
chiffre en tête je vous avais déjà
interviewé il ya il ya deux ou trois ans
sur une autre chaîne et ce chiffre
n'avait marqué dans votre pitallier que
5 % de personnel administratif contre
30% en moyenne ça c'est la moyenne
nationale ça veut dire que vous êtes un
peu le contre exemple j'ai l'impression
que vous déléguez au chef de service une
grande partie de votre pouvoir est ce
que c'est pour ça que ça marche mieux
chez vous
le chiffre donné et est exact on est à
5% sur le personnel administratif
il ya une forte délégation polaire et
médicales au sein du centre hospitalier
de valenciennes par exemple mes
prérogatives de directeurs jeudi délègue
à 90%
au médecin et donc les médecins qui ont
la capacité par exemple de faire des
recrutements des recrutement de médecins
des recrutements des infirmiers
d'aide-soignante ils ont la capacité
dernière sur du matériel biomédical sur
des médicaments ils ont même la capacité
de faire défaire des travaux le modèle
de l'hôpital de valenciennes est un
modèle qui est basé sur un concept qui
datait des années 80 de l'hôpital
magnétique était un concept américain
sur lequel dans les années 80 les
hôpitaux américains et notamment la mayo
clinic qui est connue actuellement pour
son excellence sur les soins
a mis en place en fait a vu qu'il y
avait un problème d'attractivité sur ces
soignants et pour refaire venir des
soignants au sein de l'hôpital ils ont
mis en place d une gouvernance
totalement inversée en mettant un
administratif un directeur un médecin et
un soignant à la tête de l'hôpital et à
la tête des des services ce qui fait que
la prise de décision en fait est prise
au niveau du terrain et les services de
structures les services
supports en fait sont là uniquement au
service du donneur d'ordre le donneur
d'ordre c'était le chef de service et
donc on a pu noter excusez moi mais je
vous interromps une seconde pour pour
rebondir sur le constat de départ à
revenir au constat de départ est ce
qu'avec votre modèle
vous avez moins de
turn over moins de lits fermés
aujourd'hui où est ce que vous êtes
confrontés malgré tout à une crise
similaire
alors actuellement ce que je viens
d'entendre ça c'est pas ce qu'on vit au
centre hospitalier de valenciennes au
centre hospitalier de valenciennes on
n'a pas de lits fermés pour cause de
l'absence de personnel on a
effectivement une certaine tension sur
le personnel paramédical et médical due
à la situation de crise qui a été malin
et demi et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
une pénibilité du travail
importante mais par contre on a eu des
départs qui sont des départs on va dire
qu'ils se produisent chaque année pour
différentes raisons qui sont à peu près
équivalents
sur les années précédentes que sur 7 sur
cette année on a eu des recrutements
aussi en nombre suffisant pour pouvoir
maintenir des effectifs c'est ouvrir
ouvrir au lit conformément à un autre
potentiel alors je vous donne la parole
à vous restez avec nous évidemment
rodolphe bizarre c'est on se dit moi je
suis un peu basique parfois ça marche là
pourquoi on duplique passé s'est passé
pas si simple pour une raison simple
c'est qu'un hôpital toute institution ne
peut pas bien fonctionner s'il ya pas
une bonne gouvernance est en fait ce qui
arrive à faire l'hôpital de valenciennes
c'est ce qui est intéressant si vous
pouvez dire finalement dans le même
système valenciennes arrivée d autres
arrivent pas oui il n'est pas illégal
oui dans sa façon oui mais un vrai
système c'est un système qui permet à
tout le monde doit 95 % des
établissements d'être gérée comme ça
donc probablement surplus d'entregent
plus de charisme plus je sais pas mais
en tout cas c'est pas accessible à un
directeur d'hôpital normal donc donc
c'est un problème de système et canton
ont mais on peut pas on a mis énormément
de moyens dans l'hôpital mais on n'a pas
fait l'essentiel qui est parce qu on
n'admet pas ce constat qu'on vient de
faire il ya un problème de gouvernance
depuis 2009 on a dit un seul chef
et ce chef il y sera administratif mais
on n'en sort jamais et depuis on a
toujours renforcer ce sens là et en
effet de recentraliser plutôt de
décentraliser bon et après il ya il ya
autre chose aussi qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'il ya des problèmes de de carrière
hospitalière parce que les carrières si
si elles sont moins attractives c'est
probant qu'il faut les repenser cette
trivalent c'est à dire que vous pouvez
un peu tout faire ce qui est juste
impossible tout ça est un peu suranné la
trivalle ans vous pouvez faire de la
recherche 17 pays et ups professeur
d'université faire pâtir spitalier vous
pouvez faire des soins des séances de la
recherche de l'enseignement enfin vous
êtes plus vous représentez non donc il
faut repenser ça il faut probablement
nous on a proposé des des contrats
d'obligation de 5 ans qui vous permettre
de diversifier les carrières quelqu'un
qui veut pendant cinq ans faire du soin
et de la recherche depuis cinq ans après
qui veut diversifier il faut qu'ils
puissent le faire mais il faut le rendre
attractif l'hôpital public est pas avoir
les statuts et le statut souvent
longtemps il faut changer non mais le
statut lui permet il suffit juste un peu
que d apporter des réformes donc il faut
apporter la flexibilité intelligente qui
a été apportée d'abord de la
décentralisation et puis de l'autonomie
de l'autonomie aux hôpitaux on y revient
on va faire un peu de politique tient
pendant ce débat et je vais donner la
parole à à mathieu poissant d'abord un
élément c'est une vidéo qu'on a qu'on a
trouvées sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est anne hidalgo qui est en
déplacement dans le train en route vers
un hôpital de la drôme et qui réagit
comme ça à regarder bonjour
dans la drôme c'était peut-être
et de ça
voilà elle utilise la une de libération
matthieu croissandeau alors évidemment
on peut dire anne hidalgo en attend des
propositions originales ou un plan pour
réformer la santé mais au delà de ça ce
que je trouvais intéressant c'est c'est
que ce qui teinte en train de se passer
même si vous nous dites on sait ça
depuis des mois mais n'empêche que là
c'est dans le débat public c'est un jeu
fait pas comment dire ça mais dans le
bilan qu'ovide de l'exécutif c'est quand
même un coup de canif là bas on a un
phénomène conjoncturel la crise
politique qui s'ajoute à un énorme
problème structurel qui est la crise
hôpital qui dure depuis beaucoup plus
longtemps
sur la gestion de la crise qu au vide
sur le phénomène conjoncturel pour tout
regard des enquêtes d'opinion bon an mal
an les français finissent par considérer
que cette crise a été gérée alors là pas
été extraordinairement bien géré mais
ils ont craqué regardez un peu ce qui se
passe ailleurs et un jugement qui n'est
pour hacker plutôt neutre en tout cas
sinon positif pour emmanuel macron sur
la crise de l'hôpital ont pas non plus
rendre ce gouvernement responsable de
deux problèmes qui durent depuis depuis
des décennies moi ce qui me frappe
surtout c'est l'absence de ce sujet une
certaine façon dans la campagne on
sortait une crise sanitaire monstrueuse
qui a mis le système de santé tellement
attention qu'on a aujourd'hui des
démissions qui s'explique par les
raisons structurelles qu'on a dit mais
aussi par raisons conjoncturelles et
vous entendez parler les candidats de la
droite de réductions d'effectifs alors
et 10 prennent soin de dire peut-être
pas dans l'hôpital
d'insécurité et d'immigration mais qui
parle de santé qui parle de santé qui
dit le principal sujet aujourd'hui c'est
ça il ya une demande sociale très forte
pour un système de santé très fort il ya
une réponse politique pour l'instant
très faible qui se joue soit sur des
rémunérations qui va augmenter ou
regarder ce que dit olivier veyrat
libération aujourd'hui à un ami de 10
milliards sur la table pour le secteur
de la santé so what où est ce qu'ils
sont c'est bien aujourd'hui ça a dû être
mis au passif du bilan de la gestion de
crise parce que je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez l'un et l'autre j'ai commencé
avec vous patrick peloux mais c'est
peut-être quand même une occasion
manquée cette crise que vit de fait il y
avait sans doute une grande réforme à
poser à ce moment là avec une très
grande déception ça a été le discours en
mars 2001 du président de la république
quand il a dit ça n'a pas de prix quoi
qu'il en trouve donc là comme beaucoup
mais je suis tombé de ma chaise en
disant ah ça y est ils ont compris et
puis il ya eu cette période extrêmement
difficile pour travailler mais où on a
vu des moyens et puis il y avait plus de
problème vous voyez c'était fou plus une
adhésion collective citoyenne et il faut
lui rendre hommage ou des personnels de
deville venir travailler à l'hôpital les
infirmières venaient de province et
cetera et cetera et cetera il faut que
société en soute séance population
soutient et où il s'est passé vraiment
quelque chose je pense que ça a fait
trembler un certain nombre de la
technostructure qu'ils sont 10 mars est
en train d y sont en train de fissurer
ce qu'on a essayé de monter et ils ont
ils ont donc fait un système en réaction
et c'est pas étonnant que la classe
politique n'en parle pas en fait parce
que en fait ils ont que des potes qui
sont un peu responsable de tout ça voyez
parti socialiste l'erreur massive du
parti socialiste ça a été de ne pas
abroger la loi bachelot qui est l
hôpital entreprise qui était l'antithèse
de ce qu'il fallait faire qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait quand ils sont arrivés
au gouvernement ils ont gardé la loi
bachelot ils ont fait une loi la fameuse
loi des gouttes de gouvernance des
hôpitaux par territoire etc alors là on
comprenait plus rien parce que hôpital
entreprise mais vous devez travailler
ensemble à non des concurrents ont des
concurrents avec la rs plus personne n'y
comprend rien ce qui fait que c'est un
un magma est en effet il faut rentrer
là-dedans or vous avez une classe
politique qui est d'une nullité
affligeante dans globalement à part
xavier bertrand qui a été ministre de la
santé qui comprend un peu les trucs les
autres c'est assez accablant parce que
dako évidemment ils sont entourés de
conseillers
qui sont à la manoeuvre donc d'un coup
des gens comme nous qui arrivons et qui
disons non mais attendez on se trompe
complètement faut remettre à plat et il
mille fois raison faut revoir vraiment
les statuts par exemple il ya un truc
dont on parle pas juste une parenthèse
ça a été la fuite de la chirurgie
publique dans le privé avec la crise
pourquoi les chirurgiens on a fermé les
livres l'hôpital public est entièrement
consacré aux qu'ovide très très bien on
a pris les salles de réveil c'est à dire
les salles qui font du pré pré
opératoire post opératoire en disant on
va mettre du corps etc les chirurgiens
on leur a dit vous opérez plus mais un
chirurgien il opère les cliniques
privées sont allés les chercher et
ondimba venait opéré chez nous et j sont
restés parce que qu'est évidemment
pourquoi est ce qu'ils disent et quand
vous parlez avec eux ils vous disent vu
les difficultés qu'il y a à l'hôpital
public il préfère est en clinique ou
d'un coup quand on leur dit le blog
commence à 7h il commence à 7h on a
perdu ça et quelque part je suis désolé
et quelques pas c'est voulu parce que
quelque part fallait casser le service
public hospitalier et c'est voulu sur
des exemples qui étaient des exemples
nord américain on disait voilà il faut
que ça parte dans le privé etc et puis
on va faire de la chirurgie ambulatoire
et plus on va faire des tas de trucs
comme ça tu ne répondent pas à l'attenté
de la population parce que derrière ça
essayer de trouver un cardiologue dans
certains secteurs en france vous ne
trouvez pas l'accès à la psychiatrie est
dramatique quand vous parlez avec les
pédopsychiatres ils vous disent mais
voilà la jeunesse où elle va comment
l'hospitaliser etc à tous les niveaux
tous les niveaux bruno mais germania bon
je reviens sur l'occasion manquée
peut-être à l'occasion de cette crise
que vit le grenelle 2 2 de la santé
est-ce que vous dans la lassitude
exprimée par
les personnels dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire ceux qui expriment
depuis des mois qui veulent partir il ya
clairement cet argument là se dire on
n'y a cru à un moment on s'est dit la
société derrière nous le gouvernement
nous annonce d
des hausses de salaires et finalement on
voit pas grand chose changer est ce que
vous avez ce discours là alors c'est
vrai qu'en fait on a connu en tout cas -
comme chef de service deux mois et dit
l'icg en fait tout est effectivement on
pouvait rencontrer un médecin le matin
et lui demander de travailler le soir
malheureusement ça n'a duré que deux
mois
pendant ces deux mois on pouvait si on
avait besoin d'un appareil est bien
immédiatement appelé le fabricant et
demandé sa livraison le soir
malheureusement tout a changé très
rapidement en fait des mets 2020 la
technostructure réapparu avec son
millefeuille qui est de plus en plus
complexes et en fait on doit remplir d
excellent si vous voulez en pratique qui
vont aller la première direction qui
doit envoyer la deuxième direction qui
doit monter à la troisième direction
vous avez vous fait de moins en médecine
en fait quasiment pas en fait quasiment
pas comme chef de service et très peu en
fait et parce que vous faites ph c'est
que vous êtes sur le terrain vous est
déconsidéré on vous prend pour un
imbécile parce qu'on a sur le ter est ce
que tu es sur le terrain et il soigne
les malades et quand je dis il ya un
truc qui va pas on t'écoute pas les
seuls moments où je fais de la médecine
c'est quand je suis de garde ont fait la
nuit où je suis le seul médecin donc là
j'ai fait la médecine sorti de là je
suis dans mon bureau à remplir d
excellent parce que si je ne le fais pas
eh bien le service est déconsidéré je ne
reçois plus rien je suis perdu je suis
obligé de remplir et d'ailleurs c'est
une administration qui c'est on va dire
auto entretenue à tel point qu
effectivement le représente 30 à 35 %
des salariés de l'hôpital public est en
fait une administration on demande une
autre qui va contrôler et celle d'après
et c est ce qui fait qu effectivement eh
bien on est noyé par les documents
administratifs entre ce qu'ils doivent
aux demandes indispensable mais aussi le
contrôle de ces demandes et finalement
n'ayant aucune aucun moyen financier en
main eh bien on dépend totalement on et
poings liés à ces administratif se
chiffre lui dans dans l' enquête de
libération environ 4000 infirmiers et
infirmières de la région rhône alpes
rhône alpes pardon pointe actuellement
au chômage dans l'espoir d'obtenir
un travail beaucoup mieux payés en
suisse ou en allemagne assuré j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment frappant rodolphe
bourré je reviens vers vous je n'ai pas
la réponse à la question j'ai pas trouvé
ça en préparant les missions est ce que
vous payez mieux on va rester sur les
infirmières et les infirmiers
hôpital de valenciennes où est ce que
finalement vous êtes dans la même et
pure que dans que chez vos collègues
connaît dans la mêlée pure en est on a
utilisé les les mesures secure pour
augmenter notre personnel mais autrement
on était dans la même et pure mais par
contre ce qui change ce sont les
conditions de travail
nous les conditions de travail ce sont
des conditions de travail qui sont
décidés par par les médecins les équipes
soignantes et médicales si on regarde la
crise qu vide nous au niveau du centre
hospitalier de valenciennes on n'a pas
des structures et notre organisation
notre organisation et les tournées vers
le soin et donc on a une organisation
pas de structure pas de moyens dans
l'ain organisation qui est orienté vers
le patient temps quand est arrivé le coc
vide en fait les les médecins ont au
lieu de traiter des patients avec des
maladies conventionnels ils ont traité
cohidon à changer l'orientation de
l'offre de soins quand la première vague
est arrivée on avait déjà anticipé le
fait qu' il fallait des sas qu'il
fallait des unités qu'ovide particulière
et c est en fait ce sont les médecins
qui ont donné des ordres aux
administratifs et qui se sont mis en
ordre de marche pour pouvoir accueillir
les patients quand la première vague a
été a été terminée nous l'hôpital il a
repris un fonctionnement classique c'est
à dire qu'on a plus soignée de patients
qu'aux vide et on a soigné des patients
de manière conventionnelle ce qui veut
dire que la structure telle qu'on la
nouvelle et très agile les circuits
administratifs son centre est très
rapide je donne un autre exemple qui est
assez amusant j'ai aimé pratiquement
aucune note de service les cantines des
notes de service qui sont de fait elles
sont faites par les médecins et donc ce
sont eux qui émettent les notes de
service par exemple pour les fermetures
de lits ou pour la présence de médecins
qui vient d'arriver et c'est donc on est
on est véritablement d'agen un système
qui est repensé au tournant donc vous
dites ce n'est pas seulement une
question de salé à face avec blizzard
sur cet aspect du salaire
ces paquets pas uniquement une question
de salaires enfin quand pendant dix ans
ne vous en partie gelé le point lundi
c'est à dire vous geler la hausse de la
rémunération au quand vous négligez la
formation continue qui vous permet de
progresser de passer de dents de d'une
aide soignante à une infirmière parce
que justement il ya des problèmes de
ressources
vous n'aidez pas non plus à ce que
l'environnement soit stimulant combien
donc le sauve gagné en suisse
ce pays a relativement paupérisée depuis
20 ans et enseignant ces soignants ces
pompiers c'est ce et voilà il ya un vrai
problème de reconnaissance dans la
valeur un compte vous voyez mais vous
pouvez prendre aussi en ville une
consultation de 25 euros vous n'avez pas
ça dans d'autres pays donc l'infirmière
et payer moins que le salaire moyen ce
que vous n'avez pas ça dans les autres
pays développés donc vous avez un vrai
manque de reconnaissance générale se dit
patrick peloux c'est dire nous on s'en
fout parce qu'on reçoit vous soigner et
donc vous êtes presque petites mains
donc c'est un vrai problème culturel si
vous voulez qu'ils formaient un hôpital
ces deux ressources humaines
technologiques et les deux ont été
négligés à part quelques endroits où est
là où on a toujours pour montrer qu'en
faisant de la république vallée montrer
qui est un entrepreneur mais globalement
la question c'est encore une fois
pourquoi on du people et bonnes
pratiques ça semble exclusif frédéric
est juste et c'est à qu'utilisé par un
problème c'est que vous avez en plus
l'oppression sociale des personnels
parce que par exemple pour parler de
l'assistance publique et de paris mais
c'est valable dans les grandes villes se
loger se loger devenu épouvantable donc
du coup parfois les personnels pour
venir travailler il faut 20 30
kilomètres en voiture pour arriver ils
sont remarquables parce qu'ils arrivent
à l'heure mais il ya les sens à nous
retomber sur votre sujet de l'autre jour
il ya le prix de l'essence il ya
logement après évidemment vous avez
toutes les femmes qui sont
monoparentales d'accord et ça ça pose un
problème donc du coup il ya cette
globalité et comme comme comme tu viens
fort justement de dire on est encore
même avec les augmentations du ségur on
est passé de la 28e place des pays de
l'osce et des oeufs à la 18e place des
pays de la cedeao sur les chefs des
salaires des ald et un fils des
soignants très bien mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut remettre un coup de pouce est
en effet derrière ça y'a la valeur des
choses or on est on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une société là
c'est pour élargir le débat mais vous
avez plus de valeur à faire de boursiers
a joué à la bourse d'accor à être sur
youtube heures à une influence aux alors
là c'est le summum de tout maintenant à
mes infirmières et vous avez une
péjoration des valeurs et c'est vrai et
c'est vrai quand les gens les ont
applaudi quand on nous a applaudis on
s'est dit tiens il ya quelque chose il
se passe quelque chose et là il ya une
déconvenue il ya une déconvenue et moi
je me souviens encore du navire avec qui
j'ai parlé l'autre soir qui va dit moi
j'arrête parce que ma hiérarchie
m'écoute pas et j'en ai assez parce que
je choisis entre me racheter des
fringues ou partir en vacances eh ben ça
c'est pas possible parce que vous pouvez
pas sauver des vies humaines vous pouvez
pas sauvé des la souffrance des gens
d'accord par amour parce que tout ça
c'est de l'amour et puis vous dire et
pas les fins de mois elles sont
épouvantables bruno milliards d'années
ce cadet des risques cette situation là
qu'on vit avec les lits fermés faute de
personnel si on se projette dans
l'hypothèse on espère que ça n'arrivera
pas d'une nouvelle vague d'une crise
qu'ovide similaires aux précédentes ça
craque oui vous avez raison en fait on
avait surtout alerter qu'en septembre
plus qu'un vrai une vraie vague nouvelle
avec une arrivée massive de patients ce
qui allait faire le problème c'est la
crise sociale alors en fait il faut
savoir c'est qu'en fait on rentre dans
un cercle vicieux parce qu'effectivement
vous avez des départs de personnels la
solution que trouve l'administration
s'est fermé des lits or les besoins en
termes de santé de la peau d'une
population qui est malheureusement
vieilli qui a des maladies de plus en
plus grave qu'il faut soigner avec l'aco
vide et bien reste la même et donc en
fait on augmente la charge de travail
sur finalement ceux qui restent qui sont
d'ailleurs les plus volontaires les plus
motivés malgré toutes les conditions et
bien il en arrive au burn out il parle
encore plus et on quand on ferme des
lits etc donc on est dans cette dans
cette spirale
sans fin et pour pour solutionner les
choses un visa 1000 lits de moi et pour
solutionner l'hôpital n'a qu'une seule
solution c'est d'amener ces fameuses
intérimaire qu'il paye 3 à 4 fois plus
cher alors que s'il avait mieux régler
les ressources humaines s'il avait
amélioré les salaires de façon
convenable avec les infirmiers
titulaires peut-être en leur demandant
un engagement de carrière à l'hôpital
public on n'en serait pas là
c'est juste pour pour ajouter à ce qui
vient d'être dit que la pénibilité elle
et pas seulement ceux sur le salaire
c'est aussi cet hôpital entreprise qui
est arrivé est l'antithèse de ce qu'il
fallait faire et en effet si on repart
de ce qui s'est fait à valenciennes en
fait ça parle mais alors ils ont voulu
faire ça en créant ce qu'ils appelaient
des pôles c'est-à-dire tordre le coup au
service c'est-à-dire tordre le cou à la
proximité et puis créer des pôles où on
a pris des médecins en leur disant vous
allez devenir en gros chez les recteurs
directeurs de pôles d'accord c'est même
maintenant directeur
départemental mais on met des gars là
encore c'est que les et des armées
mexicaines plus on met deux médaillés
moyen de soldats donc c'est très bien
ils ont fait ça on ne s'est complètement
déconnecté de la réalité des problèmes
du personnel ce qui fait que d'un coup
on nous achète nous a acheté des
brancards on nous a acheté des des
ambulances mais personne n'a donné son
motta coup le truc il tombe du ciel
comme ça et vous travaillez mal avec
vous savez mais on a relevé la corrèze
mais ça correspond à rien oui juste dans
la valeur dont on parle et patrick tout
à l'heure c'est relativement simple et
c'est ce qui se passe à valenciennes
c'est que ce soit plus une gouvernance
participative c'est bien si c'est pas
très compliqué comme de faire participer
les gens chassés et qui est un autre
aspect plus économique c'est qu'il faut
gérer des ressources médicales à
l'échelle d'un service c'est-à-dire
proche des patients proches du terrain
est maintenant proche du territoire
juste une seconde survenir sur l'aspect
politique que votre confrère diable je
les ai vus dans d'autres pays c'est pas
propre à la france
le personnel politique ne s'intéresse
pas à la santé pour trois raisons le
premier c'est que personne ne travaille
dans les partis politiques sur le fond
sur les questions de santé sur le fond à
l'exception de six mois avant l'élection
on essaie de trouver trois idées art qui
vont porter le truc c'est vrai dans tous
les partis et aujourd'hui en france
c'est vrai deuxième chose c'est qu'à une
représentation un peu excessive des
politiques qui se dit c'est un sujet
casse gueule hypersensible il ya les
lobby des médecins si on va là dedans
c'est un truc bon et
la troisième chose qui se passe c'est
que l'on manque de vrais réformateurs
parce que c'est vrai que je reviens sur
ce que j'ai fait obama pour avoir
travaillé là bas quand il est quand il y
était c'est qu'il ya dix mois j'ai fait
une seule chose mon premier mandat
c'est la réforme de la santé le deuxième
mandat j'ai fait principalement une
chose c'est défendre la réforme à bien
c'est les réformes sociétales parce que
si vous voulez c'est la santé ça touche
l'ensemble de la société c'est du social
ces du médical c'est de l'économique et
on sait maintenant que c'est du
géopolitique c'est du soft power donc
donc oui tout ça c'est moi je dis
qu'elle quand je vois des candidats
jeudi tête voulait quelque chose
d'important sur lequel vous pouvez
porter prenez juste ça si vous
réussissez ça l on l'a vu récemment dans
l'édition vont rester dans l'histoire
tatamis a raison il ya un exemple
politique là dessus c'est la guerre le
génocide au rwanda quand le génocide
s'arrête que fait le président du rwanda
il fait un système de santé avec une
sécurité sociale et ça calme tout le
monde en disant on va soigner tout le
monde c'est donc le socle de la
république c'est le socle des sociétés
façon vous prenez n'importe quel chaos
même actuellement en afghanistan le seul
truc où il ya marqué encore et qui tient
encore la route c'est marqué hôpital
même s'il n'y a rien derrière c'est pas
grave sa structure les sociétés et c'est
ça qu'on a perdu bis et aricie pour
structurer les deux allemagnes créé la
sécurité sociale à sion non mais donc si
je reviens je reviens à la centrale là
je reviens la théorie blocage sans fin
les théories à li na 7 6
occasion manquée et vous avez raison et
la campagne présidentielle ne répond pas
aux attentes des français ne vous
étonnez pas ils n'iront pas voter parce
que ça lui a intérêt à poser une
dernière question il nous reste quelques
minutes avant de le gouray bien j'ai eu
le
le ségur c'était le ségur de la santé
seront pas j'allais dire le grenelle
mais c'est pas le même ministère et le
ségur de la santé vous y étiez associés
oui non sous quelle forme pour essayer
de comprendre comment les le voilà le
personnel politique tient compte d'une
expérience qui marche
alors nous on a été auditée par la
mission aux clarisses pour montrer
qualité dans son modèle le dos rond et
après on a pu été nous solliciter et
donc c'est vrai que le modèle de
transformation de valenciennes a peu été
à mon avis utilisés dans les réformes
c'est dommage il y avait véritablement
une rupture avec le système qui était
assisté à matri est rare chic qui
existent actuellement le modèle de
valenciennes est un modèle qui est
complètement inversé avec
l'hôpital qui arrive à soigner en même
temps qu'ils arrivent à être attractifs
qu'à la paix sociale et puis qui a une
augmentation d'activité qui est
constante en dix ans ce modèle-là a
permis
de revenir à l'équilibré financier mais
c'est presque secondaire en fait c'est
un impact secondaire en fait une
activité de soins qui a s'est multiplié
par deux en dix ans grâce à son modèle
organisationnel et pourquoi se sont
multipliées par 2 parce que tout
simplement les parcours de soins ont été
décidées par les soignants et les
soignants ont décidé des moyens qu'ils
allaient affecter à leur parcours de
soignies et donc à partir de ce moment
là les coups comme était sur le soin on
n'était pas sur la gestion
administrative et donc quand moi je dis
qu'on a cinq pour cent de de coûts
administratifs comparé à 30-35 %
d'anglais au plus tôt les 25% à votre
bien chez moi ils sont orientés sur le
soin sur les équipes soignantes et c'est
vrai que par exemple sur les effectifs
les actifs moi j'ai certainement plus
effectif
que les autres hôpitaux de taille
équivalente parce que on a mis ses ce
budget pour pouvoir justement soigner en
fonction de ce qu'on avait décidé à
faire on tue ce que les médecins ont
défilé ces briques on est sur une
gouvernance qui est participative avec
un ensemble de deux médecins deux
soignants et puis d'administratifs mais
administratives sont au service en fait
de la décision médicale si merci rodolfo
et puis on voit que ça fonctionne
l'intelligence collective puisque c'est
un directeur avec l'accent du sud qui
travaille dans un hôpital de
valenciennes donc ils s'écoutent les
alizés merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant je sais pas si elle a donné
des idées aux candidats en tout cas ils
peuvent aller voir du côté du du nord il
ya sans doute quelques quelques bonnes
idées à trouver on passe à notre
rubrique les électeurs ont la parole
les électeurs ont la parole vous pouvez
réagir comme tous les soirs avec le mot
diez le hashtag sens public avec ce soit
le coup de pression la région des hauts
de france on y est encore face à la
grande misère de trois de ses lignes ter
elle menace la sncf de ne plus payer
samia de chiens la réponse de la sncf ne
s'est pas fait attendre 24 heures après
le coup de gueule de la région
l'entreprise ferroviaire a annoncé un
plan de redressement immédiat pour les
ter des hauts de france d'ici le 8
novembre 40 contrôleurs et conducteurs
vont être envoyés en renfort et de
locomotives supplémentaires seront mises
en service dès cette semaine des
personnels volontaires des métiers de la
maintenance vont également prêté main
forte pour réparer les rames en panne
des trains endommagées par les heures de
gibier et des actes d'incivilité assure
l'entreprise qui reconnaît aussi un
manque de personnel ces tensions
humaines et matérielles ont fortement
perturbé la régularité du service la
région au de france estime que les
suppressions de trains ont été
multipliées par trois depuis début
septembre
hier elle a publiquement menacé la sncf
de suspendre ses paiements si elle ne
rétablissait pas un service régulier
d'ici mi novembre
chaque année les hauts de france
consacre 500 millions d'euros au
fonctionnement des trains express
régionaux
deux invités pour illustrer ce constat
et le bras de fer avec la sncf gilles
laurent qu'est président de la
fédération des hautes france des usagers
des transports et franck dhersin qu'est
vice président à la recherche des
mobilités infrastructures et des ports à
la région des hauts de france gilles
orange commence avec vous racontez nous
la la galère depuis des semaines des
mois même sur ses lignes ter
oui bonjour donc effectivement ce
charmant d'ailleurs
et moi c'est pas seulement depuis début
septembre mais ça s'est aggravée début
septembre on va dire avec la rentrée
bien sûr c'est un peu comme si la sncf
n'avait pas vu la rentrée venir et on
s'est retrouvé avec une multitude non
seulement de retard mais aussi de
suppression et de train trop court qui
ont pour conséquence que les gens
s'entassent dans les trains et ont
beaucoup de trains supprimés ça a une
double conséquence sur les grosses
lignes et bien
des trains supprimés font que l'on va
devoir prendre le dessus banques et une
demi heure plus tard par exemple mais
qui va être beaucoup plus surchargées
donc en cette période quand même deux
pandémies séparer une bonne idée et puis
sur les lignes plus secondaire si on
peut dire les petites lignes là on va se
retrouver avec un train supprimé le
suivant à être dans deux heures ou dans
trois heures par exemple avant vous
imaginez bien que les personnes qui ont
un besoin quotidien du train et même
celles qui en ont besoin occasionnel
d'ailleurs quand on se retrouve devant
une telle défaillance du service
ferroviaire on n'a pas envie de
recommencer l'expérience est très
souvent quoi voilà donc ça ça pose des
gros soucis y compris sur des lignes
fraîchement rénovée je pense à
saint-paul et appela monsieur dhersin
connais très bien cette ligne-là de même
qu'à bancourt le tréport ce sont d une
toute neuve qui permettrait normalement
d'avoir un bon service et on se rend
compte que c'est totalement défaillant
quadras sont supprimées et ça va pas du
tout alors justement franck dhersin
comment ça s'explique après on va parler
du bras de fer mais ce point précis à d
il ya du matériel neuf sur sur une ligne
et pourtant ça fonctionne pas c'est quoi
l'explication oui alors le gie l'euro a
très bien résumé la situation qui se
passe depuis des mois et qui s'est
largement aggravés donc début septembre
en vérité il y a un manque très
important de matériel
et de personnel qui est normalement doit
être donné par les scènes scène dans le
cas de la convention que nous nous avons
donc manque de conducteurs manque de
chef de bord
effectivement beaucoup de trains abîmé
est en panne et la capacité dans les
centres d'entretien à trouver
suffisamment de personnel pour pouvoir
réparer ses trains et donc voilà on a
une succession très importante de
suppressions de trains de trains courts
alors que ce devrait être des trains
longs et surtout un énorme défaut la
sncf en matière de communication la sncf
c'est très souvent le soir même que le
train de 6h58 du lendemain matin de rap
à dieu parce qu'ils savent que la ram
est en panne il semble que le conducteur
n'est pas là où qui n'aura pas
deux contrôleurs il suffirait pour de le
dire de prévenir les gens même à minuit
ou tôt le matin et des gens pourraient
au moins se prépare et prendre la
voiture même si c'est parce que nous
voulons prendre un train avant ou intra
près mais non ils se retrouvent sur le
quai et il voit
apprenons sur le quai que le train
n'aura pas lieu et ça c'est
insupportable
franck dhersin qu'on combien la région
verse par mois à la sncf pour pour un
service normal évidemment je m'étais
guillemets au mot normal et quelles
réponses double question est quelle
réponse vous avez eu la en urgence à
partir le mans vous avez menacé de plus
peu de ne plus payer
c'est une convention de 500 millions
d'euros par an 1 c'est un million deux
cent soixante six mille euros par jour
donc vous voyez si vous voulez pas vous
x 30 donc c'est considérable c'est un
budget énorme et d'ailleurs c'est un
budget qui ont augmenté de 50 millions
d'euros quand on a signé la convention
et la sncf a assez d'argent puisque au
niveau des hauts de france elle a fait
l'année dernière un bénéfice avant
impôts de 30 millions d'euros donc là
les moyens là l'argent pour mettre des
moyens supplémentaires alors donc nous
avons tapé du poing sur la table nous
avons menacé de plus payé justement tous
les mois ces sommes est bon en moins de
trois jours le directeur monsieur mouche
2 e au directeur des ter au niveau
national s'est déplacée est venu merci à
lui d'avoir répondu aussi rapidement et
nous a fait toute une série de
propositions comme ça a été relatée dans
les propos liminaires de votre reportage
et donc nous mais très rapidement dans
le courant du mois de novembre du
personnel conducteur du personnel de
bord et surtout du personnel pour
entretenir mieux les trains gilles
laurent bon là il ya une il ya une
réaction on va dire d'urgence mais
qu'est ce que vous réclamez j'imagine un
programme d'investissements
de ce nom c'est quoi les solutions vous
imaginez vous comme usagers
nous ce qu'on regrette en premier c'est
qu' il ait fallu ce bras de fer une fois
de plus pourquoi la sncf bouge je dire
ça fait des semaines qu'elle le sait on
a l'impression qu'elle est pas au
courant qu'il rentrait le 1er septembre
ça fait des semaines qu'elle sait qu'on
a des problèmes elle a attendu voilà à
quoi ça aurait pu durer comme ça jusqu'à
noël ou jusqu'à jusqu'à plus tard encore
il a fallu qu'ils aient cette cette
histoire de plan de transport adapté et
que la sncf a mise en service pour les
deux semaines des vacances de la
toussaint qui n'a jamais lieu d'habitude
qui revient à réduire le service de
l'ordre de 8% je crois de mémoire
c'est très pratique ça parce qu'en fait
ça officialise les suppressions de
trains envoyée la sncf annonce ça donc
comme ça tout le monde est censé savoir
que ces trois là seront supprimés tous
les jours voilà ça empêchera pas tient
d'autant plus d'ailleurs d'être
supprimés et puis surtout ça enlève ses
trains la des statistiques de la sncm
boyet du fait qu'ils ont été prévus à
l'avance comme ne circulant pas ce ne
sont plus des trains supprimés c'est
très pratique ça va permettre d'en
jolivet les statistiques et nous ça ne
nous convient pas du tout c'est une
manière de mettre la poussière sous le
tapis voilà et donc la sncf si c'était
une entreprise vraiment en sérieuse
j'utilise le mot elle aurait pris des
mesures avant ça avant qu'ils aient tous
ces problèmes avant que la mécontents
que le mécontentement
soient tous les jours et que ça dissuade
même des gens de prendre le train parce
que nous notre objectif c'est que les
gens prennent le train il avec une
fiabilité qui atteint ce niveau là
franchement ça n'est plus possible
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à notre rubrique les
électeurs ont la parole la dernière
partie de ce sens public maintenant
chaque semaine vous le savez on passe au
crible les propositions des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
presque toute la gauche propose de
travailler moi idées neuves aux idées
courtes c'est la question du jour
avant d'en débattre la réponse d'un
patron celui de ldc elle c'est le numéro
1 français de la vente de matériel
informatique et du high tech en ligne
depuis janvier dernier le groupe
applique la semaine de 32 heures sur 4
jours sans perte de salaire reportage à
limonest c'est dans la banlieue de lyon
avec flora sauvage c'est un patron pas
comme les autres en janvier dernier à
l'occasion des 25 ans de sa société de
vente de matériel informatique
laurent de la clergerie président
fondateur de ldlc a instauré la semaine
de quatre jours sans perte de salaire
pour ses équipes un jour j'ai lu un
article sur microsoft qui avait testé la
semaine de quatre jours au japon pendant
un mois en offrant un vendredi assez
équipe et qui avait eu 40 % d'efficacité
en plus et en fait c'est surtout que ça
a planté une idée que j'avais jamais eu
c'est à dire quatre jours tiens ça m'est
venu dans la tête et du coup je me suis
dit mais si on travaillait quelques
jours est ce que ça pourrait marcher
chez nous pour passer ces 1000 salariés
à la semaine de quatre jours
laurent de la clergerie avait prévu
d'embaucher et de dépenser 2 millions
d'euros mais finalement cela ne lui a
quasiment rien coûté j'ai eu une
surprise on l'a recruté personne les
gens font en quatre jours et en 32
heures le travail qu'ils faisaient avant
en 35 voire je pense même qu en réalité
sont encore plus efficace que ça on a
gagné en efficacité
et donc je leur ai demandé mais comment
vous sentez est ce que vous êtes très c
est ce que l on fait ça les faisait
sourire quand je parlais tout ça parce
que que valence et non on se sent bien
on est heureux effectivement on fait le
même travail qu'avant mais on est
reposée c'est plus la même semaine
pourtant au départ certains salariés
sont dubitatifs à l'instar de jean
claude qui a choisi de vendredi comme
jours off j'étais un peu sceptique je
savais pas comment j'allais rentrer
l'intégralité de mes tâches d'enfin que
dans quatre jours ça fait déjà du mal
sur 5 il a fait le contrôle des rues
noël de nouvelles ressources finalement
nous optimiser notre temps de travail
réduire peut-être aussi
le temps consacré au rendez-vous
extérieur par exemple huit mois après la
mise en place de la semaine de quatre
jours les salariés sont unanimes au
siège comme dans les boutiques de
l'entreprise donc les pièces sont
garantis 2 ans guti là c'est un souci ou
passez directement vers mes collègues à
l'atelier à la semaine aussi parce
beaucoup plus vite
psychologiquement c'est ça rien à voir
et même un petit regain de julia de
motivation parce que du coup ça donne
envie de s'investir un petit peu plus
dans la dans la boutique et la société
donc un pari gagnant pour l'entreprise
qui a demandé quelques ajustements on a
introduit beaucoup plus de polyvalence
dans le travail de chacun
le but étant qu'ils aient une continuité
c'est à dire que partir du moment où
quelqu'un est en jour off
on peut pas s'arrêter parce qu'ils en
jouant au foot dont qui il a fallu
développer des outils des stratégies
pour que le travail continue et que
l'information circule huit mois après la
mise en place de la semaine de quatre
jours 80% des salariés l'ont déjà adopté
des salariés visiblement plus heureux au
travail qui sont aussi devenus plus
productifs l'entreprise ldlc a connu une
croissance de 46 % de son chiffre
d'affaires l'an passé
travailler moins idées neuves aux idées
courtes on en débat je vous présente mes
invités cendrars gaulle bonjour vous
êtes secrétaire nationale adjointe du
parti europe ecologie les verts anne
sophie elle si bonjour bonsoir
d'ailleurs on peut dire bonsoir un
violeur vous êtes chef économiste au bdo
france cabinet de conseil et d'audit
robin rivaton bonsoir investisseurs et
économistes vous publiez sur un autre
thème je cite votre livre souriez vous
êtes filmés c2d édition de
l'observatoire avec nous également en
visioconférence gilbert cet économiste
professeur
neoma business school vous étiez l'un
des inspirateurs de la réforme des 35
heures de martine aubry matthieu
croissandeau toujours à mes côtés est
évidemment bon quand on quand on passe
au crible comme sa une une proposition
de campagne je fais un petit tour de
table rapide semble golvin an après les
35 heures on peut pas dire que c'est une
idée neuve est ce que c'est pour autant
une idée courte ce qui serait une idée
courte c'est de revenir dessus et de
pensée
aller à l'encontre du sens de l'histoire
là aujourd'hui on a des jeunes
générations qui aspirent à avoir plus de
temps pour leurs familles pour eux mêmes
et on a même des exemples on est de
montrer à travers ce reportage comme
ldlc ou en fait le temps rendu le temps
de vie fait des employés qui travaillent
mieux et qu'ils sont plus heureux et
c'est même le pari que fait au départ
cet entrepreneur qui n'est pas un
philanthrope mais qui est vraiment un
entrepreneur et donc il ya coeur d'avoir
les meilleures rentabilités possible
pour son entreprise c'est de dire si mes
salariés sont plus heureux alors ça
fonctionnera mieux et ça a l'air d'après
ce que vous nous en montrer huit mois
après d'être plutôt une formule de
succès oui alors c'est un exemple
évidemment la question c'est d'une
généralisation et sous et sous quelle
forme parce que c'est ça derrière une
promesse de de campagne rob arrive at on
idée neuve aux idées courtes travailler
moins il des anciennes là les premières
idées sur la réduction du temps de
travail c'est 1993 le premier débat de
pierre larrouturou donc une idée qui a
traversé tout champ politique et un
passant de la droite à la gauche l'idée
qui a plutôt montré ses effets négatifs
en tout cas si on impose une personne
n'empêche une entreprise de travail et
32 heures si elles veulent faire votre
exemple le monde parfaitement
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a un cadre
qui est loin d'être optimale mais en
tout cas qui fonctionne donc autant le
garder autant garder le cas de votre
avis à celles ci alors déjà la réponse
allait aussi binaire c'est
vrai que laurianne comme quand vous
regardez tout le xxème siècle et la fin
des révolutions industrielles on a eu
une baisse du temps de travail en raison
de la robotisation et du progrès
technique c'est le progrès technique le
progrès technique fait que vous avez en
effet une baisse du temps de travail on
va continuer là dedans donc c'est vrai
que la cité ne sais pas en fait le temps
de travail globale la question c'est par
rapport à quoi quand on avoue libye
c'est le temps de travail c'était pour
augmenter en tout cas essayer de faire
baisser le taux de chômage donc là
le but c'est d'avoir une réflexion mais
art secteur et surtout par rapport à la
compétitivité vous n'êtes pas de réponse
globale la réponse doit être par secteur
par la branche et c'est les entreprises
qui doivent négocier elle-même et puis à
vraiment l'aspect progrès technique
parce qu'on sait en effet plus les
emplois qui ont un impact et qui sont
impactés par le progrès techniques et
via ce sont des emplois la semaine des
32 heures ce sont des ingénieurs de la
ruhr en allemagne qui l'ont proposé donc
là aussi c'est pas en effet des
défilants propre des secteurs qui sert
ce le signe cherché à faire moins de
profits pourquoi parce qu'en effet on a
vu que quand vous avez une baisse du
temps de travail vous avez une
augmentation de la productivité horaire
d'ailleurs enfants vous avez un des taux
de productivité horaire les plus élevées
de l'europe et vous avez aussi plus de
créativité et d'innovation et pour les
emplois qui sont très impactées par le
progrès technique c'est positif après
dans les services c'est très différent
parce que là en effet c'est des emplois
qui sont non délocalisables il y avait
l'idée en fait de se dire qu on baissait
le temps de travail dans les services
pour et bien favorisé l'embauché et pour
favoriser l'emploi donc c'est vraiment
très important de se dire emplois
industriels compétitivité internationale
versa emplois dans les services non
délocalisables alors la france
travaille-t-elle moins que les autres on
va répondre à cette question et je
voudrais d'abord faire un peu d'histoire
législatives avec quentin calme et
bonsoir cantat bienvenue vous on va
remonter grâce à vous a même un peu plus
un peu plus loin jusqu'à la seconde
guerre mondiale oui tout à fait je vais
commencer par vous donner une
statistique effectivement un thomas
depuis à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale durée annuelle du temps de
travail des salariés a baissé de près
d'un quart depuis effectivement les 145
quel style en fait depuis le début des
années 2000 donc voici effectivement un
petit retour en arrière des grandes
étapes de l'aménagement du temps de
travail des salariés en france alors on
a tous en tête en fait même avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale ces grandes
mesures ces deux grandes mesures
adoptées par le front populaire en 1936
ce sont les deux semaines de congés
payés et la semaine de 40 heures sans
démission de salaire avec les trente
glorieuses on le voit ensuite les
salariés profitent de nouvelles semaines
en fait deux congés payés et en 1982
sous la présidence de françois
mitterrand élu alors avec les
communistes les salariés passent aux 39
heures et bénéficie d'une cinquième
semaine de congés payés la réduction du
temps de travail prend une nouvelle
ampleur avec les lois aubry dont vous
avez déjà commencé à parler au début des
années 2000 mais en fait le mouvement
était déjà lancé depuis la loi de robien
c'était en 1996 donc c'était à ce moment
là sous la présidence de jacques chirac
met donc avec ses lois aubry les
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
passent aux 35 heures puis les autres à
partir de 2002 et en fait on voit
ensuite un mouvement d'aller retour les
gouvernements fillon reviendra sur ses
35 heures avec la loi tepa qui vise à
exonérer les cotisations à des heures
supplémentaires puis souffrance au long
du rhin mouvement comme ça inverse la
gauche est revenu sur ces mesures
emmanuel macron dans 1 dans l'autre sens
en 2019 mais donc depuis le début des
années 2000 ce qu'on note c'est que le
temps de travail est globalement stable
merci quand un emmanuel macron vous en
parliez à l'instant le prêt dans la nuit
qui veut que les français travaillent
plus on les écoute c'était lors de la
présentation du plan d'investissement
france 2030 quand on se compare nous
sommes un pays qui travaille moins que
les autres en quantité ça reste vrai et
donc nous avons une quantité de travail
à louer qui n'est pas au bon niveau à la
fois dans le cycle de vie en horaire
cumulée et au fond on a une force qui
est notre modèle social et éducatif en a
une faiblesse c'est qu'on a plus le
modèle productif qui permet de le
financer
c'est ça notre grande incohérence
nous sommes dans un pays qui travaille
moins que les autres je sais pas si vous
allez être d'accord pour faire le
constat on n'a pas encore entendu gilles
verse est là dessus est ce que la france
est un pays qui travaille moins que les
autres et d'abord si vous m'y autorise
et je te répondre à votre première
question
allez-y mais rapidement alors bouger il
faut qu'on avance dans l'historique mans
historiquement la le temps de travail
était divisé par deux voiliers depuis le
milieu du 19e siècle il a été divisé par
deux comment et bien tout simplement
parce qu'il a été financée c'était tout
très bien dit précédemment c'est et
financés par des gains de productivité
par le progrès technique pour et
technique a permis de financer à la fois
une augmentation du pouvoir d'achat et
une augmentation du temps de loisirs
voyez les gains de productivité était
assez fort aujourd'hui le plus 15 ans
les introductive heat et son très faible
0 5% par an on n'a pas de quoi financer
simultanément la transition écologique
le désendettement public le
vieillissement de la population les
aspirations une hausse de pouvoir
d'achat et une augmentation du temps de
loisirs cette augmentation du temps de
loisirs si elle peut avoir lieu elle
sera nécessairement financée par ses
bénéficiaires mais elle pourra pas être
financés par des gains de productivité
qui ne sont pas là qui ne sont pas au
rendez vous c'est un élément fondamental
à prendre en compte effectivement mais
merci de l'avoir rajouter et donc la
question est ce que la france travaille
moins que les autres et par ailleurs sur
le cycle de vie la france travaille
évidemment moins que les autres l'âge de
départ à la retraite est en france
beaucoup plus bas que dans d'autres pays
l'espérance de retraite est beaucoup
plus élevé que dans d'autres pays c'est
ça la principale différence qu'il faut
noter entre la france et ses principaux
partenaires économiques alors sur sur ce
constat de la durée annuelle du temps de
travail dont j'ai un peu lu tout et son
contraire
c'est difficile d'avoir un constat
partagé quels conseils vous fait il ya
plusieurs façons de calculer videmment
si vous regardez les gens à un instant t
les gens qui travaillent vous prenez pas
en compte le fait que mon travail les
français ne travaillent pas quand ils
sont jeunes et ils travaillent ils
partent à la retraite plus tôt donc la
seule façon de calculer ça c'est de
ramener le volume annuel de travail donc
toutes les heures travaillées dans le
pays ils sont des heures déclaratives
donc je sens mesure tout ce que chacun
fait et on divise par le nombre
d'habitants le nombre d'habitants entre
20 ans et 65 ans et quand on fait cette
mesure on voit que la france et le pays
de nos cd eux qui travaillent le moins
are an par habitant je ne dis pas par
salarié je dis bien par habitant est
donc on avait trouvé 32e sur 38 en
europe le rallye nature qu'il derrière
nous dans le cd m et voilà on est
vraiment dans les derniers on travaille
1200 heures par an en 2100 pardon aux
heures par an là où les allemands
travaillent 1200 les autres et les
australiens et les suis au travail
vous êtes en train de donner ses
chiffres et nous on n'a pas trouvé les
mêmes jeux là nous mêmes sources il va
regarder les travailleurs à temps plein
résistance des habitants des
travailleurs c'est compliqué quand même
de parler de cette taille djabi n'ont
pas accès au travail et vous verrez oui
c'est bien ce que l'on dit on dit qu'on
veut en volume de travail le total du
volume et de darwin gens qui travaillent
ce serait bien de rester sur le sujet
sur lequel on est en fait non en tout 1
du volume travis payne dans le pays pour
me payer le fait que certaines travaille
on travaille pas c'est très différent
pour arriver à les faire tomber
sciemment c'est un geste rhétorique à
ses habituels la réalité ce sont les
chiffres de l' ocde oui mais même si on
est 32e sur 38 on peut pas forcément
s'en satisfaire là on est on est on est
on est déjà pas l'un des pays de l'osce
et d eux qui travaillent le travail le
plus ça vous est faite selon les
chiffres de l' ocde si on prend le temps
de travail annuel la france elle est
entre mille 4500 heures et les pays qui
sont loin derrière celle allemagne
danemark etc qui sont autour de 1300
heures donc non on ne travaille pas
moins que les autres tout à fait c'est
en deuxième sur 38 oui mais c'est soit
il faut regarder ce qu'il ya derrière
comme vous l'avez dit par rapport au
nombre d'habitants le problème en france
qu'on a un chômage structurel à 8% et on
n'a pas de plein emploi donc on en effet
on a un taux d'activité des moins de 25
des plus de 55 ans qui est très bas par
rapport au reste de la peau de la
population en europe mais c'est pas
forcément c'est souvent dû contre un
c'est pas du volontaire donc en fait on
a un problème de marché du temps de
travail du taux de chômage qui explique
quand on fait cette comparaison quand on
prend tout le monde va forcément on a
les heurs plus basse et juste pour finir
là-dessus sur ce débat du temps travail
- à mon sens ce n'est plus le débat en
fait aujourd'hui le débat c'est que le
nombre d'heures travaillées mais c'est
la valeur ajoutée que vous produisez et
c'est ça le sujet même en effet dans un
contexte on a des gains de productivité
qui vont cesser de décroître notamment
avec le vieillissement la numérisation
la question c'est quelle valeur ajoutée
vous créez nous en effet on a le
problème comme on est spécialisée dans
les services qui crée moins de valeur
ajoutée que dans l'industrie d'où la
preuve la problématique de la
réindustrialisation est de faire revenir
des activités productives mais un
ingénieur qui va créer une formule
mathématique ou un lot garric qui va le
vendre à google et qui va le vendre des
milliards d'euros est bien en temps de
travail l'a peut-être fait ça en deux
heures bon c'est pas pour ça qu'il va
être énumérées les milliards d'euros
qu'il a
créée en termes de valeur ajoutée donc
c'est vrai que et la numérisation et la
transition écologique et vieillissement
fait exploser la norme qu'on pouvait
avoir classique en disant voilà une
heure travaillée tant de valeur ajoutée
produite ça va vraiment dépendre encore
une fois du progrès technique alors ce
débat et la fois économique on est
vraiment sûr c'est sur ces questions et
il est aussi politique matthieu
croissandeau parce que évidemment on en
a déjà parlé quand on quand on dit
travailler - allez peut-être jusqu'à 32
heures par semaine ya le totem des 35
heures qui apparaît totem ou sparadrap
d'affaires pour pour la gauche c'est un
peu les deux je vous parle d'une date
c'était 24 ans le 10 octobre 97 jean
gandois qui était alors le patron des
patrons patron du cnpf l'ancêtre du
medef sortait sur le plan matignon et 10
et nous avons été bernés il sortait d'un
rendez-vous où lionel jospin venait de
lui annoncer que les 35 heures serait
faite par la loi alors que lui pensait
que ça serait par la négociation on y
retrouve qui en plus était proche de
martine aubry qui l'avait embauché comme
directrice générale adjointe quand il
dirige et pechiney tu pensais être en
confiance et il a été bien de quoi je
vous raconte ça parce qu'en fait de ce
depuis cette date là il ya les 35 heures
sont vendus à la fois un enjeu
idéologique il ya un objet de bataille
politique et c'est pour la gauche un
totem c'est la dernière grande réforme
sociale inscrite au fronton du parti
socialiste mais c'est aussi un sparadrap
qui lui revient dans la figure à chaque
échéance électorale fois d'abord parce
que sur un plan économique le bilan est
mitigé
popularisé après la sortie d'un livre de
jeremy rifkin qui s'appelait la fin du
travail les 35 heures ont été conçus en
tout cas vendu comme l'idée que ça
allait créer des emplois partage de
travail pour créer des emplois dans les
faits l'insee parle d'un bilan entre 300
et 400 mille emplois créés les
économistes sont très divisés parce
qu'au fond on se demande qu'est ce qui a
créé l'emploi est ce que c'est la
réduction de la durée légale de 39 à 35
heures ou est-ce que c'est toutes les
mesures d'accompagnement qui est avec
qui son gigantesque opération de baisse
des charges surtout une gigantesque
opération de plus pour plus de
flexibilité à travers notamment
l'annualisation du temps de travail la
modulation du temps de travail qui
étaient fournis en échange sur un plan
social les salariés eux mêmes sont
partagés sur les bénéfices de cette
flexibilité on se souvient qu'à l'époque
ça plutôt bénéficié aux cadres il y
avait une après midi par semaine
plus d'argent et qui partait en week-end
à une demi journée plus tôt c'était
l'époque c'est là que ça explose et les
city trips le week end partez visiter
les capitales européennes et les
ouvriers eux certains avaient plutôt une
de la version une deux entre 20 et une
demi-heure de moins par jour et e on
aurait préféré à l'époque plutôt du
salaire que des loisirs qui ne pouvaient
pas si on parle du coup politique le
coût pour la gauche tout coup politique
pour le coup il a été réelle parce que
la gauche n'a jamais été remerciés des
35 heures souvenez-vous que jospin était
battu en 2002 alors qu'elle ait fait
cette grande réforme sociale et surtout
parce que la droite s'est emparée de ce
sujet pour en faire un angle d'attaqué
récurrents alors à les entendre les 35
heures auraient fait chuter la producti
la compétitivité de la france c'est un
peu plus compliqué dans les faits parce
qu'on fait de la compétitivité et je
suis top avec la montée de la chine avec
des réformes schröder en allemagne ont
donc glissant fait avant la mise en
place des 35 heures les plus largement
la droite en fait reproche à la gauche
d'avoir dégradé la fameuse valeur
travail comme si elle avait encouragé
une forme de droit à la paresse sans
refrain classique qu'est devenu à chaque
élection vous l'entendez encore un de
ceux qui défendent aujourd'hui la valeur
travail comme s'ils avaient été déviés
berger à l'image du laxisme supposé de
la gauche avec la criminalité vous savez
on dit toujours sur la sécurité et la
gauche laxiste soit là elle aurait
dégradé la valeur travail l'ironie du
sort c'est que depuis vingt ans la
droite elle a gouverné dix ans et que
même si elle a on en a parlé tout à
l'heure dévitalisées l'esprit des lois
aubry elle ne se n'est jamais revenu sur
la durée légale qui est toujours à 35
heures en grande partie parce que
beaucoup d'entreprises maintenant ils
sont opposés l'ajb recette vous étiez
l'un des inspirateurs de cette réforme
quel bilan vous en fait de deux
décennies plus tard
écoutez je pense et je l'avais écrit à
l'époque d'ailleurs je pense que ça a
été un échec dans deux domaines est une
réussite dans un autre domaine là ça a
été un échec c'est pour l'ensemble de la
fonction publique ça a été réalisée de
la plus mauvaise des façons avec une
réduction de la durée du travail de
personnes qui pour il pour certaines
d'ailleurs en l'ignorant sans savoir
avec une modalités de décompte identique
à celle du secteur privé être déjà à 35
heures voire parfois en dessous et puis
au delà du secteur oui on a beaucoup
parlé de l'hôpital ça a été un échec
dans l'articulation avec avec le salaire
minimum
l'instauration de garantie mensuel la
dynamisation du salaire minimum dans son
mécanisme de détermination et de
revalorisation par la baisse même de la
durée du travail tout ça a renchéri le
coût du travail des peu qualifiés il a
fallu éviter des effets désastreux sur
la compétitivité par un développement
des allègements de charges mais vraiment
considérable très cher donc c'est cesser
de bilan voyez des deux échecs et la
réussite
globalement les entreprises ont absorbé
cette réduction du temps de travail
pourquoi et bien parce que ça se sait
accompagné de beaucoup d'innovation
l'instauration du forfait jour
le jeu dire là la création d'un seul
système de modulation du temps de
travail beaucoup plus simple puisqu'il
existait auparavant
le fait de faire passer dans la
législation française la définition de
ce que c'est que les temps de travail
effectif
et qui est défini au niveau européen et
ça ça finances et déjà le tiers de la
réduction de ton travail voyez des
innovations qui ont été très riches et
qui se sont associés à des accords de
réduction du temps de travail qui geler
ou qui modérait la progression des
salaires à un moment on avait beaucoup
de tension sur le marché du travail je
rappelle qu'en 2000 on a créé un nombre
d'emplois comme peu d'années durant ce
ces 150 dernières années donc voyez le
le bilan est un peu un peu mitigé très
juste quand même revenir sur deux points
si vous m'y a autorisé les et le premier
point quand on compare le temps de
travail durant l'année c'est vrai avec
les incertitudes de ce genre de mesures
je ne suis pas sûr que la france soit
derrière d'autres d'autres pays qui sont
très performants sur le plan économique
par contre sur le cycle de vie là ça ne
fait aucun doute encore une fois les
français partent plus tôt en retraite
que les autres il suffit de lire les
rapports du conseil d'orientation des
retraites du cor pour pour s'en rendre
compte c'est très très bien montré et
puis une dernière chose on dit souvent
oui mais en france on peut se permettre
ça parce qu'on a un niveau de
productivité très élevé mais pourquoi on
a un niveau de productivité très élevé
justement parce qu'on laisse sur le bord
de la route les gens les moins qualifiés
c'est eux
qui sont sur représentés parmi les
chômeurs et parmi les personnes qui ne
sont pas en emploi alors quand on écarte
l'emploi les personnes les moins
qualifiées mécaniquement sahel la
productivité horaire du travail de ceux
qui sont en emploi oui bon c'est un
raisonnement pour l'inclure petit imité
en trompe l'oeil c'est ce qui vous êtes
en train de nous dire vous parliez de
l'âge de la retraite on va écouter jean
luc mélenchon le candidat de la france
insoumise qui lui veut aller plus loin
et parle d'une retraite à 60 ans et
coûté lusage le plus intelligent qu'on
peut faire de cette masse produite en
temps inférieur c'est de partager le
temps de travail si on partage le temps
de travail on travaillera tous et on
travaillera mieux comme l'ont montré
toutes les expériences de réduction du
temps de travail réduire le temps de
travail ça veut dire dans la semaine ça
veut dire dans l'année et ça veut dire
dans la vie c'est la raison pour
laquelle je défend la thèse de la
retraite à 60 ans et je vais contre tous
ceux qui ont dit comment vit plus
longtemps faut travailler plus longtemps
j'ai toujours dit si on vit plus
longtemps c'est parce qu'on travaille
moins longtemps
s'arrêter à 60 ans dit jean luc
mélenchon qui travaillent encore à l'âge
de 66 ans c'est ce que je dis pas ce que
je fais non mais au-delà de ça au delà
de la blague
c est ce que sandra vous écoutez depuis
un moment le débat j'ai l'impression
mathieu disais c'est un marqueur
politique est-ce que c'est pas
idéologique le fait de mettre cette
mesure-là au programme d'europe écologie
les verts justement pour s'ancrer à
gauche parce que et est-ce que c'est pas
contradictoire avec le pragmatisme
affiché par votre candidat c'est surtout
aller dans le sens de l'histoire c'est
une logique qui a toujours été celle des
écologistes parce qu'en fait respecter
les temps de vie c'est quelque chose de
primordial si on veut une société
apaisée et qui fonctionne encore une
fois confère l'exemple que vous preniez
un début d'explication en revanche ce
qui est un totem ce qui est vraiment
idéologique c'est cette passion qu'à la
droite française pour faire passer ce
pays pour un pays de paresseux pour un
pays de gens qui refuseraient de
travailler et c'est pour ça que
je m'excuse nous avons plutôt terre
c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
pénible d'avoir des gens qui utilisent
les chiffres qui joue avec les chiffres
n'ont pas pour essayer de comprendre
comment est-ce qu'on peut avancer offrir
plus de travail avoir plus de moyens
pour financer l'éducation la transition
écologique et d'autre mais qui cherche
justement à s'accaparer en totem assez
dépassé disons le franchement qui est
celui qui consisterait à dépeindre la
france comme un pays de fainéants et
donc sur cette base là arriver à faire
passer toutes les pilules recul est de
plus en plus l'âge de la retraite donner
de moins en moins de droits aux gens qui
pourtant ont cotisé je pense notamment
la à la réforme du chômage l'assurance
chômage et ainsi de suite et ça c'est
pas tolérable et c'est justement là
contre ça a contrario de ça que
s'inscrivent les écologistes en
proposant un projet de société dans
lequel la relocalisation de l'économie
la réindustrialisation du pays
permettent non seulement de créer plus
d'emplois des emplois qui préserve le
climat dont qui allège la dépense
publique les 100 milliards d'euros qu'on
me dépasse qu'on dépense chaque année en
france pour compenser ce qu'on a détruit
ce n'est pas possible c'est l'équivalent
du plant de relance que chaque année
nous dilapidons littéralement juste
parce qu'on n'est pas capable d'avoir
des politiques qui prennent les
décisions protectrice tout ça est
vertueux et c'est pour ça que ce n'est
pas un totem que c'est extrêmement
pragmatique et que nous tenons
énormément as à ce respect la diminution
du temps de travail avec un bémol et
j'en termine la dgi qui que ce n'est pas
la même chose dans chaque secteur
d'activité et que la priorité quand on
parle de réduire encore plus le temps de
travail c'est de se pencher d'abord sur
les besoins des conditions de travail
des personnes y aura une grande
consultation secteur par secteur social
à une surtout pas de voix et si l'on est
pas loin ça c'est une question qui
arrive en second 1 seconde et une loi
raison de l'implantation jusqu'à ce que
soient les secteurs c'est ce qu'a montré
les récents nourrissent et logis forme
et je finis la loi ou pas la loi ça
c'est ce qui ressort de la consultation
qui doit être mené avec les entreprises
avec les différentes branches
d'activités pour déterminer ce qu'il ya
des secteurs où c'est sur la semaine qui
ferait dur l'emploi de retrousser sur
l'année d'autres où c'est sur le rythme
de vie ce n'est pas du tout la même
chose compris mathieu et ensuite le 10
octobre c'est exactement ça règle en
réunion négociations et ça s'est fini
par une loi donc c'est parce que c'est
compliqué tout ce qui tombe d'en haut et
à partir du moment où on fait de façon
uniforme pour les petites comme pour les
grandes entreprises dans tous les
secteurs ça ne marche pas c'est ce qu'a
montré des 35 heures ça profite aux
grosses entreprises qui ont les moyens
de mettre en place pour les petites
c'est compliqué parce qu'on peut pas
remplacer on avait dit à l'époque 1/2 un
gars essaient y voit assez 90% par
ailleurs il ya quand même un décalage
aussi dans la schizophrénie mentale des
français qui vous pour certains veulent
réduire le temps de travail et pour
certains veulent se faire livrer leurs
courses jusqu'à minuit ou toute la nuit
où il faut tout le temps disponible
aucun moment à faire choisir entre
modèles de travail les modèles de
consommation vauzelle de vie sans pales
de compétitivité robin arrive à toi
est-ce qu'on peut la france peut rester
compétitive avec un abaissement du temps
de travail alors mensuel ou surtout sur
la vie vous pouvez répondre aux deux
aspects et d'une certaine façon à jean
luc mélenchon si vous voulez évidemment
que non aujourd'hui si la france encore
une fois sur le cycle de vie je viens de
l'expliquer c'est pas de la manipulation
des chiffres c'est les chiffres qu'ils
le disent sur le cycle de vie
malheureusement on est un pays qui ne
travaille pas c'est donc si aujourd'hui
on veut réduire la quantité de travail
fait sur le cycle de vie aujourd'hui
c'est réduire la production de richesses
dans le pays et donc c'est réduire ce
que l'on aura tous pour consommer pour
vivre à la sortie il faut bien se rendre
compte qu'on est dans un monde où le
capital s'échangent par tous
l'information s'échangent par tous le
niveau de formation des individus
s'échangent par tous donc au final tous
les facteurs qui pouvait faire une
différence entre les pays aujourd'hui
sont à peu près à elles mêmes à égaler
go à travers le monde donc ce qui fait
la différence c'est le volume de travail
comme était derrière nous si vous vous
produisez moins de richesse vous êtes
moins riches à la fin d'année vous avez
moins consommer et juste pour finir sur
voulez vous inscrire dans le sens de
l'histoire je vous invite à la relire
puisqu'en fait la réduction du temps de
travail
parce que la réduction de temps de
travail elle commence avec pierre
larrouturou en 93 qui convoie un député
rpr de déposer une proposition de loi
sur les 32 heures en 1995 ses charmes
millions président de la région rhône
alpes rhône alpes à l'époque fait passer
les 35 heures dans la fonction publique
et le candidat chirac à peine élu va
visiter les usines pas skier en 95 qui
est une usine qui a fait l'arrêt mais
réduction des 35 heures donc on voit
bien que la première force politique à
avoir saisi la réduction du temps de
travail ce n'est pas la gauche c'est la
droite qui deux ans plus tard s'est fait
complètement doublé sur ses muses cette
mesure par la gauche et là il commence
avec les tickets donc vous pouvez vous
inscrire dans le sens de l'histoire
inscrivez-vous dans les traces du rpr de
93 et on verra s'il s'avoue
pour un robot d'air par rapport à ça moi
je viendrai plus sur les chiffres de
l'insee modestie fraudes et des
instituts nationaux de choses sur la
compétitivité qu'est ce qui fait la
france a perdu de la compétitivité c'est
vraiment le niveau de gamme des produits
qu'elle a exporté donc c'est
véritablement ça qui a fait qu'on s'est
mis sur du moyen de gamme on a peu
investi avec des prix de vente des
produits industriels élevés et donc on a
pris de plein fouet la concurrence
asiatique alors que les autres pays
comme notamment l'allemagne ont investi
massivement dans les compétences et donc
ont augmenté et bien le sait vous de ce
palier la baisse
c'est vraiment le problème de
positionnement de gamme et c'est pour ça
qu'on en revient ou pouvait dire et me
reprendre ses statistiques de toute
façon vous êtes dans la vieillit cement
énorme de la population donc d'ici 20
ans vous aurez une augmentation des
petites 60 ans qui va augmenter donc
vous aurez des gains de productivité qui
vont complètement s'effondrer donc là
vous pouvez faire après travailler les
gens m'aiment abstrait on parle de la
catégorie des 70 80 ans donc après on
peut faire travailler ces catégories là
mais de toute façon on aura un
effondrement de ses gains de
productivité dans un
domaine où on aura en effet la question
de financement de la protection sociale
et de la retraite donc encore une fois
la seule molle seul moyen de s'en sortir
c'est vraiment le progrès technique les
compétences et l'innovation le temps de
travail c'est vraiment je tairai pas
débat du 20e siècle mais à mon sens ce
n'est pas comme ça que vous allez créer
beaucoup beaucoup de valeur ajoutée
c'est ce dont on a besoin vous avez dit
oui moins de gens travaillent là la
quantité de rush de richesses créées
pendant une année non quand vous
regardez les fameux tableau entre
assorti bin c'est la valeur ajoutée
créée par secteur vous voyez que c'est
l'industrie parlait plus que dans les
services où vous avez un temps de
travail qui est souvent beaucoup plus
faible donc il n'ya pas de corrélation
entre la valeur ajoutée créée et le
temps de travail effectif
je voudrais qu'on parle sur le
l'opportunité de cette réforme dans le
climat économique le le taux de chômage
les chiffres sont pour le troisième
trimestre sont tombés aujourd'hui 200
6000 inscrits en moins au troisième
trimestre jb recettes je reviens vers
vous j'espère que vous allez répondre à
ma question et pas aux précédentes cette
fois ci même si j'offre beaucoup de
liberté avait invité il ya aucun souci
le chômage est en baisse est ce que ce
serait le bon moment pour réduire la
durée de travail hebdomadaire
égouttez les créations d'emplois sont
très fortes le chômage est en baisse et
on est l'économie française se heurte à
des difficultés de recrutement massif
cercle s'est pas l'emploi qui manque
c'est les gens qui qui se dirige vers
ses emplois c'est ça qui manque en ce
moment et donc la difficulté c'est pas
de juste dire et de se répartir un
gâteau qui ne changerait pas de taille
si on va diviser le temps de travail je
suis considère que maintenant ils
changeraient de évidemment taille la
difficulté c'est d'amener les personnes
vers l'emploi rendant ces emplois plus
attractif voyez donc la poursuite de la
reprise économique des créations
d'emplois et de la baisse du chômage qui
est essentiel pour qu'on redevienne un
pays normal je rappelle que parmi les
pays d'olt cédé 2,38 les blessés deux on
n'a que quatre qui avaient un taux de
chômage supérieur au nôtre avant la
crise qu vide 4 c'est tout tous les
autres étaient quasiment au plein emploi
le problème de chômage ne laissez pas au
contraire ils connaissaient des
problèmes de manque de main d'oeuvre
donc nous on a si vous voulez les
problèmes de manque de main d'oeuvre de
pays qui sont plein emploi comme
l'allemagne les pays-bas alors qu'on a
un taux de chômage des pays du sud de
l'europe très élevé qui eux n'ont pas de
manque de main d'oeuvre en ce moment
donc il ya un problème de fonctionnement
du marché du travail est assez
spécifique à la france c'est l'une des
priorités à laquelle on doit s'attaquer
pour que la baisse du chômage se
poursuivent et qui est création
d'emplois puissent
évidemment bénéficier à l'économie
française est ce que l'objectif son art
gold une telle mesure c'est de faire
baisser le chômage d'une telle mesure de
diminution du temps oui il est l'un des
objectifs c'est de diminuer le chômage
mais aussi d'améliorer les conditions de
vie des salariés c'est à dire que on a
bien abordé c'est en tout ce n'est pas
juste diminuer le temps de travail par
semaine dans l'année ou au fil de la vie
mais c'est offrir d'autres conditions de
travail c'est à dire créer de nouveaux
secteurs d'activité ce que la france ne
fait plus vous y est revenu à plusieurs
reprises il n'y a pas d'innovation de
lancement de nouveaux secteurs d'avenir
là où d'autres pays ont investi nos
jeunes qui est en train de se de secret
et de se structurer on peut parler de
l'art ya un type de filière hydrogène
est en train d'être assurée en train
d'être imaginé mais qui n'est pas une
innovation c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
investi sur les énergies de demain là où
d'autres pays l'ont fait parce que
président de la république avec le plan
celui 30 c'est dommage qu'il ait pas les
pleins pouvoirs et à l'assemblée
nationale et au gouvernement pour mettre
en place ce soir le média tu mens et
d'être déjà en fin de mandat tout ceci
en fin de match mais trêve de
plaisanterie et donc il ya un tout avoir
c'est pas juste est-ce qu'on diminue
encore le temps de travail mais comment
on le diminue et comment est ce qu'on
fait en sorte qu'on reste dans un cercle
créateurs d'emplois parce que si on ne
crée pas de nouveaux emplois la question
de travailler plus ou de travailler
moins
ce n'est même plus la question prégnante
si on a si on adopte pas en plan de
formation qui soit corrélé au secteur
d'activité que l'on développe alors
toutes ces questions qu'on se pose sur
le temps de travail donc aussi rien à
voir il ya des pays où on a travaillé
très bien des pays voisins sur la
transition je pense notamment l vous
n'avez pas entendu parler de la sortie
du charbon en espagne pourtant elle est
réelle ça a été accompagnée de plans de
formation pour les personnes de création
de nouveaux secteurs d'activité pour
absorber cette activité nouvelle ces
gens qui perdent leur emploi et c'est ça
qu'il faut penser aujourd'hui le
problème c'est qu'on est effectivement
dans une chasse aux totems où il ya une
gauche en tout on lisait il ya une
droite qui ne sait plus comment se
radicaliser et qu'au milieu de tout ça
et là les françaises et les français je
suis désolé d'être écologiste d'avoir
des valeurs à gauche de ne pas être issu
de leur histoire ce qui me permet de
parler assez tranquillement et de la
droite et de la gauche mais c'est la
réalité dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui
parce que nous on propose si je peux
parler pour ma paroisse c'est justement
de faire autre membre de miser sur la
transition écologique de l'économie pour
créer en forme les secteurs d'activité
qui refonde de la france demain un pays
leader est pas un pays super mathieu
pour moi je trouve que c'est une réponse
un peu totémique pour le coup de la
gauche qui passe à côté des vrais sujets
qui sont la pénibilité ou la pénibilité
est un vrai sujet des blue qui sont
beaucoup plus pénible de l'autre c'est
peut-être sur ces boules ou là qu'il
faut âgées qui sont la nature des
emplois il n'existe pas sans ce moment
une explosion des emplois de service peu
qualifiés peut payer voila voila et
voilà vraiment débat de réflexion de la
gauche on sait sujet qu'est ce qu'on
fait les systèmes d'auto tour prenant
taux entre auto entrepreneurs un nombre
d'emplois individuel renvoie bien
libéralisation du marché du travail
c'est un vrai sujet et puis le troisième
sujet mardi
c'est qu'à mes yeux les français
demandent plus du pouvoir d'achat en ce
moment que du temps de travail et donc
répondent diminution du temps de travail
de façon un peu comme ça jair totémique
pour tout bien programmatique ça me
paraît manquer ces trois sets c'est pour
ça que la question que je me pose c'est
est-ce qu'elle est pas un peu anti anti
climax est cette réforme est ce que
c'est le bon moment économiquement je
parle pas des arguments idéologiques
mais économiquement est ce que ça peut
être le bon moment pour baisser le temps
de travail font pas du tout selon vous
pour parler non jb recettes l'a très
bien expliqué aujourd'hui on n'a pas un
sujet de d'offres d'emploi sur le marché
qui sont qui ne serait pas disponible il
ya beaucoup d'offres d'emploi sur le
marché on ne trouve pas les personnes
face à ça donc si demain on réduit le
temps de travail pour dire qu'on va
créer des postes équivalents à ceux qui
sont déjà proposés ils ne trouveront pas
plus les personnes pour venir les
remplir donc là les entreprises se
trouveront désorganisé tout en n'ayant
pas les capacités à recruter les bonnes
personnes qu'on n'aura pas de bénéfices
par rapport à ça et en plus comme on l'a
très bien dit la réforme des 35 heures a
été accompagnée d'une baisse de charges
massives est-ce que là aujourd'hui le
gouvernement qui est déjà un
gouvernement et puis les candidats à la
présidentielle actuelle qui sont déjà
dans une augmentation des dépenses de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards si ce
n'est centaines de milliards peuvent
encore ajouté à ceux à cette promesse ou
à cette liste du père noël une baisse de
charge de l'ampleur de celle qu'on a
connue qui se chiffrerait en dizaines et
dizaines de milliards d'euros donc je ne
le pense pas je ne pense ce n'est pas du
tout bon moment pour faire une telle
réforme est encore une fois personne
n'empêche une entreprise qui le veut de
travailler 30 2h30 heure 28 heures ou
25,6 et elle est son choix elle a toute
la liberté pour l'organiser on a
aujourd'hui un art se mêle du code du
travail qui est fait de telle façon
qu'elles peuvent le faire et à la
capacité à négocier avec ses salariés à
travers plein de mécanismes qui ont été
mis en place de démocratie interne
d'entreprise je pense que si quelqu'un
veut le faire ils peuvent le faire
allez-y on en fait quoi de ce temps
libre aussi ses salaires n'augmentent
pas c'est une vraie question la grande
question c'est vraiment celle à mon sens
plus de l'inégalité que du temps de
travail c'est à dire que vous allez
avoir les personnes qui n'ont pas de
qualifications et qui donc de fait
produisait à quitter avec très peu de
gains de productivité et ceux qui sont
ultra qualifiés et qui là vont avoir des
gains de productivité énorme la première
catégorie c'est souvent en effet dans
les services s'est souvent donc un temps
de présence contre un important don cap
un travail qui va pas forcément diminuer
parce que vous devez tenir le voyage
dans le reportage l'inquiétude des
salariés
de l'entreprise c'est de devoir faire le
même job mais en exactement où elle est
là c'est beaucoup plus difficile donc ça
veut dire souvent la une tente le temps
travaille ça peut être en effet
augmentation des cadences augmentation
de la productivité parce qu'en fait vous
devez faire le même travail en moins de
temps et puis l'autre catégorie très
diplômés où il ya beaucoup d'innovations
beaucoup de progrès technique est bien
là va pouvoir bénéficier d'un d'une
baisse continue du temps de travail à
cause justement de l'innovation et d'une
valeur ajoutée créée qui va exploser et
donc vous aurez de plus en plus à mon
sens a marché du travail à deux vitesses
avait vraiment des gagnants et des
perdants comme on avait un peu avec la
mondialisation au niveau international
avec l'industrie sauf que là ce sera
nationale et au sein des secteurs et des
actifs et c'est très intéressant ce
qu'ont à dire parce que c'est déjà la
critique qui a été fait et vous l'avez
rappelé mathieu tout à l'heure en
faisant le bilan de des 35 heures c'est
à dire que finalement cette réforme elle
avait plus profité aux cadres de ces
contre je sais pour elle j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre pourquoi vous êtes
encore sur 7 sur cette ligne là avec le
risque finalement ça profite plus aux
catégories des cadres d où la catégorie
moyenne supérieure je parlais termes
économiques sains que co salariés les
plus en difficulté que ce ne sont pas
les écologistes qui ont développé cette
loi et qu'ils ont mises en oeuvre mais
que deux suisses et pendant ce temps la
majorité de ceux-ci volet on peut jouer
à
qui était ou mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que les écologistes n'étaient
ni en mesure de dicter ce qu'ils
allaient faire cette loi ni en mesure de
faire les négociations non mais c'est
quand même dans le programme de 2
yannick jadot c'est de passer par une
grande conférence pour le pour le
négocier pour le 10 août et fait de très
longue date parce que ça apporte un
bienfait dans la vie de tous les jours
mais l'essentiel est sauf et permet
désormais contraire le risque le risque
était vraiment à votre propre caisse
je dirais que oui on a abordé le fait
que l'importance était d'augmenter le
niveau de vie des personnes et augmenter
le niveau de vie des personnes c'est pas
que augmenter les salaires c'est pâques
augmenter le temps de travail si on
reprend l'ancien
sarkozienne ou aujourd'hui macro nien
mais c'est aussi diminuer les charges
contraintes et en fait je suis désolé de
revenir là dessus mais la question ne
peut pas se limiter juste à combien
d'heures de travail mais doit prendre en
compte comment on travaille et comment
on développe cette industrie c'est pour
cela que j'insiste sur les conséquences
santé sanitaire des conditions dans
lesquelles on travaille particulièrement
quand on est dépendant des emplois ou la
pénibilité est forte ou on est exposé à
des choses dangereuses vous avez la
double peine c'est à dire d'avoir pas
forcément beaucoup d'argent mais en plus
d'en perdre beaucoup dans vos conditions
de pardon de par votre volonté
avec le risque je reprends la
démonstration d'anne-sophie lcif avec le
risque qu'une nouvelle baisse du temps
de travail finalement défavorise les qui
est défavorisée vraiment l'emploi cd
plein comme le cic eux qui eux sont des
réformes qui elle était une réforme
d'ampleur pour qui n'a apporté aucun
emploi et a dilapidé 18 milliards
d'euros d'argent public
ça ce sont des mauvaises choses diminuer
le temps de travail on n a jamais
précipité la france dans l'abyme ça ça
des inégalités vont croissantes mais
elles ne sont pas liées uniquement c'est
à dire que ce serait quand même
de considérer qu avoir plus de temps
pour soi et plus de temps pour vivre à
égal salaire serait une mauvaise chose
pour chacun d'entre eux voilà une puce
les uns et les autres exposer vos
arguments je dois dire que les médecins
qui participait au débat précédent quand
ils ont vu qu'on avait parlé des 35
heures et d'hypothèses et 32 heures et
ils ont 10 à casser l'hôpital et surtout
pas baisser le temps de travail j'aurais
dû rappeler patrick foulhoux et nous
autres invités bref merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'était passionnant
merci mathieu on se retrouve alors
peut-être pas la semaine prochaine on se
retrouve dans une dizaine de jours
profitez en bien parce que vous
travaillez vraiment beaucoup merci aussi
à gilbert c'est tout était avec nous
également dans ce sens public au
marathon je rappelle souriez vous êtes
filmés c'est sur un autre thème mais
c'est aux éditions de l'observatoire je
vous dis à demain et puis ne ratez pas
le rendez vous politique dans la
matinale bonjour chez vous c'est bruno
retailleau le président du groupe mr au
sénat qui est l'invité dorian romancini
salut à tous
talonné par eric zemmour marine ne pas
une riposte en mots et en images mais en
se décalant un peu plus 2 14 certains de
ses partisans qui ne mâchent pas leurs
mots sur les réseaux sociaux un pari qu
on décrypte cette semaine au hashtag
#ce2010 8h sur public sénat
[Musique]
denny reconnaissance repentance pardon
elle est longue la liste des mots pesée
et soupesée par les derniers présidents
pour parler de la mémoire de la
colonisation et de la guerre d'algérie
alors que les 60 ans des accords d'evian
marquant la fin de la guerre seront
célébrées en pleine campagne
présidentielle au mois de mars emmanuel
macron ne cesse de revenir sur cette
mémoire à vif mais comment cet ambitieux
chantier de la mémoire par le tilt aux
harkis aux pieds noirs aux
indépendantistes et à leurs descendants
dans cette campagne qui démarre de façon
très clivée en train eric zemmour lui
même enfin de pieds-noirs et d'autres
qui compare les violences policières aux
crimes de 61 pas facile de parler dans
la subtilité c'est pourtant ce que nous
allons faire avec emmanuel blanchard
historien spécialiste de la guerre
d'algérie et victor boury qui a suivi
l'écho de ce sujet brûlant sur les
réseaux sociaux où chaque camp se
retrouvent et cela spécialement depuis
le 30 septembre
ce jour là emmanuel macron reçoit dans
les jardins de l'elysée 18 jeunes chargé
de lui faire des propositions pour
apaiser les mémoire de la guerre
d'algérie suite au rapport stora
quelques photos dont celle ci posté sur
le compte twitter du président où il
présente ses jeunes descendants de
harkis d'indépendantistes de rapatrier
de jus d'algérie d'appeler de militaires
d'immigrés bref il fait attention à
n'oublier personne et les remercier de
les changes sauf que et c'est là le
rebondissement cet échange a suscité les
foudres du pouvoir algérien après qu'un
journaliste du monde rapporte deux
phrases du président est ce qu'il y
avait une nation algérienne avant de la
colonisation française
ça c'est la question est celle là aussi
la nation algérienne poste 1962 s'est
construite sur une rente mémorielle tout
le problème est là puis il précisa qu'il
ne parle pas de la société algérienne
mais du système politique militaire qui
attention s'est constitué sa trente
mémorielle en réécrivant l'histoire ces
propos entraîne immédiatement
une riposte d'alger qui a un rappelle
son ambassadeur et 2 interdit le survol
de son territoire aux avions militaires
français qui se rendent au sahel en
algérie le journal el watan qualifie ces
propos d' emmanuel macron de dérapage et
en france victor boury comment ces
propos sont-ils reçues on a bu emmanuel
macron énuméré toutes ces communautés
leurs descendants comment ils reçoivent
ces phrases on assiste à des échanges et
des débats qui sont essentiellement au
sein de ces communautés et serait sur la
sur leur histoire on le voit dans le
dans le nuage de mots quoi qu'on a ici
avec et 1,2 de colonies d'un juge de
dictature qui font bien écho à ces
histoires liées à ces comme ça veut dire
qu'en face malgré le entre guillemets
clash avec l'algérie a que j'ai expliqué
ça ne concerne qu'une petite communauté
on voit qu'au fur et à mesure de faim
jour après jour on a une grande majorité
de personnes qui n'étant pas concernés
sont pas au départ s'étaient pas
exprimés dessus et donc on assiste à des
commentaires en fait et différents faits
d'actualité et de déclarations du
président on le voit dans les mots
d'avion de rappel de l'ambassadeur on en
fait il ya il souffre d'une forme de
deux surprises par rapport à ces
événements alors ayez blanchard du coup
cet incident ont ils posent une question
qui est est-ce voulu fin à skis emmanuel
macron a voulu selon vous envoyer un
message avec ses phrases qui sont
prononcés un hors caméra mais quand même
un journaliste assiste à les changes et
si oui est-ce que c'est des phrases
voilà destinés à la france puisque on
voit bien qu'il ya cette phrase sur la
nation algérienne qui s'est constitué
grâce à la colonisation est ce qu'il est
dans le débat franco-français risque il
parle à l'algérie avec
l'histoire de la rente mémorielle il ya
deux choses qui sont évidentes de tels
propos ne pouvaient que froisser le
pouvoir algérien et il était sûr qu'il y
aurait des réponses à de telles à de
tels propos et des réponses qu'ils
pouvaient bien sûr chercher une escalade
sur le plan diplomatique puisque
emmanuel macron avait considéré que les
questions mémorielles relevé la
diplomatie ce qui est un choix pour le
moins étonnant puisque les mémoires des
deux sociétés sont forcément cris v ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
voulaient que ça se fasse en somme c'est
à que ce soit un travail au conjoint
c'était en tout cas il considérait que
dans le rapprochement entre la france et
l'algérie du point de vue diplomatique
il pouvait insérer ces questions
mémorielles ce qui encore une fois est
un choix étonnant la deuxième chose
qu'on peut dire en tant qu'historien
c'est que je ne sais pas sur quel plan
c'est parce que ces places et onel
macron mais en tout cas il ne pouvait
pas prétendre à la justesse historique
il a effectivement eu des propos où il
donnait l'impression de se placer
au-dessus de la mêlée alors même que ce
qu'il affirme avec force peut être reçus
en algérie par exemple la question de la
rente mémorielle cela a été signalé par
des historiens algériens depuis des
années la société algérienne quelque
part refusé aussi la façon dont la
guerre d'indépendance et patrimoniale
ise en revanche là c'est un fait on va
dire
en revanche il a aussi cherché à
trianguler d'une certaine façon il a
cherché à régler des comptes avec la
turquie en considérant que l'empiré
ottoman était une puissance coloniale
alors que tous les historiens qui
travaillent sur cette époque disque oui
bien sûr tu vends que la turquie s'est
fait oublier la france le seul
colonisateur voilà c'est ça donc on
s'interrogeant sur l'existence d'une
nation algérienne du point de vue
diplomatique et franchi une ligne rouge
et du point de vue historique on peut
dire qu'il rend une très mauvaise copie
puisque bien sûr que les nations tels
qu'ils existaient à la fin du xviie au
début du 19e siècle n'avait pas la forme
on n'avait pas une alliance voila voila
il relit l'histoire à l'eau
mon critère alors non acronis m'a
beaucoup en ce moment alors on a entendu
votre lecture sévère on va dire
d'historiens sur du moins les propos la
justesse du propos d' emmanuel macron
qui vous dit assumer sans doute une
intention il ne s'exprime pas pas dans
quelques jours mais face à la relation
très tendue avec alger il s'exprime en
marge d'une interview moi j'ai le plus
grand respect pour le peuple algérien et
j'entretiens des relations vraiment
cordiale avec le président de t bone
après nous nous avons enclenchée entre
et donc on se dit des choses qui sont
pas agréables pour nous mêmes je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas je ne nous ai pas ménagé
avec notre propre histoire mon souhait
c'est qu'il ya un apaisement parce que
je pense que c'est mieux de se parler
d'avancée il ya sans doute des
désaccords la vie c'est fait pour parler
des désaccords et aussi les partager et
donc il y aura immanquablement d'autres
tensions allez y aurait d'autres
tensions on connaît le proverbe on fait
pas une omelette sans casser d'oeufs et
ben là ça serait plutôt ont fait pas à
chantier mémorielle sans créer des
tensions que pensez vous de son
commentaire dans un premier temps j'ai
l'impression que justement il cherche un
peu à rétropédaler dans le sens où il
considère que ce chantier mémorielle et
avant tout un chantier français un
chantier national d'une certaine façon
ok donc là pour ouvrir être paie
d'ailleurs se reposant parce que même
s'il dit bon bah voilà ça crée des
tensions il y en aura immanquablement il
révoque détention plutôt dans un
contexte franco-français c'est ça dans
un an
dans un premier temps dans un second
temps il essaie de se positionner une
certaine façon encore une fois c'est pas
mon métier mais en personne qui parle
francs quand on parle francs on crée des
tensions tout simplement ils se
positionnent dans une histoire où les
sujets de mémoire et d'histoire la
guerre d'indépendance ont forcément été
clivant entre les deux états puisqu'il a
des demandes et des attentes qui sont
fortes du côté algérien qui sont pas des
attentes de mémoire qui sont des
attentes de reconnaissance et d attente
de réparation et donc tant qu'il n'y
aura pas cette reconnaissance et ses
réparations d'une certaine façon
forcément vouloir amener le gouvernement
algérien sur la question de la mémoire
c'est une façon de ne pas répondre le
contexte de la campagne pour vous il
pèse ou pas l'acheteur vous êtes sérieux
en fait quand même vous connaissez bien
le sujet de ce travail sur la mémoire
vous vous dites là il est en campagne on
sait que ce sujet il arrive toujours
dans les campagnes où vous vous dites il
continue son voile à son travail entamé
depuis qu'on est passé aucun cas n'a une
élection présidentielle sur deux
concorde avec les commémorations de la
fin de la guerre d'indépendance
algérienne et l'émergence de ce nouvel
état algérien donc effectivement ce
sujet est forcément un des sujets de la
campagne même si c'est pas forcément le
sujet qui est le plus attendu par la
plupart des électeurs des électrices
mais pour les 11 à dire les personnes en
campagne pouvoir parler à des
communautés organisées pouvoir parler à
des associations c'est important
organisé et alors justement vous dit
c'est pas forcément le sujet attendu par
les français mais c'est vrai que manuel
macron à peu près au même moment
quelques jours avant eh bien ils avaient
demander pardon aux harkis à un pardon
cette fois dans un cadre très officielle
juste avant la journée en hommage aux
harkis un pardon qui poursuit un travail
entamé par ses prédécesseurs françois
hollande et nicolas sarkozy on va voir
comme vous le disiez que c'est vraiment
un passage obligé alors à tous les
harkis envers lesquels la france n dette
je dis au nom de la république que la
france leur doit réparation je reconnais
les responsabilités des gouvernements
français dans l'abandon des harkis aux
combattants abandonnés à leur famille
qu'ils ont subi les camps la prison le
déni
je demande pardon
nous n'oublierons pas alors on a
beaucoup présenté un finalement emmanuel
macron comme allons plus loin que ses
prédécesseurs en demandant pardon mais
si je vous écoute bien celui qui parle
de réparation c'est c'est nicolas
sarkozy finalement alors est ce qu'il ya
une vraie évolution est ce qui va
vraiment plus loin que ses prédécesseurs
ou pas entre ces mots à réparation de
nicolas sarkozy responsabilité de
françois hollande et pardon d emmanuel
macron pour vis-à-vis des harkis la
horde des propos des dispositifs d
hommage à ceux qui sont appelés les
harkis effectivement on pourra en faire
toute une histoire je crois que les
propos qu'il a tenus étaient des propos
qui était attendu et qui ont été bien
reçues par ce qu'on peut appeler la
communauté harkie organisée mais ce qui
est surtout attendu c'est le contenu
concret des réparations et le contenu
concret des réparations cela fort prend
forcément une forme de politique une
forme politique qui ne va pas simplement
dans des indemnisations individuelle
d'un torts subis et se tord est ce qu on
le répare par des indemnités
individuelles ou est ce qu'on essaie de
le réparer en faisant en sorte que les
descendants de ces personnes puissent
bénéficier de politiques et d'une
certaine façon viennent contrecarrer un
certain nombre de perte de chance et
viennent régler gray pleinement au
ciment voix dans le débat là on n'est
vraiment pas comme ils tous clairement
on est la politique tu rends mémorielle
a fait quoi là à l'époque des mânes de
nicolas sarkozy d'être effectivement il
parle de réparation n'était plus concret
je sais pas à quoi c'est lié et pourquoi
est ce que là pour le coup c'est un vrai
choix politique entre les deux entre
nicolas sarkozy qui parle de réparation
emmanuel macron qui est dans un chantier
purement mémorielle non c'est une
stratégie politique là je ne sais
absolument pas ce que emmanuel macron va
décider comme politiques concrètes en
faveur des descendants de harkis donc de
soins mais vous vous doutez quand même
qu effectivement on est dans quelque
chose purement mariale on peut noter que
le cadre qu'a choisi le président la
république sur sous toutes ces questions
est avant tout un cadre mémorielle il a
cette année mais il ya un autre
anniversaire
particulièrement important ou emmanuel
macron était très attendu c'est
l'anniversaire du 17 octobre 1961 ou
lors d'une marche pour l'indépendance de
l'algérie organisée par le fln des
policiers abate jette dans la seine
plusieurs dizaines de personnes après
des années de déni et de chiffres
maquillés pour la première fois en 2012
françois hollande écrit dans un
communiqué la république reconnaît avec
lucidité c'est fait hélas pour les 60
ans et les 60 ans un anniversaire
important
emmanuel macron était donc attendu et il
parle les temps changent cette fois ci
c'est dans un tweet où il reprend
d'abord les mots de françois hollande
lucidité et responsabilité et il ajoute
les crimes commis la nuit du 17 octobre
1961 sous l'autorité de maurice papon
sont inexcusables aux victimes nous
rendons hommage à leur ce mot
inexcusable a été extrêmement commenter
parce qu'il ne demande pas pardon c'est
un vrai sujet ou une fausse polémique là
emmanuel blanchard selon vous ça il faut
le demander aux représentants des
associations il n'y a pas que les
représentants des associations il ya
aussi les commentateurs voient la
silicon valley c'est
une forme d'habileté du président de la
république qui essaie de ménager d'une
certaine façon
voilà mais ce qu'on peut dire quand même
ce qui s'est passé quelque chose pendant
la république à aller beaucoup plus loin
que ce que ses prédécesseurs de ce point
de vue là il
s'est passé quelque chose après on peut
commenter mot par mot noter ceux qui
sont présents et ceux qui sont absents
ceux qui sont présents c'est par exemple
cette référence à maurice papon mais
aucune référence à la chaîne d'autorité
au dessus de maurice papon puisque
maurice papon est resté en poste on peut
aussi noter c'est ça qui est du côté
algérien et partenaires ont noté qu'il y
a aucune référence à la situation
coloniale donc il ya une reconnaissance
le mot république est utilisée quand
même jusque dans le tweet en revanche
l'analyse reste partiel l'analyse reste
partiel alors cela dit vous l'a dit il
va plus loin et victor boury comment
c'est reçu là pour le coup
par les uns et les autres
voir les français une lambda et non
concernés par le sujet parce qu'on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
annoncé à l'avancé c'est cette
commémoration on voit qu'il ya bien un
avant et un après et à partir de la date
du 17 on a des discussions et des débats
qui sont beaucoup plus polémique plus
clivée on sent à la lecture des messages
que le débat s'électrise un peu plus en
tout cas dans dans la teneur des
messages et ses lectrices à ses
lectrices justement sur le fait qu' base
sur un sur le terrain sur les bouquets
sur les mots qu'il emploie sur sa
communication il franchit un pas et les
internautes le commente amplement on a
deux catégories derrière de messages qui
est qui s'opposent avec d'une part les
communautés concernées avec des mots
comme comme massacre oublié martyrs des
mots très forts qui sont employées dans
les messages et d'autres communautés qui
sont qui évoque le besoin plus de
réciprocité et pardon donc on sent qu'à
partir de cette date c'est aussi un
besoin d'apaisement qui est qui émerge
n'ont besoin d'apaisement avec des
messages qui qui qui souligne que
désormais pour les lavant et d'avoir des
efforts aussi des deux côtés donc il ya
un grand volume de messages qui est
plutôt neutre à
alassane à notre surprise qu'on a fait
l'analyse des messages c'est à dire que
finalement là c'est pas une question de
réparation c'est pas une question c'est
une question de passer à autre chose et
d'arrivée seulement à seul des commandes
à fait raison non plus à choisir seul
des décomptes en tout cas passé voix
apaisée ça veut dire aussi passer à
autre chose ça vous étonne ça d'ailleurs
que ne sont pas les émetteurs des
messages qui met effectivement élevé
pour un certain nombre de personnes qui
ne sont pas directement concernés sans
doute qu'il réalisait que plusieurs pays
ont été effectués successivement par le
président hollande en 2012 par le
président macron il peut y avoir
l'impression que d'une certaine façon ce
contentieux est à purée et qu'il n'a pas
de conséquences dans le présent alors
qu'une partie des personnes considèrent
et vous l'avez montré dans un tweet en
début d'émission que ce qui s'est passé
ce jour-là est certes exceptionnelle
mais ne s'est pas interrompue du jour au
lendemain est devenu beaucoup moins
intense dans bien sûr le degré de
violence mais avec des confrontations
des violences et des meurtres racistes
qui ne se sont pas interrompues du jour
au lendemain il ya certains qui roulent
en côte il ya un présent qui à présent
du passé et d'autres qui considère qu'il
faut couper qu'il faut séparer le passé
et puis il ya aujourd'hui non merci
victor borie on a parlé des mots mais
quid des images et des choix de l'elysée
autour de cet anniversaire hautement
symbolique du 17 octobre 61 on regarde
les images attention cherchez l'erreur
et on accueille philippe lentschener
communicants pour parler de ces images
du président au pont de bezons près de
paris où avait démarré la marche du 17
octobre
et on a comme ça plusieurs minutes
d'image sans un mot sans un discours
alors c'est étonnant parce que dans une
fine du président il dit les mots qu'on
a commenté tout à l'heure il ya un
communiqué publié dans la foulée pardon
qui stipule je cite le président a dit a
dit tout ce qu'on voit dans le tweet
sauf qu'on ne l'entend pas dire lors de
cette cérémonie ce qui est quand même
assez étonnant philippe lentschener ça
veut dire bonjour ça veut dire qu'en
communication politique il ya les mots
qu'on dit et les mots qu'on écrit non il
ya emmanuel macron à c'est à dire c'est
à dire que vous avez avec ces deux
extraits que vous avez montré c'est à
dire celui ci plus le l'intervention
devant les harkis devant l'air qui les
amène en dollar qui voilà vous avez en
fait toute la politique africaine
d'emmanuel macron parce que c'est
toujours la même chose si vous regardez
bien vous avez d'un côté
vous pouvez coller ouagadoudou en 2017
le liban vous pouvez coller montpellier
avec le sommet pourrait coller ça vous
êtes toujours la même chose et vous avez
un exercice de contrition dans lequel il
excelle vous avez ainsi de contrer suite
et les harkis je reprends voilà ouais
vous avez de l'autre côté l'immersion
limbes l'empathie pour témoigner d'une
proximité absolue avec la vie que les
gens vivaient avec les sentiments qu'ils
ressentent face et bah ça c'est là quand
il est il est en immersion au milieu
d'eux quand il est sur le point de la
même façon vous avez toujours une
troisième chose qui ait l'appui
intellectuelle
c'est à dire qu'il a besoin d'être backé
par benjamin stora quand il s'agit de
l'algérie par rob mbe quand il s'agit du
2 le film
figure actuel oui qui donne une caution
intellectuelle avait rationnelle
émotionnel intellectuelle vous avez le
triangle de la communication mcc
reviennent avec au milieu toujours parce
que si on oublie qu'il a 40 ans on peut
pas comprendre une culture du clash et
du parler cash qui après tout rappelle
qu'il est de sa génération oui vous avez
cité ces trois ingrédients vous approuve
y est pour vous c'est un peu la même
chose il ya comme une spécificité
algérienne
en tout cas je jouais petite analyse me
paraît tout à fait pertinente mais on
peut aussi dire qu'il ya des mots qui
sont parfois difficile à dire si on
analyse l'histoire des cérémonies sur
l'esclavagé la traite la colonisation
ici une 7 octobre 61 même quand il y as
reconnaissance les reconnaissances sont
souvent muettes comme s'il était
difficile d'affirmer un certain nombre
de choses clairement puisqu'ils sont des
sujets qui continuent d'être clivant non
pas qu'il soit irrecevable par la
société mais parce qu'il ya des groupes
politiques qui mettent ces sujets sous
tension et d'une certaine façon pour
emmanuel macron ici en allant sur le
pont de bezons il rendait un hommage qui
n'avaient jamais été rendues en et
isaure bien là on excuse à kick
effectivement le monde parle de ce mot
mais il ne le prononce pas c'est ça qui
est incroyable elles disent rien il
évitait aussi de donner prise en main
square non mais là le fait de se taire
de ne rien dire et de montrer que il
faut avoir de la compassion parce que
tout de même on parle de morts et de
gens qui ont été balancés comme les
sciences informatiques en a jamais eu
exactement combien d'années témoin
l'artega sincèrement on peut reconnaître
une justesse à ce moment-là et
missionnaire cela dit du côté des
réactions que ce soit dit ou écrit je
parle des réactions politiques on n'a
pas l'impression que ça ait changé grand
chose puisque à gauche de jean-luc
mélenchon à yannick jadot on considère
que le président a raté l'occasion de
parler de crime d'état on perdrait fallu
aller plus loin tandis qu'à droite on
certain et comme eric ciotti ici
considère comme dans la propagande
victimaire et antifrançaises et qu'il ya
des massacres de harkis et de
pieds-noirs jamais commémorait on voit
que la droite qui a vraiment ce thème
effectivement dès qu'on parle d'eux des
excuses de victimisation voit la cccc
dénoncée à droite
et pourtant il ya 25 ans jacques chirac
président de droite reconnaissait la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
la déportation des juifs donc on se
demande si emmanuel macron et dansait
pas ou pas emmanuel blanchard tout
simplement peut-être qu'il aurait voulu
pouvoir avoir lui aussi un grand
discours tels que celui de 1995 mais sur
le sujet franco algérien sur le sujet du
passé colonial de la france ce n'est pas
possible il faut imaginer que jacques
chirac a tant de temps que ça après
fabrice jacques chirat lille par l'a1
moment où il ya un relatif consensus
dans la société pour l'admettre ici
emmanuel macron doit plutôt être très
satisfaits devait apparaître au centre
du débat politique dont le sens où à la
fois il allait plus loin et en même
temps ils cristallisent des oppositions
des deux côtés donc il se remet au
centre du débat politique peut-être
qu'il rêvait effectivement d'être
jacques chirac en 95 sauf que voilà la
mémoire n'est pas apaisée sur ce sujet
là et il se replace au centre du jeu il
ya quand même un mérite alors oui il
n'est pas face à un bloc politique et
celtique vous en avez eu deux
précédemment le premier c'est l'
esclavage qui a fait que ça a été facile
de reconnaître la responsabilité dans
l'esclavagé vous avez eu le vel d'hiv où
ça a été facile de reconnaître la
responsabilité de la vernette pas face à
un bloc vous n'êtes pas face un blog et
il ya en plus de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée un état un état qui est un
régime autoritaire qui est dans une
crise quand les états autoritaires sont
dans des crises ils ont toujours la même
chose et le même réflexe facile
peut-être avant de vous faire réagir je
voulais qu'on revient justement sur
l'historique et le passif puisque
emmanuel macron n'a pas attendu la
campagne présidentielle de 2021 pour
s'intéresser à la mémoire et demandé
pardon à en 2018 déjà il prononcé ce mot
lors d'une visite à la veuve de maurice
audin mathématicien français et
militants de l'indépendance assassiné en
algérie
demander pardon
ce pardon de 2018 par est dans la droite
ligne de ses propos de campagne de 2010
est d'abord lors d'une visite en algérie
en laye bien en algérie il parle à la
télé algérienne la colonisation fait
partie de l'histoire française ceci est
un crime c'est un crime contre
l'humanité c'est une vraie barbarie et
ça fait partie de ce passé que nous
devons regarder en face en présentant
aussi nos excuses à l'égard de celles et
ceux vers lesquels nous avons commis ces
gestes la colonisation est un crime
contre l'humanité en pleine campagne
présidentielle emmanuel macron s'attire
les foudres des pieds noirs j'en ai
blessé je le sais pour des mauvaises
raisons je les regarde dans les yeux et
je leur dis que je les aime 1 je les
aime mais je vais le faire et c'est vrai
quand on revoit ses extraits aujourd'hui
on a l'impression qu'en 2017 il a un cap
très clair qu'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis je pense qu'il faut distinguer
les deux moment où le discours de 2017
et le discours d'un candidat à la
présidentielle
il parle en son nom il ne parle pas au
nom de la france s'était fait il parle
en son nom et il parle en algérie où
l'utilisation de crimes contre
l'humanité apparaît comme quelque chose
d'évident c'est jerry l'on n'est encore
pas une présidentielle et ses
commentaires voilà il s'exprime en
algérie à ce moment là quand il parle
comme présent la république avec madame
josette audin quelques semaines quelques
mois avant qu'elle ne décède se dire le
temps qui s'est passé pour la
reconnaissance ici c'est la parole du
président de la république et la parole
du prévent la république qui sait elle
est importante parce qu'encore une fois
il y a eu les mots que nous avons vu
mais il ya aussi un communiqué et dans
les mots que nous voyons ici il apporte
la réponse attendue depuis des décennies
par cette femme mon mari n'est pas
disparu il a été tué par l'armée
française c'est effectivement de très
intimiste
beaucoup plus de force parce qu'il
reconnaît en tant que président de la
république que maurice audin est un cas
parmi d'autres il a d'ailleurs fait
ensuite en reconnaissant ali boumendjel
en 21 oui mais était ce qui s'est passé
alors depuis pour que justement là il
est cette phrase on le voit bien enfin
on l'élève a commencé l'émission avec ça
sur la nation algérienne qui s'est
constitué
avec la colonisation qu'est ce qu'il est
déjà un président française ne devrait
pas porter de récits sur ce qu'est une
autre nation mais qu'est ce qui se passe
voilà vous pensez qu'il lance une
dynamique avec les les pouvoirs
algériens ou le pouvoir algérien ou
alors qu'il n'attend plus rien comme
comme on l'entend par moments un qui
n'attend plus rien des autorités à heavy
rain parce qu'il est peut-être était
déçu tout simplement en tout cas qu'ils
en aient conscience ont pas
c'est peut-être toujours la même chose
du point de vue de la rhétorique en
revanche du point de vue du fond il est
passé d'une position qui était très
recevable par l'algérie qui était une
position anti colonialiste williams et
on ne me dit
rien contre l'humanité et donc si on
revient juste passé de séquences où il
s'adresse à l'état algérien là il
reprend des poncifs coloniaux dire que
l'algérie n'existait pas avant la
présence française en tant que nation
c'est un poncif coloniale bon bah
écoutez c'est compliqué la mémoire
de la guerre d'algérie avec réparation
ou sans réparation en voilà un sujet
complexe et passionnant c'est un sujet
qui va nous emmener directement cette
vidéo montage
qui vont se coucher tard comme dit un
ancien président que je te veto ou les
deux
voir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
talonné par eric zemmour marine le pen
riposte en mots et en images mais en se
décalant un peu plus 2,14 certains de
ses partisans qui ne mâchent pas leurs
mots sur les réseaux sociaux un pari qu
on décrypte cette semaine au hashtag
#civsocial
8h sur public sénat
nous nous trouvons dans une maison
d'enfants à caractère social de la
banlieue lilloise un lieu tenu secret
qui accueille des jeunes filles mineures
majeur en souffrance victimes de
violences intrafamiliales
mais depuis un an la structure encadre
également des jeunes filles en situation
de prostitution elles ont entre 13 et 16
ans et nous allons rencontrer l'équipe
qui les accompagnent
muriel et éducatrice elle encadre au
quotidien les jeunes résidentes l'une
d'elles qui se prostituent est en fugue
depuis deux jours donc c'est le studio
d'une de nos jeunes qui reflète bien
effectivement à la fois son mal-être
qu'elle est perdue
et qu'effectivement elle a besoin
d'accompagnement pour faire l'entretien
donc on le fait régulièrement on le nid
toi avec elle mais on peut revenir une
heure ou deux heures après
c'est de nouveau dans un état est
aujourd'hui dans sa situation actuelle
de prostitution et de consommation de
produits toxiques important parce que
craque c'est effectivement très
compliqué
ces adolescentes sont difficiles à
cadrer déscolarisés elle vise qu'à la
marge s'adonnant à des pratiques de
prostitution très diverses et parfois
sans admettre en être victime on n'est
plus dans un système de mac avec de la
prostitution son trottoir on est dans
une prostitution avec des échanges de
snap instagram snap où elles peuvent
donner rendez-vous dans des hôtels ou
dans des parcs c'est des pratiques et
des passes qui se font très très très
très vite
pour accompagner au mieux ces
prostituées mineures un centre dédié
s'apprête à voir le jour une première en
france c'est un lieu donc en milieu
rural mais nous allons garder bien
évidemment le secret sur
ce lieu qui pour la protection des
jeunes qui vont s'y trouve est
financé par l'état et le département à
hauteur d'un million d'euros par an ce
lieu se lit fermé sera expérimentée
pendant deux ans et s'il y aura entre 13
et 15 jeunes filles elles viendront se
reconstruire et entamer un travail de
réinsertion sociale l'objectif du
programme un donc ces deux en milieu
rural donc c'est de les sortir de leur
réseau prostitutionnel et aussi de leur
environnement de les rassembler
puisqu'elles ont une problématique
commune ensuite c'est d'avoir un
accompagnement éducatif et thérapeutique
adaptée et enfin c'est les amener à une
dynamique de changement et une
projection dans des possibles il y a un
an le département du nord a mené sa
propre enquête pour évaluer l'ampleur du
phénomène sur son territoire 145 enfants
victimes de prostitution ont été
identifiés un chiffre que la
collectivité estime elle même très en
deçà de la réalité dans l' enquête
au delà des 145 dossier qui nous sont
remontés on a les moyens de voir par la
méthodologie de l'enquète que des
situations sont identifiés par certains
les travailleurs sociaux de rues qui ne
sont pas identifiés par les maisons
d'enfants donc on sait que on a encore
beaucoup à faire pour que dans nos
équipes de protection de l'enfance on
puisse identifier repérer ces phénomènes
de prostitution de mineure
la prostitution des mineurs semble
augmenté de façon alarmante dans le nord
mais également au niveau national selon
un récent rapport six à dix mille
mineurs en sont les victimes aujourd'hui
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec france
culture et avec le soutien du centre
national du livre présente livres et
vous
[Musique]
vous retrouvez dans livres et vous
l'émission littéraire de public sénat
aujourd'hui on parle de politique mais
de politique avec un philosophe et vous
allez l'entendre et le voir ça change
tout le philosophe c'est marcel gauchet
bonjourbonjour marcel gauchet vous
publiez non pas un livre mais deux la
droite et la gauche histoire et destin
c'est aux éditions gallimard et puis d
entretien avec eric conan et françois
azouvi macro les leçons d'un échec aux
éditions stock dites-moi quand même le
son d'un échec emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui plutôt populaire par rapport
à ses prédécesseurs
la crise sanitaire a semble-t-il été
mieux gérer peut-être en france qu'en
angleterre il ya par exemple un rapport
parlementaire qui étrille le
gouvernement anglais alors pourquoi un
échec l'échec est un comprendre en
fonction de ce qui était une ambition
initiale du gouvernement de manuel
macron
emmanuel macron n'est pas tout à fait un
président comme les autres c'est un
président de rupture qui promettait une
transformation qui promettait même une
révolution puisque c'était le titre de
son livre de campagne et l'échec c'est
l'échec de cette promesse de rupture
elle ses promesses de transformation le
paradoxe étant même qu'à l'arrivée
emmanuel macron candidat de la rupture
but l'homme qui sort du milieu politique
habituelle devient le garant de la
continuité etc sont aujourd'hui son
appui politique principale politique de
la raison est ce que vous y êtes
philosophe est ce que la raison en
politique ça existe oui la raison en
politique existe mais encore faut-il
bien
délimiter les conditions de son emploi
ce ne serait pas une substance magique
qui appartiendrait à certains c'est le
moyen d'explorer les données d'une
situation et c'est le
là que ce juge l'exercice de la raison
et il faut bien dire que très souvent il
ya une confusion entre la raison comme
instrument intellectuelle d'exploration
sans concession d'une situation et le
raisonnable le raisonnable qui consiste
en gros à s'inscrire dans les pas de ses
prédécesseurs et à faire la même chose
que sans s'écarter trop d'une espèce
d'orthodoxie implicite c'est de quelle
raison par l'ong bien souvent dans les
élections présidentielles en france le
raisonnable ça ne fonctionne pas ce sont
plutôt des des candidats qui réussissent
à galvaniser les foules marcel gauchet à
le raisonnable fonctionne puisque en
gros c'est toujours des candidats du
cercle de la raison comme dirait à la
main qu'ils sont élus mais évidemment
que ça provoque une frustration dans une
partie de la population car c'est
raisonnabilité là ces cartes tout de
même assez du vécu d'une part importante
des citoyens de telle sorte qu'il ya une
protestation contre la raison qui peut
d'ailleurs tourné aisément à
l'irrationalité pure et simple mais qui
est devenu presque une composante de
notre système politique qui n'oppose
plus tellement une droite et une gauche
que le plus le parti prétendu de la
raison et le parti d'une civilité à la
raison qui sait pas toujours très bien
ce qu'elle veut mais qui sait quels sont
les motifs de sa protestation voilà le
cercle de la raison c'est par exemple 8
6 en 2005 a refusé d'entendre le non au
référendum sur la constitution
européenne
ben oui puisque le raisonnable c'était
de ne pas entrer dans les
bouleversements considérables qu'on
aurait supposé de tirer les leçons pour
de bon non au référendum sur le traité
constitutionnel donc le raisonnable
c'était de faire comme s'il n'y avait
pas eu de référendum mais évidemment que
les conséquences du coup les
conséquences sont elles dans l'effet à
long terme de cette décision qu'on peut
se demander s'il obéissait véritablement
à la raison et oui qu'est-ce que vous
avez publié de nombreux livres sur
l'histoire de notre démocratie un
événement tel que celui ci justement
est-ce qu'il ne tourne pas le dos à
l'exercice démocratique demander au
peuple ce qu'il en pense et ne pas en
tenir compte
à l'évidence et nous avons eu une leçon
de ce point de vue donné par nos amis
anglais car la tentation de revenir sur
le référendum qui a déclenché le break
si tu étais très grande dans les élites
britanniques
il n'empêche que la ligne qui l'a
emporté a été de respecter la volonté
populaire exprimée par référendum nous
avons préféré le schéma inverse et ce
n'est pas étranger au marasme qui
affecte notre démocratie droite français
droite et gauche c'est l'un des deux
livres que vous publiez est ce que ces
deux définitions elles valent encore
marcel gaucher alors que nous avons un
président qui est sensé qui a été élu en
pensant donc transcender ces deux
parties alors emmanuel macron a eu
l'intelligence et l'habilité de ne pas
dire qu'il ne voulait qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas la droite et la gauche
il a dit ce qui est beaucoup plus
intelligent et d'ailleurs correspond
davantage à une réalité politique qu'il
était à la fois et de droite et de
gauche et que donc il ne prétendait pas
abolir ce clivage mais le cancer
l'instrument d'un dialogue au sommet en
quelque sorte qu'ils s'incarnerait dans
sa personne et qui lui permettrait de
répondre aux aspirations des deux côtés
évidemment que c'est une situation qui
correspond à un brouillage profonde et
terme de ce clivage le mais la question
est de savoir et c'est la question à
laquelle j'essaie de répondre si parce
qu'il y à brouillard qui parce qu'il y a
déstabilisation des termes habituels
dans lesquels ont identifié la droite et
la gauche ce clivage a perdu son sens
c'est mon idée est que non mais il a
profondément changé de sens et si ce qu
emmanuel macron a su très intelligemment
exploiter expliquez-nous pourquoi il a
changé de sens marcel gauchet le critère
principal de ce changement me
semble-t-il est là découle la prise de
conscience la pénétration du pluralisme
démocratique dans l'inconscient de
chacun des acteurs on a plus simplement
deux camps affronter glee se détestent s
ignorent et donc où le rapport de force
prime mais quelque chose dont les
acteurs ont intégré qu'ils ont un
rapport avec le camp d'en face la droite
pense
à ses valeurs propres ses perspectives
mais ne peut pas ignorer qu'il y à une
gorge il y en aura toujours une d'une
certaine manière et que tout ce qu'elle
dit n'est pas absurde et dans l'autre
sens la gauche est obligé les lecteurs
de gours la plupart d'entre eux pas tous
mais la plupart d'entre eux
reconnaissent qu'en effet tout n'est pas
à jeter dans ce que dit la droite et par
conséquent le ce clivage s'est beaucoup
relativiser
il s'est même estompé de certains égards
il ya une droitisation
de la gauche et une gauchisation ces
jeunes gens voyaient cette néologisme
affreux de la droite et c'est cette
situation-là dont il faut reconnaître à
emmanuel macron le flair d'avoir su
l'exploiter d'en faire une ressource
politique par exemple vous le voyez dans
le domaine des valeurs les valeurs de la
droite et de la gauche sont de plus en
plus s'interpénétrer donnez moi des
exemples l'exemple le plus banal c'est
se situe sur le terrain des deux valeurs
cardinales de la droite et de la gauche
l'ordre du point de vue de la droite et
la justice du point de vue de la gauche
un ordre injuste n'est plus un ordre et
une justice qui est source de désordre
n'est plus une justice digne de ce nom
il ya 12 12
ficultés nouvelles des potes de nos
dirigeants politiques de définir une
ligne dans ce contexte il suffit plus
d'obéir à une sorte d'identité très
déterminés mais véritablement d'épouser
ce sens nouveau des contradictions qu'il
y habite les citoyens et alors vous qui
êtes philosophe du politique on
al'impression on a tendance à dire en ce
moment qu'on ne parvient plus à débattre
en france c'est votre sentiment oui à de
certains égards ou plus exactement on y
parvient plus au centre du système car
par ailleurs le débat existe
profondément dans la société est ce qui
est frappant c'est le décalage de ce
point de vue entre la scène éclairée où
la victime est reine et les profondeurs
de la société ou au contraire en
fonction de ce pur de 7 ce sens profond
du pluralisme démocratique la discussion
est devenu beaucoup plus aisée qu'elle
ne l'était dans ma jeunesse par exemple
c'est donc on a une situation elle-même
ambiguë ce qui se passe en fonction de
cette relativisation du clivage entre la
droite et la gauche c'est que vous avez
d'un côté
une dépolitisation de jean-philippe
finalement si on est tous d'accord à
quoi bon s'occuper de tout ça puisque
finalement on va gérer un équilibre
précaire et puis vous avez de l'autre
côté des gens qui se refuse à cette
dépolitisation et qui au contraire sont
emportés dans un mouvement de rennes de
radicalisation de réaffirmation d'une
vraie gauche ou d'une vraie droite eu
des mots très typique du vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui qui elle retrouve avec un
sectarisme exacerber les valeurs
fondamentales avec lesquels on ne peut
pas transiger au point qu'il est
question d'interdire ce qui ne peut
interdire de parole ceux qui ne sont pas
dans le cercle de ses vraies valeurs
je vous propose maintenant marcel
gauchet d'accueillir l'invité qu'on n'a
pas pu inviter et s'est invitée c'est
l'historien allemand ernst kantorowicz
lequel a notamment écrit les deux corps
du roi les deux corps du roi c'est un
ouvrage qui est très souvent citée par
exemple quand françois hollande a fait
une petite promenade je crois en scooter
autour de l'elysée on a évoqué les deux
corps du roi l orsque emmanuel macron
est entré dans la cour du louvre au
moment de son élection on a parlé de là
aussi des deux corps du roi mais je
crois que très peu de gens ont lu les
deux corps du roi donc surtout si vous
ne l'avez pas lu rester avec nous que 10
ce livre et en quoi celui-ci permet est
il justement d'éclairer bien la
présidentielle française c'est à la fois
un livre très savant et un livre qui est
une oeuvre d'art que vous revendiquez
comme tel par l'auteur c'est à dire dont
l'interprétation est assez énigmatique
mais en même temps un livre qui met le
doigt sur une donnée transhistorique
pour ainsi dire de la du pouvoir qu'est
ce à double face tous les pouvoirs ont
toujours une double face la violence et
la paix
la sagesse et la capacité de
transgression et effectivement nous
voyons bien que ce qui est john son écot
prodigieux à ce livre peut lui parce
qu'il est très difficile à lire et à
comprendre c'est une étude historique
sur des représentations et des doctrines
médiévale que locataires des tudors ça
c'est le point de départ mais ensuite on
va plonger dans le moyen âge profond
jusqu'à haut
au cérémoniaux de charlemagne en quoi
c'est vraiment de la haute et rue lotois
mai mais c'est une érudition qui met le
doigt sur un point très peu compris et
dont on voit qu'il est toujours actuelle
car on né sait qu'après tout qu'y at il
de commun entre l'hérault entre les rois
de l'angleterre tudor hénault président
de la république aujourd'hui eh bien oui
il ya quelque chose comme 1 ils ont deux
corps un corps individuel ça gibb les
mortels et un corps politique un corps
politique qui fait qu'ils incarnent à
eux tous seuls dans leur personne là le
pays qui les a élus et avec la
difficulté de gérer l'articulation entre
ce corps publics pourrait-on dire et ce
corps privé qui se retrouvent à toutes
les étapes de leur de leurs exercée lors
les dés de cordes emmanuel macron les
deux cordes emmanuel macron ils sont
dans son discours il ya un emmanuel
macron solennelle qui affecte les
grandes envolées
visionnaire et un emmanuel macron qui
comme le dit on comme le dit dans son
dans son entourage pense tout haut lieu
de par se comprendre qu'ils s'adressent
à un public qui attend de la solennité
de son discours et il ya chez emmanuel
macron inde
c'est très intéressant car c'est
extrêmement perçue par l'opinion qu'il a
2 à des deux types d'adhésion très
différents ce qui aime l'homme privé qui
parlent librement qui dit ce qu'il pense
gaulois réfractaires
combien a encore récemment à propos du
pouvoir algérien mais il dit une vérité
oui en effet la rendent mémorielle la
rente mémorial il c'est un pouvoir
militaire qui vit sur la mémoire de la
libération de l'algérie mais dont
l'intérêt merci c'est plat les rayons de
la librairie n'est pas le souci c'est
pas la même chose dans les deux cas
pardonnez moi marseille c'est parce que
le dit les gaulois réfractaires ya
beaucoup de français qui n'ont pas été
satisfaits de cette phrase tandis que
j'arrange mémorielle jeune forêt on peut
discuter à l'infini sur le contexte de
chacune de ces propositions mais dans
les deux cas c'est des propos qui
transgressent parce que c'est l'homme
privé qui parle qui disent qu'ils
pensent à titre strictement individuel
alors qu'on attend d'un président de la
république qui tiennent un discours plus
ou moins convenue avec lequel le charme
des manuels macron indiscutable de
rompre bien qu'il en fasse beau ou des
tonnes aussi dans ce registre où il est
tendu entre deux d'entre deux pôles il a
bel et bien de corps en tout cas il a
deux paroles fait la transgression c'est
une donnée importante en france
récemment par exemple notre pays a rendu
hommage à bernard tapie qui était un
personnage transgressif eric zemmour
fait énormément parler de lui c'est un
autre personnage transgressif c'est
important la transgression en politique
ça c'est logique ça le devient c'est
fonction d'un contexte historique où
certaines questions très douloureuse est
très délicate parce qu'elle touche à la
dignité des personnes évidemment au
premier chef l'immigration sont devenues
très difficiles d'abord la difficulté de
ces sujets sur divers plans pratiques
moreau rend le la tendance à les
escamoter très forte et on regarde quoi
le la la transgression devient une prime
à celui qui ose la risqués et en ce sens
on peut rapprocher ça je ne sais pas par
exemple de la présidence de donald trump
oui je crois que le donald trump a donné
ce nom pas ses lettres de noblesse mais
il a fourni la preuve de l'efficacité de
la recette je pense qu'il aura de
nombreuses de nombreux imitateurs ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'à l'époque
c'est une époque que de la politique
vous êtes philosophe du politique dont
vous ne faites pas de la communication
politique mais donald labrie les livres
de communication politique qui les a
tous qui est innée et il a été élu n'a
pas été réélu il a trébuché sur locaux
vides est ce que ça veut dire qu'en
france on peut s'asseoir sur tous les
principes de communication politique et
accéder à la fonction suprême c'est ce
que nous allons voir
il faut se garder d' j'essayais d'avoir
un petit mais en tout cas moustiques en
tout cas la recette fonctionnelle il
faut dire puisque nous avons des
éléments de comparaison qu'elle
fonctionne différemment en france et aux
états unis nous évoquions le cas de
bernard tapie qui est très intéressant
il a transgressé sur un certain nombre
de plans en déclarant dans une société
catholique et où l'argent était un tabou
que évidemment qu'il fallait faire
fortune et c'était là l'objectif normal
de tout individu un tant soit peu
ambitieux c'était une transgression par
rapport à la culture ambiante de la même
façon je pense qu'on pourrait le croire
le montrait assez en détail par la façon
dont il a géré les affaires sportives
est mené l'olympique de marseille a une
triumph bien connu et il a su mettre en
scène une transgression des codes d'un
milieu très frileux et la transgression
était aussi dans le fait qu'un membre de
l'élite
qu'il en fût jamais s'intéresser au
sport le plus populaire verdier
on peut à chaque fois il faut
contextualiser la transgression pour
voir la transition de quoi il s'agit est
ce qu'elle signifie mais c'est quand
même assez curieux parce que on rend
hommage à bernard tapie pourtant si mes
souvenirs sont bons il n'a pas toujours
été complètement règle avec ses
différents actes fiscaux illégaux et
aujourd'hui on est intransigeant
vis-à-vis des hommes politiques
lorsqu'ils commettent des imprudences
fiscale de certains hommes politiques et
pas d'autres voilà ce qu'il faut
comprendre il ya ce que ça tue purement
et simplement et il ya ceux qui sont non
seulement s'en sortent très bien mais
qui on tire une sorte de gloriole
comment est il justement c'est un peu
mystérieux et sa demande en fait à
chaque fois une explication très très
circonstancié ça ne s'est pas une
recette infaillible qui veut dire que
n'importe quel l'hybride us sortie des
enfants ont
dépassé à bout peut devenir tout d'un
coup de la scène publique dont c'est
évidemment pas de ça qu'il s'agit mais
de d'une tactique
communicationnel qui n'a rien à voir
avec les recettes de la communication
politique qui permet à des personnages
parce qu'ils ont aussi une dimension il
faut un support il faut à vous il faut
des qualités
qui ne sont pas nécessairement dans la
nature et qu'on ne peut refuser
assurément pas à bernard tapie c'était
un homme hors du commun une force de la
nature pour commencer est évidemment que
là on voit bien qu'il y a des des
transgressions qui rendent invulnérable
ce qui les implique alors eric zemmour
l'une de ces transgressions c'est par
exemple de revisiter le passé français
et vous parliez du malheur français
marcel gauchet lui revisite par exemple
les heures sombres la seconde guerre
mondiale donne une vision où pétain le
golo pettini sme revient est ce que
c'est ça qui parle aux français
aujourd'hui non jaffa l'enjeu le
problème de ce type de discours n'est
pas de susciter la division c'est pas le
but c'est de montrer d'abord le courage
d'un individu qui c'est s'opposer à
l'opinion généralement admise et il en
faut dans le cas puisqu'il ya une sorte
de consensus appuyée en plus sur de
bonnes raisons la collaboration n'est
pas
près de qui que ce soit et d'ailleurs
eric zemmour justement il essaye de
sauver pétain de la collaboration c'est
très habile sont de son discours il ne
dit pas il fallait deux collaborateurs
dont et appuyer hitler dans ces
entreprises de l'empiré européen pour
quelqu'un qui se réclament de la nation
française c'est justement j'ai aimé il
il va dire il va dire ce qui est
d'ailleurs pas un argument nous
puisqu'il a été employée par les
défenseurs de pétain qu'au contraire
pétain a essayé de défendre la france et
il est vrai qu'en plus cela il s'appuie
sur un fond historique la thèse du
bouclier le bouclier est il s'appuie sur
un fond historique qui est aujourd'hui
disparu mais qui ya longtemps a pesé
c'est que pétain c'est l'homme de la
victoire de verna mais c'est pas rien
c'était l'homme qui a en quelque sorte
humaniser le comportement du
commandement militaire pendant cette
guerre terrible de 1914 1918 il a eu un
fils il ne t'a pas au hasard sur un un
clou choisi arbitrairement il ya quelque
chose qui réveille un fond historique
avec avec en plus
un vrai talent une vraie culture dont on
peut totalement discuter des conclusions
mais qui ne ce qui est réel sur le dur
le plan intellectuel la gauche peut-elle
être aujourd'hui transgressive marcel
gauchet elle l'a été c'est même son acte
de naissance elle s'est inscrite contre
l'ordre existant et maintenant elle est
l'ordre existant à beaucoup d'égards et
c'est tout son problème c'est nous
sommes en europe en particulier en gros
dans des sociétés social démocrate
qu'est ce que nous avons à faire de plus
que d'aménager cette social-démocratie
donc pas d'horizon est en revanche un
cadre installé que tout son passé lui
interdit de remettre en question
évidemment que c'est une des raison de
l'impasse des gauches européennes
aujourd'hui
des hauts et des bas qui tiennent aux
conjonctures électorat local c'est
qu'elle les en l'absence de projet et en
l'absence de démarquage vis-à-vis de
l'ordre existant ce qui était son arme
c'était son identité profonde donc dans
ces conditions est ce qu'on peut
imaginer je ne sais pas jean luc
mélenchon par exemple il est plutôt
transgressif non il n'est pas
transgressif il est excessif c'est très
différent il tire son discours vers la
surenchère qui est une voie de sortie de
semaine stream social démocrate mais qui
en réalité
ne fait que reconduire les prémices même
s'il donne une tonalité différente à
l'expression de cette identité politique
le fait que ni plus de projets
véritablement qui apparaissent qui n'y
ait plus de religion séculaire comme
disent les philosophes du politique
c'est à dire quelque chose qui suggère
le sacrifice de tous ce qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire est ce que c'est vraiment
la fin d'une époque une tâche est
complètement tournée marcel gauchet une
page est en train de se tourner oui
certainement nous sommes en train de
changer d'époque et bien malin qui
saurait dire comment
les choses vont tourner nous sommes dans
une situation assez semblable à celle en
fait des du début des années fin des
années 1970 début des années 1980 ou
dans une grande confusion et une grande
absence de discernement de tous les
acteurs mal premier que j étais
le monde a changé de face et bien je
crois que nous sommes devant une
métamorphose danoise il changé de face à
cette époque là nous sommes sortis du
d'un consensus qui est prévalait depuis
1945 sur le rôle des états dans la vie
collective oncle
dont la technocratie gaullienne en
france a été
modèle à une échelle rayonner sur le
monde l'oublié aujourd'hui et puis on a
vu sarah arrivée un la mondialisation
l'ouverture généralisée des sociétés les
unes sur les autres et 2
la signalisation du capitalisme avec
toutes les conséquences que ça a eu pour
les français très dramatique puisque ça
s'est traduit par une détente d
industrialisation dont nous voyons
aujourd'hui les effets politiques mais
alors est ce que l'on peut dire
politiquement de ce malheur français ou
est-ce que le malheur français c'est
justement de vouloir le guérir par le
biais du politique je crois au contraire
que peut-être les français retrouvent
une chance dans le contexte actuel de
renouer avec le ska et et le courant
dominant de leur histoire que
précisément toute cette période a mis
sur le côté le nous sommes à nouveau
dans une période où l'efficacité des
états va devenir le critère fondamental
dans un contexte international ultra
compétitive si ce n'est aux limites de
l'affrontement est aussi dans la gestion
interne des sociétés c'est la grande
leçon de ce qui s'est passé avec la
pandémie de la colline où on a vu que la
l'armature public était ce qui
permettait une société de fonctionner
dans un contexte qui aurait été
dramatique sans son concours et je crois
que nous revenons d'une manière très
différent de ce qu'a été la période
d'après guerre les priorités fait autres
vers quelque chose qui va nous permettre
peut-être aux français de sortir de ce
malaise profond qu'ils ont éprouvée dans
un contexte qui prenait à rebours tout
leur ont dit l'entité les plus enracinés
sur le plan politique à droite comme à
gauche merci beaucoup marcel gauchet
pour cet exposé très claire de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
pour le prolonger les deux livres de
notre invité la droite et la gauche
histoire et destin c'est aux éditions
gallimard et macron les leçons d'un
échec une conversation avec eric conan
françois azouvi aux éditions stock à
très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec france
culture et avec le soutien du centre
national du livre vous a présenté livres
et vous
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les vendredis de
l'histoire le documentaire karpov et
kasparov de roi pour une couronne
lorsque commence cette grande bataille
épique entre kasparov et karpov l'union
soviétique les déjà très essoufflée
kasparov aldeta des soutiens au centre
d'un empire soviétique moins puissant
que son capot fils à des fins soutien
des russes préfèrent que ce soit à
karpov qui reste champion du monde ça
c'est clair si j'avais gagné dans ma 31e
partie le match se serait terminé avec
le score de 6 à 0
je ne vais pas gagner j'ai perdu la 32e
j'ai joué de mieux en mieux et il
perdait son assurance c'est pour ça que
la nomenclature à sportive soviétique a
décidé d'arrêter le match
le match avec carpe a souhaité la lutte
entre le monde soviétique et la nouvelle
russie s'en servir et beaucoup de gens
l'ont compris comme ça
karpov et kasparov de roi pour une
couronne vendredi à 22h sur public sénat
qui sait
son internat
2 oui oui
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel
il y a des rendez vous à ne pas manquer
pour continuer à vous protéger penser
dès maintenant à votre dose de rappel
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public j'ai le
bonheur de vous donner rendez-vous tous
les jours pour 90 minutes de débat
d'actualité de réflexion notre promesse
et de donner du sens à l'actualité et
donner des clés de compréhension aux
citoyens
sens publiques présenté par thomas
hugues du lundi au jeudi à 18 heures et
à 22 heures sur public sénat
[Musique]
elle est entrée dans l'histoire en
devenant la première est encore
aujourd'hui la seule femme première
ministre de france elle est restée aux
commandes pendant presque onze mois sous
la présidence de françois mitterrand
entre 91 et 92 un moment de sa vie qu'on
lui rappelle systématiquement et qui
éclipse peut-être tout ce qu'elle a fait
par ailleurs son combat pour une europe
plus forte et plus solidaire par exemple
sa fondation qui a permis de créer des
dizaines d'écoles de la deuxième chance
sa mission d'élu local en tant que maire
de châtellerault pendant 14 ans les
arcanes du pouvoir elle les connaît par
coeur c'est une partie de son monde
depuis près de 60 ans elle va nous le
faire découvrir de l'intérieur bienvenue
dans un monde un regard bienvenus edith
cresson et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
c'est un peu vrai ce que je disais on
vous ramène systématiquement à cette
période de votre vie à cette courte
période vous avez été premier ministre
oui c'est le seul pays disons parmi les
pays comparables à la france ça se passe
comme ça il ya une femme premier
ministre portugal longtemps avant moi on
n'a pas posé des questions de ce genre
quand madame thatcher a été premier
ministre au royaume uni je sais pas je
sais bien que c'est pas la même le même
système parce que au royaume uni le
premier ministre est élu alors qu'en
france la constitution veut que le
premier ministre nommé par le président
n'empêche que j'avais été élu comme vous
l'avez rappelé le maire député
conseiller général j'avais été cinq fois
ministre et la seule chose dont on parle
encore maintenant la preuve c'est ça
donc quoi d'après vous non c
ceux spécifiquement français c'est un
phénomène spécifiquement en france
j'veux qu'on appelle le pouvoir entre
guillemets
appartenir sais pas pourquoi mais enfin
c'est comme ça et quand il ya une
exception à cette règle ça prend des
proportions extraordinaires j'ai tout
entendu sur ce sujet est encore la
preuve ça continue donc j'aimerais bien
qu'un jour les choses se normalisent que
la france soit comparable à ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays pays disons
comparable pays européens alors on n'a
jamais vu mais vous avez bien conscience
d'être encore aujourd'hui un symbole
pour beaucoup de femmes politiques aussi
puisque c'est à la fois un succès et
peut être un échec parce que ça a été
très bref et on va y revenir mais c'est
aussi un succès d'avoir été vous êtes
encore la salle aujourd'hui femmes
première mais je ne sais pas si c'est un
succès je sais que la seule chose que je
sais c'est que j'avais quitté le
gouvernement avant et j'avais créé une
entreprise c'était après la chute du mur
de berlin j'avais créé une entreprise
pour aider les entreprises françaises à
s'installer dans les pays de l'est
j'avais fait ça avec eux didier pineau
valencienne ça marchait très bien et
jusqu'au jour où françois mitterrand m'a
appelé pour me dire qu'il souhaitait que
je sois premier ministre j'ai commencé
par refuser j'ai dit non pourquoi parce
que j'avais pour moi c'était une page
qui est tournée
et je faisais des choses qui me semblait
utile ce qui m'intéresse dans la vie
c'est de faire quelque chose qui est des
résultats est premier ministre on n'est
pas utile
d'autres c'est pas qu'on n'est pas utile
c'est pas ça c'est qu'il y avait
beaucoup de concurrence c'est à dire que
tous ces messieurs voulait être premier
ministre surtout que c'était là le
deuxième mandat de françois mitterrand
c'était la deuxième partie du deuxième
mandat donc la pire période puisque on
s'acheminait vers la fin et tout ces
messieurs étaient enragés à l'idée que
ne serait pas premier ministre et qui
n'avais que ça en tête donc je savais
que j'aurai beaucoup d'ennemis à
l'intérieur et que ce serait extrêmement
difficile c'est pour ça que j'ai refusé
il a tellement insisté il était malade
est ce tu as donc j'ai fini par accepter
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir dû en
faire
plus que les autres et que notamment les
autres zones de vous et vous est
ressorti endurci de cette expérience un
dur sinon je crois pas mais parce que
c'est exactement ce que je pensais
qu'ils allaient se passer enfin pas à ce
point là pourquoi pas à ce point là
qu'est ce qui a été qu'est ce qu'il ya
des pauses dépasser votre votre image et
leur comportement la trahison permanente
le fait qui parlait aux journalistes
racontent des mensonges
c'était c'était terrible donc c'est vrai
que je savais que cela serait terrible
mais c'était encore pire que ce que je
pense vous parlez d'une expérience qui a
été difficile et on l'entend notamment
parce que vous étiez entouré d'hommes
qui voulaient votre poste qui ne voulait
pas d'une femme première ministre est ce
qu'à un moment donné vous vous ai
demandé si vous vous aviez peut-être
fait des choses avec maladresse avec une
est ce que vous aviez une part de
responsabilité dans le fait que ce soit
bref 11 mois ou que les choses se soient
mal passé oui certainement je dois faire
des maladresses calmer mais le problème
n'est pas là je suis pas la seule donc
pour une femme on pardonne absolument
rien et on invente surtout des choses
qui sont totalement fausses on m'a prêté
des propos que je n'avais jamais te dis
qu'est ce que vous auriez malfait vous
pensez à quelque chose quand je vous
demande si est un je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas certainement j'ai dû faire des
choses que dire des choses qu'il fallait
pas mais
on ne s'occupe pas si vous voulez les
journalistes surtout mais ils étaient
amis certains journalistes sont amis
avec des hommes politiques et marchent
ensemble et donc
ce que je faisais du tilt n'était jamais
on n'en parlait jamais donc on cherchait
toujours les choses négatives c'est
quand on cherche entre edith cresson
comment vous y est devenu à la politique
comment l'étudiante à hec que vous étiez
se décide un jour à se dire tiens je
vais y aller je vais me lancer moi aussi
mais là c'est très simple quand j'ai
fait hec j'avais une amie qui s'appelle
paulette de craine et dont le père était
un ami de françois mitterrand et elle
m'a raconté que pendant la guerre quand
elle était petite un jour on sonne à la
porte elle va ouvrir et elle voit un
jeune homme qui lui dis à ton père que
françois morland et la mort lente ce
descendant de résistance et donc
après hec elle a travaillé avec lui et
c'est elle qui m'a fait venir qui m'a
dit tu devrais venir c'est intéressant
ça s'était longtemps avant 81 et je
travaillais au parti socialiste j'étais
chargé la jeunesse des étudiants
et j'ai beaucoup appris donc ça m'a
intéressé ensuite on m'a envoyé à
châtellerault qui était réputée
imprenable
on va y venir à cette expérience d'élu
local mais peut-être j'ai lu vous allez
me dire si je me trompe ou pas j'ai lu
que c'était aussi un discours de pierre
mendès france sur la jeunesse qui vous
avez décidé qu'ils vous qui vous avaient
motivé pour entrer en politique c'est
vrai ou pas une figure important que
j'avais beaucoup d'admiration pour
pierre mendès france c'est vrai oui
pourquoi qu'est ce qui fait que ces
données selon lui qui vous ait des
sources plusieurs raisons d'abord parce
qu'il s'intéressait à l'économie il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui
s'intéresse vraiment à l'économie qu'il
avait beaucoup de bon sens il me
semblait être qu' il est très courageux
ah oui j'avais de l'admiration dans le
parler des chaussées vont parler
d'économie se sont pas forcément les
sujets qu'on traite à la gauche pourquoi
le parti socialiste oui mais ça compte
l'économie on le vit aujourd'hui bien
sûr donc il ya toute une mode dans la
classe dominante
politique française pendant très
longtemps par exemple on disait que
l'industrie c'est fini je pas si vous
vous souvenez l'industrie c'est fini
maintenant c'est les services les
complètement idiot parce que chaque
emploi industriel créé trois emplois de
service et puis s'il ya pas de
l'industrie n'y a pas de recherche on ne
progresse pas et aujourd'hui on est dans
une phase de révolution industrielle
totale et si on est mauvais dans ce
domaine là il est évident qu'on peut pas
exister et on existe dans le rapport de
force internationale que quand on a une
certaine puissance économique 11 ans à
cette expérience d'élu local que dont je
parlais en introduction
maire de tueur est d'abord puis de
châtellerault
1977 puis 1983 6 ans puis 14 ans
d'expérience c'est pas rien comment
s'est passé comment la greffe a pu
prendre à l'époque on aurait pu parler
de parachutage peut-être même qu'on a
parlé de parachutage et finalement la
grèce va prendre oui oui bien sûr c'est
ce qu'on appelle un parachutage ma foi
je n'étais pas la seule et quand je suis
arrivé à châtellerault j'ai été séduite
par cette ville c'est une ville ouvrière
c'est la région qui pendant la guerre a
été la plus résistante dans l'ouest de
la france il ya une manufacture d'armes
et il y avait une population ouvrière
très très intéressante est d'ailleurs la
première fois que je me suis présenté à
l'élection le maire de la ville
monsieur la blinde père je l'ait battu
sur sa ville de châtellerault pas dans
l'ensemble l'assurance fluctuant du
premier coup mais je les battues sur sa
ville donc je me suis dit il ya quelque
chose à faire ici et j'ai eu un
sentiment
j'ai pas de d'affection vis-à-vis de
cette ville sa population vous avez été
vous même surprise par ce sentiment que
c'était pas votre univers s'était pas
aux milieux vous y connaissez pas du
tout chapellan je savais à peine où
c'était et quand on m'a envoyé là
effectivement j'ai eu comme une espèce
de révélations ça m'a beaucoup touché
qu'est ce qui vous est touché chez eux
le courage de ces gens
cette population ouvrière
qui était très impliqué
qui s'intéressait à la politique qui
était plutôt évidemment plutôt de gauche
et
des gens très courageux vous savez à
poitiers était une ville
universitaire on dit chatellerault c'est
une ville ouvrière avec un petit peu de
distance moi je disais je suis très fier
d'être le maire de lille aurélien et
j'ai beaucoup aimé élire une femme n'a
semble-t-il pas été un problème pour eux
pas un sujet à aucun moment de cette
expérience d'élu local on vous a renvoyé
au fait que vous étiez une femme et que
peut-être vous étiez moins compétente
qu'un homme absolument pas alors à la
différence de la classe politique à
châtellerault ça n'a posé absolument
aucun problème jamais jamin ça poserait
plus de problème à paris et la dernière
femme renaître une femme achète vous
savez quand une femme arrive à
l'assemblée nationale vous savez bien
comment ils sont il insulte enfin c'est
à tel point que
l'actuel président de l'assemblée
nationale après une décision c'est à
dire ceux qui l'insultent les femmes on
va leur prendre la moitié de la
rémunération du mois suivant cette
relation vous avez à paris m'intéressent
j'ai envie de creuser un tout petit peu
parce que vous avez été aussi celle qui
a décidé de transférer l'ena à
strasbourg c'est à dire que vous avez
été dans cette démarche de
décentralisation
cette démarche de décentralisation comme
vous dites elle était dans le programme
comme un peu la gauche et il n'y a pas
que les normands de l'ena mais il ya eu
des dizaines et des dizaines
d'administration qui ont été
décentralisés
parce que y'a pas de raison que tout
soit à paris et il faut aussi que
d'abord ça irrigue le
le tissu local et puis les gens adhèrent
mieux à l'administration dont il voit
effectivement les membres donc c'était
dans le programme commun de la gauche et
donc je n'ai fait qu'appliquer le
programme et parmi toutes ces
décentralisations j'avais effectivement
l'ena pourquoi strasbourg l2 strasbourg
est une ville symbolique très belle
d'ailleurs qui est un symbole dans
l'histoire française et d'autre part
parce que le parlement européen siège
partiellement strasbourg bas je pensais
que ces jeunes saurait comme sa
familiariser avec une réalité locale et
européenne ou le dit peu et les français
le savent peu mais votre monde c'est
aussi et c'est même surtout j'ai envie
de dire l'europe j'ai retrouvé
évidemment votre discours de politique
générale du 22 mai 81 11 vous faites de
l'europe une priorité pour vous il
fallait et je vous cite faire réussir la
france dans l'europe de 1993 et dans le
monde l'an 2000 est-ce qu'elle a
finalement réussi cette europe
cette france dans l'europe partiellement
mais c'était l'objectif en tout cas de
françois mitterrand est d'ailleurs de
ses prédécesseurs aussi un le construire
l'europe la france seule évidemment pèse
mais pas suffisamment et la construction
européenne a été poursuivi par tous les
présidents de la république et françois
mitterrand lui a fait franchir une étape
supplémentaire avec le traité de
maastricht qui développait les
politiques communes dans beaucoup de
domaines beaucoup de domaines différents
par exemple domaine éducatif avec le
programme erasmus qui permet à des
étudiants de circuler en toute l'europe
de connaître mieux leurs homologues et
puis
pour françois mitterrand c'était
effectivement un objectif majeur et je
peux le comprendre
pour la france c'est très important
c'est pour ça que c'est toujours un peu
difficile parce qu'il ya quelquefois des
décisions qui se prennent à l'unanimité
quelquefois des pays comme actuellement
certains pays à l'est
qui sont un peu réticents et l'est
encore cohérente cette europe est ce
qu'elle est la cohérence que vous
souhaitiez cette europe quand on voit
effectivement des vrais contradictions
des vrais pays qui parfois ne partagent
même plus nos valeurs effectivement je
pense à la pologne je pense à la hongrie
elle marcherait europe elle fonctionne
pour vous oui elle marche mais ça n'est
pas facile je pense que peut-être
faudrait-il sur certains objectifs se
limiter à quelques pays peut-être pas
avec tout le monde c'est à dire d'abord
cessé d'élargir l'europe et est ce qu'on
l'a trop élargi cette europe elle est
élargie pour une raison objective ces
pays sont européens et par ailleurs
certains pays de l'est sont entrés
peut-être un peu rapidement dans l'union
européenne c'est le chant c'est l'école
qu'il souhaitait ça
et je me souviens que au moment où on a
discuté de la monnaie unique qui est
quand même un symbole très important
françois mitterrand voulait la monnaie
unique et les allemands ils savaient
qu'ils étaient réticents parce qu'il
tenait aux marques qui est menée très
fort très fort et donc
ce moment-là et françois mitterrand a
demandé à col de ne pas faire voter les
allemands sur la monnaie unique parce
qu'ils savaient qu'ils voteraient contre
et cole en a profité en disant oui je
laisserai pas voter sur la monnaie
unique mais
je voudrais que les pays de l'est de
l'europe en tout de suite en or ces pays
n'était pas prêt du tout et pourquoi est
ce qu'il le voulait c'est parce que
c'était des sous traitants pour
l'industrie allemande des sous traitants
relativement bon marché il y avait un
calcul est là oui il y avait
actuellement alors c'était donnant
donnant françois mitterrand et bien sûr
cela laisse tout ça et il a accepté donc
c'est vrai que ces pays à cause de ça
sont en train un peu rapidement dans
l'union européenne ll vous inquiète
cette europe aujourd'hui
on peut se poser des questions oui mais
enfin il faut continuer il faut essayer
de la fortifier et on voit bien
aujourd'hui les états unis la chine
bon mais ce sont des pays unique
avec plusieurs pays c'est toujours plus
difficile c'est pour ça que je pense que
dans certains domaines peut-être
faudra-t-il faire des accords sur des
points limitées est-ce que parmi les
sujets qui nous préoccupent il ya
l'environnement je vous pose la question
parce que là aussi dans ce discours de
politique générale de 1991 vous dit la
notion d'environnement ne doit plus
rester extérieur au processus de
production mais s'y intégrer là on est
en 1991 ce sont des phrases qu'on entend
encore aujourd'hui ça veut dire que vous
avez presque été visionnaire en disant
191 mais ça veut dire aussi que c'est
toujours pas fait non bien sûr mais
c'est un grand regret ce travail mais
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours été
sensible aux problèmes d'environnement
et à l'intérieur du parti socialiste
j'étais chargé de l'agriculture
avant avant la création du parti
socialiste elle est là parce qu'on
appelle la convention des institutions
républicaines et gt
chargé de l'agriculture et de
l'environnement donc ça veut dire que
c'est une préoccupation qui même avant
81 habitaient déjà ce qui constituerait
plus tard le parti social vous étiez
seul à penser à l'environnement chantier
seul ou pas c'est un combat qui
paraissait non je ne me sentais pas
seule la preuve c'est que
j'avais ce titre donc c'est accepter par
l'ensemble des parties oui sauf que
parfois il ya des titres qui sont
honorifique mais qui ne servent pas à
grand chose et ça c'était peut-être
moins évident qu'aujourd'hui mais
c'était quand même des jeunes
préoccupations qu'il existait le
sélectif et comment vous la voyez cette
question aujourd'hui alors qu'elle est
devenue majeure elle est majeure c'est
très difficile heureusement que les
états unis maintenant un peu évolué mais
depuis trump qui niait l'existence de ce
problème mais c'est sûr qu'il faut s'y
atteler d'une façon
très très sérieuse est un problème
extrêmement difficile parce qu'on
connaît mal
les effets
de certaines décisions et donc il faut
apporter une attention à mon avis encore
plus grande à ces problèmes
d'environnement aujourd'hui par niveau
qu'on gagne aussi ces écoles de la
deuxième chance est ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler vous auriez aimé vous
avoir une deuxième chance c'est pour ça
que vous savez moi je veux dire des
séquelles de la deuxième chance sont
faites pour les jeunes qui n'ont rien
appris à l'école
et donc il y en a beaucoup j'ai vu
beaucoup de jeunes sortis
de leur période scolaire ils savaient à
peine lire bon donc quand j'étais à la
commission à bruxelles j'ai fait un
groupe de travail et on a décidé le
faire les écoles de la deuxième chance
c'est à dire des écoles où pourrait
aller les jeunes qui n'ont rien appris
ou d'une période qui peut durer de six
mois un an avec des stages en entreprise
on réussir est alors faire obtenir les
les données de base lire écrire compter
et puis un peu de connaissance du monde
économique et
j'ai réussi à ce que le parlement
européen vote
cette décision
cette décision était assorti d'un budget
qui était attribué un chacun des pays de
l'union européenne les autres pays je
leur ai donné l'argent mais pour la
france je les gardais en disant je vais
le faire moi-même parce que si je donne
ça l'administration ça va être mort et
donc je cherchais une municipalité que
ça intéresse j'ai trouvé marseille et le
maire de marseille monsieur gaudin était
très intéressé par le sujet et je lui ai
donc donné l'argent pour le prototype
puisque cet argent était destiné à faire
un prototype de ces écoles dans tous les
pays il a eu son école gratuite et à
cause de ça grâce à cela j'ai pu faire
venir des municipalités de partout pour
voir comment ça fonctionnait et donc
beaucoup d'autres villes ont créé des
écoles de la deuxième chance et
qu'aujourd'hui il y en a évidemment
beaucoup il ya peu près 16 ou 18 mille
jeunes parents qui passent par ces
écoles et avec un résultat positif à
plus de 70% edith cresson d'un petit
rituel dans cette émission c'est ce
qu'on appelle ou ce qu'on va après la
séquence photo j'ai plusieurs photos à
vous montrer vous allez me dire laquelle
vous avez envie de commenter
dans un premier temps j'ai celle ci avec
simone veil et jacques chirac j'ai aussi
celle ci avec françois mitterrand vous
lui souffler à l'oreille peut-être allez
vous nous dire ce que vous lui souffre
lié à l'oreille à l'époque et j'ai aussi
celle ci à vous proposer ce sont trois
de vos ministres des figures politiques
absolument majeur encore aujourd'hui que
vous avez vous même lancé j'allais dire
dans l'arène politique et peut-être que
vous en tirez une certaine fierté
laquelle avez vous envie de commenter
dans un premier temps peut-être celle
avec simone veil
elles sont toutes intéressantes
effectivement simone veil gelé connu
c'est une femme remarquable
très intéressante première présidente du
parlement européen
très discrète j'étais au parlement
européen quand elle était présidente et
enfin c'est toute une histoire je veux
dire toute une légende si on veut donc
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie et d'amitié
pour simone weill est d'adresser des
bonnes relations oui une très très bonne
relation très bonnes relations vous
diriez qu'elle a été un modèle qu'on
aime part d'une certaine façon et elle a
été un modèle je peux pas me comparer
mais c'était une femme du fait de
l'expérience terrible qu'elle a eu dans
sa jeunesse
je crois qu'on sorte de cette épreuve
certainement tout à fait différent donc
ça ne peut pas comparer avec les 20 qui
n'a pas connu ça une femme politique
aussi qui a oeuvré
peut-être un modèle en politique
absolument une deuxième photo alors elle
et elle est intéressante cette photo
elle nous a paru à la fois sympathique
et peut-être avec un certain sens vous
aviez l'oreille attentive de françois
mallinjoud parle à l'oreille peut-être
que là des gens et je souhaite pas
qu'ils entendent enfin avant c'est sûr
vous vous cachez vous lui souffre liés à
l'eau règne souvent vous aviez vous
pouviez lui confier des choses lui
conseiller des choses il vous écoutait
il était attentif à ce que will
écouteurs il était attentif à tous les
gens qui avaient parlé et ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils faisaient toujours scandé le
conseil mais oui oui il était très
attentif et là aussi quelles étaient vos
rapports
vous entendiez bien humainement vous
étiez lucie de l'un et l'autre sur la
raison pour laquelle il vous avez nommé
premier ministre
c'était france était dit rien c'est à
dire que quand il m'a nommé premier
ministre dans la discussion que nous
avons eue il m'a dit je veux qu'une
femme était premier ministre avant la
fin de mon mandat et je n'ai dit
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu y penser
plus tôt parce que la deuxième partie de
deuxième mandat
c'est la pire période évidemment parce
qu'ils sont tous à vouloir la place et
puis le président - d'autorité dans la
fin du placement là surtout qu'en plus
ils étaient très malades donc
je le dis ça et il a senti vos
difficultés ce que vous étiez
misogynie à ce sexisme auxquels vous
étiez qu'on a on est là senti
l'ascension en parlant des journalistes
qu'ils mentaient comme il pouvait il dit
ne vous lâcheront jamais
ils le savent est facile à sous-estimer
le côté machiste à la fois de la classe
politique et journalistique parce que ça
marche ensemble
et voici donc ces trois ministres ces
trois personnes qui ont été dans votre
gouvernement dominique strauss kahn
martine aubry jean yves le drian vous
ressentez une certaine fierté de les
avoir lancés de voir qu'ils sont encore
importants absolument donner c'est moi
qui ait réussi à faire nommer martine
aubry dominique strauss kahn le drian
s'est pas uniquement moi je t'adore
françois mitterrand l'avait eu dans
l'idée mais
ça n'a pas été simple d'imposer martine
aubry par exemple si sa vie est très
facile
il ne connaissait pas mais enfin je lui
ai expliqué qu'ils s'étaient parce
qu'elles travaillent avec moi déjà
j'avais chez des groupes de travail
quand j'étais ministre des affaires
européennes pour réfléchir aux affaires
européennes et j'avais fait venir des
gens d'un peu partout avec une certaine
expérience pour me conseiller on avait
des groupes de travail on travaille
ensemble elle en faisait partie et
j'avais je l'avais remarqué
à cette occasion et donc qu'est-ce que
vous aimiez chez elle son sérieux sens à
ta rigueur voilà une très grande rigueur
beaucoup de sérieux beaucoup de
conviction aussi beaucoup de sagesse on
a une autre séquence dans cette dans
cette émission c'est la séquence
archives puisque les archives nationales
nous font le bonheur chaque semaine de
nous transmettre sinon un original ou
moins une copie d'un document historique
on a pensé à celui ci pour vous
et là vous êtes avec boris elstine c'est
une photo prise à l'occasion d'un
déjeuner en l'honneur du président de la
fédération de russie en est alors en
1992 vous êtes aux côtés de roland dumas
ministre des affaires étrangères à quoi
vous pensez à ce moment là qu est ce qu
elle vaut pour vous cette photo
les liens avec la russie oui je pense
que nous devons avoir des liens avec la
russie quel que soit ce qu'on peut
éventuellement reprocher le gouvernement
russe
je pense que surtout depuis la chute du
mur de berlin depuis la fin d'après dire
de l'union soviétique
la russie traditionnellement est une
alliée de la france et je pense que
c'est une erreur de sous-estimer
l'importance de la russie dans la
configuration mondiale les états unis la
chine l'europe avec toutes les
difficultés qu'on a puisque c'est pas un
seul pays il faut arriver à s'entendre
et nous devons tendre la main on a bien
la russie même avec
russie avec un vladimir poutine aux
commandes ont elles mêmes avec poutine
devant à mon avis c'est la russie cet
angle les russes c'est un très grand
peuple
qui a évolué en dehors du système
mondial à cause du système communiste
mais quand on va en russie
et moi j'y suis allé souvent
on est surpris par
le niveau ces gens par les scientifiques
remarquables des artistes magnifique une
vie intellectuelle intéressante et je
pense que dans ce qui se passe
actuellement encore une fois avec les
états unis la chine l'europe devrait
avoir des liens avec la russie un mot de
roland dumas qui est aussi à vos côtés
ce jour là là aussi une personnalité
politique qui vous a marqué
pour l'heure du mans fin j'en ai pas de
très bonnes relations avec lui pourquoi
c'était quelqu'un
enfin c'était très difficile très
difficile quand j'étais ministre des
affaires européennes déjà il était
ministre des affaires étrangères et
[Musique]
ses collaborateurs de ne pas donner
d'informations donc une raison pour
laquelle j'ai quitté le gouvernement
et puis après il a fait deux trois coups
qui est
c'était très difficile de s'entendre
avec lui c'était quelqu'un qui
travaillait surtout pour lui-même est ce
que vous êtes une des rares ministres à
avoir démissionné effectivement c'est
une extrêmement bas il avait un problème
avec vous en particulier
il avait un problème avec tous les gens
dont il pensait qu' il pouvait empiéter
sur son territoire dans les affaires
européennes
considérer que ça faisait partie des
affaires étrangères et donc
je n'avais pas d'informations il avait
interdit à son cabinet nous donner des
informations donc c'était très difficile
un drôle de monde en ce monde politique
tels que vous les décrivez un monde
difficile très difficile
c'est un milieu où à part certaines
exceptions il a quand même ses
acceptions heureusement mais les gens
ont tendance à travailler pour eux mêmes
edith cresson une dernière question qui
est en lien avec ce lieu magnifique dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues il
représente 4 ils sont magnifiques la
sagesse la prudence
la justice est derrière moi l'éloquence
est ce qu'il ya une de ses vertus qui
vous parle plus que les autres dans
laquelle vous vous reconnais que la
justice pourquoi pas parce que
c'est un élément très important ce très
difficile
de définir ce qu'est la justice mais
c'est que
chacun soit reconnu en fonction de ce
qu'il est réellement et non pas en
fonction de ce qu'on raconte sur lui et
je pense que la justice est une vertu
fondamentale
il a changé depuis que sa place de jouer
son rôle
d'exister et qui est pas c'est le
contraire de cette pièce de mépris que
l'on rencontre assez souvent quand vous
parlez on a l'impression que vous parlez
aussi un peu de votre parcours à vous on
a été injuste avec vous vous auriez vous
avez été victime dune nombre
d'injustices c'est arrivé je suis pas la
seule je prenais ça va merci infiniment
ritz et le cresson d'avoir été avec nous
dans ce grand entretien sur public sénat
merci nous avons livré un peu de votre
monde est un peu de votre regard sur le
monde merci à vous merci c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
il faisait durer
[Musique]